foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
okay
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
relax
ing
[Music]
foreign
questions
[Music]
foreign
chess rapid and today we will revisit
the 2018 World Championship encounter as
Fabiano caruana takes on Magnus Carlson
in a four-game mini-match in the
Winner's semi-finals it's world number
one versus World number three it's going
to be a big fight welcome everyone to
the Champions chess tour
I thought we played the free move oh my
God
now he's sitting there trying to figure
this out so it doesn't happen again
push him baby go for the attack hey Ryan
I mean that King scored a guy oh there
it is
everything and that's it wins the match
against Wesley so what a performance
this was
it's The Clash of the Titans and the
winner semi-final took before that four
players face elimination among staff
Wesley saw fighting to stay in the game
and to guide us all through every move
in the studio Grandmaster David Howell
Simon Williams and Danny Ranch Danny
what was the big highlight for you from
your first day in the studio wow so many
highlights a lot of people played really
well but I'm gonna go with Notre back's
comeback against Wesley I think anytime
you get Armageddon that's got to be the
highlight of the day that you remember
right
absolutely and that went down to the
wire but not event it was super
convincing there Simon we got a glimpse
of the form the players are in who
impressed you the most
I have well Magnus as always I mean he
won with this weird A6 move this really
irregular opening I love seeing some
crazy openings being played um I don't
know if he's going to do it today uh
also aronian I thought aronium was very
very good chess wise he was playing
fantastic chess nice ideas and seemed to
be just on top form absolutely and the
other player who played fantastic chess
on day one not about winning that Army
Garden as you mentioned Danny against
Wesley so David how did naughty back
make it look so easy well Nutter back
just has great nerves it was uh kind of
a clutch match that one where another
Beck he was up against it he needed to
win the final rapid game with black
nobody can Bank on that against Wesley
so but he did it he managed it and in
the Armageddon he was just a class apart
so it's nerves combined with fantastic
chess and uh he's one to watch he's
really informed this season on the
Champions chess tour one of the biggest
comebacks we saw on day one by another
bag he's already won one event the
chesuke cup can he do it again and going
into day two we still have our eight
players in action but two will be
eliminated later today we will have the
winner semi-final not about taking on
love on our onion and of course the big
match as Fabiano caruana faces Magnus
Carlsen but we'll start the day with the
losers round one Wesley so against
feather save italyzaga against Jordan
van forest for these players it is their
final strike it's go big or go home they
either win continuing the loser's
bracket or it's the end of the road
Simon who do you think has the nerves to
face that pressure
well I think Wesley so has to be
favorite depends if he can play better
today of course and I think the other
match is going to be very close at she
so we had Eduardo who qualified in a
very tense situation he played great to
do that so we know he's good under
pressure and uh he's playing against
Jordan I guess on paper Jordan is a
favorite but that could go either way I
feel wow Wesley so really wants that
ticket to the season final
and he is one of the strongest players
on the planet but he was super shaky
yesterday Danny yeah it wouldn't feel
right not to have Wesley in the final it
seems that way anyway but the truth is
if the Wesley so of yesterday shows up
today he's probably going home and gonna
have to look for one of the remaining
two events to get there because Wesley
so was was great the first half and then
beat himself and we know Wesley can
struggle at times depending on whether
his his head or mind is in the right
place so we'll see if it's the Wesley so
of old or the the so-so so so so Wesley
so we saw yesterday
David we start with
is there a favorite in both these
matches well I'm going to say that
Wesley will bring out his best today it
feels like yesterday was just a wake-up
call and I'm gonna disagree actually uh
with Simon I'm going to say Jordan to
bank it against uh I just feel that
Jordan he's just had a great year and uh
he's looking Sharp
looking sharp he did lose his match in
three games yesterday we will see what
happens as two players will be
eliminated in division one meanwhile
some big names have been knocked out of
division three and day one was a day of
brilliant season blunders in division
two
division two of the aim chess rapid
brought a series of positional action in
an absolute Battle of a match Grand
Master David paravian faced five-time
Argentine Champion Diego Flores with a
couple draws and traded wins it was tied
going into the final game after a
blunder with Bishop D6 by Flores
haravian found the brilliant EP takes E6
a few moves later haravian found another
brilliant move adding a piece to the
attack also causing Flores to lose a
minor piece from there it was only a
matter of time in another matchup Dennis
lazovic put on a stellar performance
against former Junior world champion
Parham mugsudlu at the end of the game
lazovic created an incredible Force
mating sequence to take home the victory
take a look at the full bracket for
division 2 in division 3 to see where
your favorite player ended up after day
one
[Music]
and there is in the other two divisions
also heats up and keeping us up to date
with all the action in the studio woman
Grandmaster caddy satsana chivali Gary
what a dramatic day of Chess that was
what was the highlight for you in
division two we had a hero of a day Jose
Martinez from Peregrine master from Peru
who made three brilliant moves three
night sacrifices and he won the match
then in the end of the day he tweeted
that he is happy to be able to play
quality chess from time to time but he's
a streamer he streams a lot of events
and his viewers know that he plays a lot
of quality chess
that's exactly what he needs to continue
keep up with the quality and maybe bring
in some more of those night sacrifices
there's so much on the line for these
Players Tour points prize money and the
big ticket to division one of the next
Champions chest Star Event Getty we've
got big pairings coming up which is the
match up for you oh it's gonna be
definitely buy against Martinez these
two names I think we might are looking
now the winner of the second division
maybe yes maybe no we're gonna know that
but I'm Gonna Keep the eye on this match
and we see so many young stars and
prodigies in that in that list there's
Dan
lazulu samayam in the mix what does this
division do and winning it what would it
mean for their career atania they're
hungry they are the average of these
players is 22 years some of them are a
bit younger and they are so hungry to
win the tournaments to beat the super
Grand Masters and for them this is a
chance and this is a challenge and I
think they are going to take it the
chance for these young prodigies to find
themselves with the big boys in the next
Champions Chester event but it's not
just division two action is on in
division three as well Getty who was at
the player of the day for you there the
player of a day was crumbling no it's
saying he blundered he plundered so
badly well fresenio was their player
every day he played this incredible move
with the Knights attacked the queen and
Eric at the same time this Knight can be
captured by Florida birds two pieces but
he cannot actually stand in this game
and he lost the first game and now he's
playing in the losers bracket the Ron
Fraser is having quite the run in the
planes he takes down Magnus Carlsen and
now winning in Grand style against the
14th World Champion Vladimir kramnik and
some big matchups today which one are
you going to be keeping a close eye on
I'm gonna keep my eyes on Christian and
marmadov because these two are such a
stylish just play players they do like
tactics they do like sacrifices and I
think that's gonna be a huge Clash it's
going to be a fun day of Chess in all
these three divisions and for full
coverage of division two and three you
can go to chess.com event also follow
chess dojo's twitch Channel throughout
the week for all the action from these
uh from division two and division three
there is a lot at stake for players
fighting in the aim chess rapid and day
one was Top Class chess and a lot of fun
he does repeat with the knight and king
and that's all that he has to do right
will this be the fourth draw right now
Jordan seems to be there but not anymore
he blundered his Knight he walked his
Knight into a trap because the night
guards before the night guards do you
know what he just never bet against
Magnus 96 can be seven and then oh can
be seven the knights out of squares oh
my God
and this is how it's done yeah I mean Mr
Carlson strikes again
whoa what is this I did not see this
move wow right now it looks like Levon
is about to wrap this up his last move
Rook H5 he's cashing in now
I was having to perform some uh real uh
tightrope walking just to survive but it
looks like white walls well wait hold on
no resigns Brooke takes G4 check I'm
gonna stick to this one for 15 seconds
four photos yeah he gives up the queen
and that's it finally it does resign I
think quite a lot of danger here
that move is because now you can now you
push Harry it's almost Harry isn't it
got the F7 Pawn this has been Domination
by NADA back managed to avoid the losers
bracket the entire chess kid Cup on his
way to winning he barely might be
avoiding the losers bracket today three
pieces attacking free it's like the
magic number it's got to be a Checkmate
right I mean that King has got to go oh
there is oh my god did he just miss that
oh my God you missed everything and
that's it takes the Armageddon wins the
match against Wesley so what a
performance this was
and we start the day with losers round
one on day two of the aim chest rapid
Wesley saw taking on Vladimir Fellowship
Eduardo terizaga will play against
Jordan one forest for all these players
they are on their final strike later
today we've got another back up the
satrobe against love on aronia and hand
the big match that we're all very
excited about Fabiano caruana against
Magnus Carlsen two players with a very
rich history and yesterday on day one
both of them won their matches in just
three games David how close are you
expecting this one to be I think it's
going to go down to the wire Tanya I
can't separate these two right now
historically ever since the 2018 World
Championship match the playoffs there
Magnus has had the advantage in Rapid
chess but fabi's been improving fabi's
been fighting back and yeah it's uh it's
hard to cool recent history says that
Favi may be playing better he did beat
Magnus in Zagreb just a few days ago of
course Magnus would go on a tear right
after that and ultimately win the event
but I agree I think that Fabiano playing
very well maybe as well as anybody right
now in the 2023 Champions chest door
he's been to two finals and I don't
think he goes into this match against
Magnus not thinking that he he's maybe
the favorite too so we'll see
and Simon they've been Rivals for a
really long time but their biggest
moment was the 2018 World Championship
match it went down to the Y it went down
to the playoffs and there we see Fabiano
caruana as the runner-up as he lost in
the rapid playoff and Magnus Carlson
taking his fort World Championship now
back then it was clear he felt his best
chance isn't speed chess he forced the
playoff went into tie break but he can't
be feeling all that confident today
I mean that world championship match was
just so close it was really nail biting
throughout and it did come down to the
rapid where uh it has to be said Magnus
dominated that rapid but uh Fabiano's
got so much better and uh he's a great
player so I think there could be an
upset here I think one thing's for sure
we saw Magnus playing this A6 move it's
a bit of a weird move that one the Saint
George I think is called but will he
play that against the great Fabiano I
mean I don't know would you reckon guys
it'd be really Brave in the studio I
would be shocked if we see Magnus
playing Asics against Bobby but I've
been shocked to see him playing against
A6 against anybody I also want to
quickly shout out the other matchup of
course of Dosa Torah versus Iranian
aronian maybe playing the best yes of
anyone yesterday so we are in store for
a treat we've got two epic matches
happening in the winners bracket and uh
I'm excited super excited for the winner
semi-final but before that we've got
action coming up in the losers round one
one big matchup between Jordan van
forest and iterizaga both these players
lost their matches on day one in just
three games but italyzaga he's such a
dangerous player and we did see exactly
what he's capable of in the speed chess
format in the playoffs when it went down
to the wire against Parham maksudlu it
broke the internet
foreign
[Laughter]
[Music]
well I don't know what was crazy the
reaction that we had from itri Saga or
the commentary that we just saw
commentary is so great and I don't mean
any disrespect to any of us and
everyone's doing a great job
commentating but I love I love the
energy that those guys bring they bring
it every time and uh ichirisago's
reaction matched it we've got to try
commentating like that today which
reckon guys
um should we give it a go now
[Music]
that took a lot of energy that did
the first time to bring in all the
energy and the losers round one as four
players face elimination and this is the
format in the loser's bracket it is
going to be a best of two unlike the
Winner's bracket where they've got a
best of four so just two games one and a
half points is the minimum margin again
the players get 15 minutes with only
three seconds additional with every move
that they make if the match ends in a
1-1 die we will have the winning
Armageddon and the winner of the match
stays on in the losers bracket while it
will be go home end of the road for the
player who loses the match this is their
last strike they've got to be feeling
the pressure right now
they got to be the pressure's on Wesley
so uh again I'm a big Wesley so fan and
known him forever so I'm a fan of the
Wesley so we normally see and and right
now but what what's up yeah I was just
saying Simon room game expert there
that's a shift from where Wesley was
playing yesterday it is yeah I mean
maybe he just felt that room was giving
some bad karma bad vibes bit of bad five
should I need to change rooms change it
up a little bit uh maybe it doesn't have
a cat flap on this room so the cat can't
come in because uh we're wondering
Wesley did disappear quite a lot uh from
from the area yesterday and what's this
move okay this is pretty normal stuff
actually but just catching up with the
game now and uh it's gonna be exciting
yeah Simon before the show we were
talking about Wesley's strategy
yesterday and you were saying he was
playing D4 uh with move one it didn't
work for him against subductor if he's
gone back to basics what he knows best
is an E4 opening uh it's an
anti-sicilian with white bringing out
the bishop to B5 and it's the line uh
the fedexev has chosen out that Magnus
Carlson himself has popularized so it's
a very closed position right now but so
it's just developing and it will take a
slower Pace the next few moves but yeah
I'm liking this switch up from Wesley I
think it's uh much more promising this
is the type of position that he really
enjoys with weight yeah yeah closed
positional Tanya go ahead I was just
going to say that you know this format
can be so deceptive for the players
because it's double elimination right
you feel all safe and secure when you
start you've got two strikes but then
suddenly you lose one match you're down
in the loser's bracket you lose one more
and you're out and that's a big
psychological shift plus it's only two
games here in the losers bracket right
we have to remember that that they don't
get as many chances to go wrong and uh
that means a decisive result here okay
we saw it come back yesterday so nothing
nothing is over till it's over but a
decisive result here would be huge so um
yeah the pressure is immediately on we
see H6 here from federal save and uh
some slow some slow jam in it right
they're slow jamming right now nothing
no no fireworks yet yes I mean I I don't
know why Wesley started playing D4
yesterday I mean it's the old saying
that if it's not broken you don't need
to fix it and he's so good with E4 so so
why was he trying out other ropings and
uh if we just look at the position
already here
um it does strike me that only white can
be better because white has some nice
holes in the middle of the board and
there we go the bishop just slides back
to try to control those holes and the
main square is that Outpost right in the
middle the D5 square and could that be
an issue David for black in this this
type of structure it could be but both
players just playing very slowly I think
we'll check back in this one a bit later
on yeah we will control over D5 square
that seems to be the name of the game
but the other one is also on as Jordan
van for a Stakes on iterizaga with the
black pieces and this feels like the
name of the game here is the English
opening yeah Simon we're loving it of
course best the name of the best opening
clearly I mean no shot much better than
the French defense my brother London has
that well London's all right second best
I'd say but the English opening is a bit
broader I feel so just alienated uh half
our viewership there Simon the London
system you know
I'm team Kings Indian
oh Queens Indian Danny or sure more of a
queen's Indian guy you're right nimzo
repertoire leads to Queen's Indians but
uh anyway now we've got a transposition
actually more of a traditional here you
go Johnny this is going to be a G3
King's Indian on the board and and we
have it and the one thing I will say
here is that iterazaga is an expert in
these types of positions every time I
see him play White he tends to fee and
Kettle his light Square Bishop yeah
Jordan okay he's playing a very direct
line now white has a chance to either
block the center or trade off a set of
Pawns in the center maybe a queen trade
coming as well but uh Jordan yeah he's
had a mixtrack record uh against this
fee and keto system uh something that I
pinpointed as a bit of a weakness in his
game uh a while ago but okay the center
has been blocked Jordan I think we'll be
happy to see this all the pieces still
on the board and despite Black's night
being forced back home to B8 uh just the
fact that the center is now closed means
that Tempe isn't so important here Ultra
positional line in in these A5
variations where black is trying to
control the dark squares rather than uh
rather than being aggressive in the
traditional King's Indian plan where
you're attacking on the king side with
the f-pawn you're you're sort of trying
to slope slow play things and and choke
White's Queen Side Pawn storm before it
gets going so
um anyway the the game is just just
beginning so trying to set the table of
course this is still a lot of theory and
both players likely still playing from
whatever they prepared at home I mean
whenever I'm playing the black side of
the kings in defense which I do a fair
bit I hate playing against G freak you
kind of get different types of structure
you want to actually get this uh this
structure you see here so I think Jordan
will be quite happy that the center has
closed down you see how the pawns are
kind of locked together there a bit like
Lego in the middle and I think that's
something that black will be happy to
get because that's more of a traditional
King's Indian defense setup so you know
you can try to attack on the king cyber
black with uh this main push Black's
gonna move the Knight away and try to
push the pawn so so I think black should
be quite happy actually with this
position
uh Simon you called it the Lego fix for
me King's Indian is always like the
Jenga fix where everything is nicely
clashed until you just put one Pawn
brick and the position explodes is that
something we can expect here I I yeah I
guess so definitely that's that's
probably a much better analogy I think
Jenga whenever I play in the opening it
always falls apart
it all goes wrong as someone who's been
playing a lot of Jenga recently it's uh
that is a game that will give you
anxiety that Rivals chess even when the
eval bar is jumping up and down so that
I think that's a great call out Tanya
and I think as you were saying Simon
these G3 systems are just harder to
assault because white has more pieces
around The King and I think in Rapid in
particular it uh makes it makes it less
attractive to want to play The King's
Indian because you don't get to do the
famous King's Indian Checkmate attacks
right so
um of course these guys play for more
than than Checkmate Thrills like you and
I Simon so I think they'll be all right
yeah but uh we're quite basic humans
aren't we when we play chess we see the
king we attack the king uh but is there
a little tactic post ability here David
maybe I mean uh you what would you take
black I've never seen you play the Kings
in defense David I'm not a spirit of a
man as you Simon I've got to admit I
don't like to be cramped uh too much and
I'm always afraid of weight gaining
space on the queen side and it feels
like this is an automatic now for better
or worse a tourism should push his Pawn
to B4 before it's too late and uh after
a trade
you didn't get that by me and uh yeah
here black does have a bit of an issue
with the Knight I guess Simon you were
thinking of maybe there are tactics like
this I was thinking about it but I mean
I it doesn't seem to work I mean uh
obviously two minor pieces are it's much
stronger to have the two minor pieces
compared to the rook and the pawn yeah
and in this position white would just be
better here so it doesn't seem to work
you know it doesn't seem to work so I'm
a bit surprised that he didn't go for
this to tourism perhaps he was afraid of
the move Knight to A4 and we'll see a
few trades black has the open a file
instead he's taken an even slower
approach that seems to be the name of
the game uh in both of the matches so
far yeah just uh maneuvering here he's
just slow played it with the point of B3
instead he's going to slowly build up
maybe plan his Bishop 183 and will
Jordan turn his attentions to a typical
King's Indian plan I think that's the
question will he start playing for this
famous F5 break in the near future
we'd love to see that on the board with
players playing on either flanks
idrisaga handling the queen side and an
avalanche by Jordan on the king side
that seems like the direction this game
is headed and while this heats up let's
take this moment to check in on Wesley
so against Vladimir fedesev and wow
there's a lot that's happened David
Black's Queen targeting White's King but
I don't see too many pieces yeah Black's
Queen needs some assistance if she wants
to deliver any checkmates we have seen a
trade of one set of knights hence the
white kingside pawns being damaged white
has double G pawns long term that's fine
but short term maybe some holes on the
dark squares around White's King problem
is for FedEx if it's like you say Tanya
if there's nothing immediate then slowly
the kickback might start and uh Black's
Queen if she's forced to retreat
think the momentum might change a bit
later on so okay how will Wesley deal
with this is him to move it's an obscure
game I think we should talk a little bit
about the pawn structure and maybe maybe
since we only have two games going bring
up bring up the analysis and show show
how that happened because it's not every
day you see doubled g-pawns like that
right in a queen on H4 but it goes back
to this position where Wesley employed
this Knight H2 plan David and I I think
that we've got a couple of Night Moves
happening over here on on the opposite
edges of the board but I have the
opening Explorer pulled up just to see I
mean we're already kind of in original
territory even if this idea is one that
one that white does sometimes employ
especially when you have the pollen
structure c2d3 E4 you're you know maybe
preparing these ideas to get space on
the king side which we should always be
thinking about but black doesn't allow
it right trades on G4 and plays Queen H4
to make sure that you have to protect
the pawn rather than playing an
aggressive F4 so anyway I think it's a
fascinating and original kind of
position right those double G pawns may
not be something to look at but they do
hold black F5 right hold back F5 for
black so a really interesting kind of
grip that white has on the king side
Yeah you mentioned F5 under control by
white is
D she just fought S3 since you mentioned
porn structure Danny I want to play the
move B3 just to put all my love and
light squares Checkers Checkers called
get out of chest down Checkers hang a
minute you know what black needs to play
here as well right black has two moves
let's do it yeah we've got to put them
on and we have the perfect structure
right so uh
listen we're literally just like kids
playing with coloring books right now I
hope someone Clips this because this is
really high level chess analysis this
looks like you're adding challenge
against magnets yeah it's literally just
Checkers uh meanwhile uh Wesley so
spoiling the fun he's put a pull on a
dart Square what are you doing Leslie C3
logical move though and uh Tanya I think
your suggestion is uh really pertinent
here if black just Retreats it feels
like you're stepping back in the wrong
direction there we go feather save
breaks down the center I like it oh it
didn't happen okay right on you no Tanya
great call I think that it's it's
usually the person who controls the pawn
breaks is controlling kind of the tempo
or the direction of the game right the
steel one from my my boy Robert house
you can't spell chess without him and we
often talk about that because I think
close positions to beginner players look
boring at first but looking at a closed
position and seeing the forest through
the trees is about seeing where the
breakthroughs are going to come and I
think D5 shows that that actually black
has a lot of good chances here because I
mean now now if the Center opens up and
White's King is over little exposed you
got the dark squares that could fall
apart that Bishop on B8 is going to be
playing if you ever take on D5 yeah I
love that via that diagonal or if you
take on D5 there's even this E4 push and
can I get just a you know just to make
the kids Happy show a little Checkmate
if you take an E4 and here comes Bishop
H2 and
and uh so anyway the point is the pieces
are coming to life because black
controls the pawn breaks and that's an
instructive thing to take away
regardless of your chest level and I
like the black played D5 yeah and now
maybe he can continue uh this Knight is
attacked to the point D5 attacked as
well uh maybe you can continue with C4
maybe there are some tactics taking this
Pawn oh man dragging the queen forward
uh to a square it can be double attacked
oh unlucky tricky position right now for
both players to manage it's quite
strange because the way Wesley is
playing he's kind of forcing fettercept
to play good moves yeah he's like you
know he's playing this move C3 to attack
the Black Knight if black moves the
Knight backwards black is just clearly
in a very bad scenario because he he's
lost that square so black has to play
actively and um that is kind of like
strange against someone as strong as
fedexf you know fedexv is going to play
good moves and uh he's got to find
another good move here otherwise again
he's just going to be worse he can't
move the Knight back because he'll lose
the pawn so he's got to play an active
move and I I don't know how this is
going to end out but the evaluation bar
seems to start start to favor Black here
as well so people just played first so
C4 is explosive when it happens this I
mean it's uh yeah oh Danny I nearly
missed that joke there Danny so one we
you've got one Dave we're lagging here
Tanya we need to yeah
Dave and I had a talk and we said hey
man we lost we lost the cringy pun game
last night and we were going to bring it
today it's not a race it's a marathon
that's right so we got time for Dynamite
that's uh there it is ah there we go
that's for sure no but Tanya you called
this D5 it was great C4 is now on the
board this is this is again we're early
but look at the board look at the evil
board look at the King on G1 A6 is
coming like this feels very scary for
Wesley already absolutely and
psychologically right when you attack an
opponent's piece you're automatically
thinking about them just retreating with
it is it possible that Wesley just
underestimated the moment when black one
D5 I think it's great call I think when
you play C3 you maybe just
underestimated both the moves we now see
D5 and C4 I think I think that's you
look at the time it's suggestive that
he's he's losing his way it's very
strange for someone as strong as Wesley
the way he's missing stuff like this I
mean he wouldn't do this normally yeah
you know he was doing it yesterday he's
doing it today and it's not a normal
normal thing for Wesley I mean he's
normally on top of everything
some exchanges happening there and
things clarifying maybe in the position
a little bit I mean yeah he's just gonna
favor say if it's paused here it looks
like he can just take the white Bishop
but no he wants more I love this move
hey look at the stretch he plays it he
leans back he's learning from around
here the aronian stretch there you know
look at the King on G1 we got we got fun
stuff here we got fireworks on the board
and and I I agree just to piggyback on
your point Simon I think that they say
class is permanent and form is temporary
and it's our job to call it like we see
it because we all love Wesley but the
truth is this doesn't look like the form
that we normally see from so yesterday
he played some had some interesting
decisions and here again he's inviting a
game it's kind of making it easy on his
opponents right now he's giving his
opponents chances I feel like he did
that against Notre back toward the end
and he's doing it against Federal save
right now yeah beautiful beautiful move
there from fair to say I've got to say
and okay he chooses to save this bishop
and uh the Knight was covering A7 so it
had to be removed and now before the
deadly check ending the game for the
fear of uh threatening that move
obviously has blocked it so still alive
but here it feels like momentum is
purely in Black's favor uh you can start
hitting this White Queen you can start
uh maybe even just taking a pawn
you need something now but uh it feels
like Wesley yeah missing stuff just not
on form right now he needs to pull
himself together yeah it's an important
bishop move there that white played I
mean why absolutely absolutely needed to
cover that diagonal with his last move
any other move uh he'd be losing already
we see feder said bringing a rook to the
middle for a natural move Rooks below
and open files but
um the bishop Wesley's Bishop does seem
okay and I like this idea that Wesley's
playing if you're in a tricky scenario
try to get rid of your opponent's Queen
because it's less likely you'll get
checkmated so is it that bad for Wesley
or is he is he actually just okay here
no matter what the evaluation bar
actually says yeah I mean it looks like
uh if the Queen's come off he should be
totally fine I think that's the point I
think the queen should not come off I
think Queen E7 is
what the doctor ordered and it's a
reluctant Retreat if fed to say it does
keep the Queens on because you want to
of course deliver Checkmate to White's
King but maybe you just need to step
back find a new angle and we do see the
evaluation bar here that might be
misleading I'm certainly influenced by
it I'm wondering now I mean I would
prefer black but I'm not sure it's that
good from a human perspective but uh
yeah computer seems to think black has a
massive Advantage here I like your move
Danny just coming back to E7 white has
some weaknesses on the queen side as
well I was gonna say the air quality
remains good so better safe has that
going for him the room hasn't changed
air quality still just allowing him to
play some high quality chess yeah and
the position remains good as well for
blacks or fantasy of here
decide to try this one out in the end
game or will he keep all the trumps in
the position and retreat with the queen
trying to grind down a middle game he
does take a decision Queens are off the
board and immediately also snaps up the
A4 Pawn does the queen trade surprise
you it does Super surprised me I think
that it I think that
we'll see what he calculated I think now
will be the move because whatever he
decided he must have some sort of
follow-up normally
um it's very strange isn't it because
we're sitting here we see the evaluation
bar these guys don't see the evaluation
bar so from feather says point of view
maybe he just didn't realize how good
his position was maybe he's like okay if
I make some exchanges I'm going to get
nearer to a draw and uh that might be
the way I can just play this keep it
simple maybe that's you know something
that's happened here a big decision
there about Vladimir father said will he
have Queen trade or will you'll be able
to grind down this end game we'll jump
back to this as this one has come down
let's head over to the Eduardo iterizaga
versus Jordan van Forest Queens are
still on the board and quite a crazy
position upon on B3 in White's Camp how
on Earth did that get there
how on Earth did that black porn arrive
on B3 black is a pawn up as well how did
Black get rid of that King's Indian dark
squared Bishop it looks like there have
been many developments in this game and
uh we'll check in on the current
position but let's just do a quick
action replay I think like the other
game Danny we need to figure some stuff
out and I'd love to figure out how we
got here because I'm it's funny this is
one where I will openly just disagree
with the eval giving black a tiny Edge I
look at the position and feel like if we
okay you get us there and then I'll give
my opinion on the live board okay 84
happened so A4 happened and this is how
what uh the pawn eventually landed on B3
black first installed a nice Knight on a
very strong square and it was here
Bishop to H6 the king's Indian Bishop
came to life the White Knight had to go
the long way around to trade off this uh
mighty steed on B3 and after a few more
trades we did see not Queen takes Pawn
I'm wondering why first of all he didn't
capture this Pawn looks like it was up
for grabs but uh after the Knight
stepped back this is the current
position Danny but I think you entered
it if we want to show real quick I think
if you take V3 then when you take E4 the
White Knight doesn't have any squares
and if you can't take E4 back because of
Bishop F5 so I think that must have been
the the combination as far as why white
had to postpone the corralling of that
of that overextended B3 Pawn so so back
to the live position it's funny because
even though I Now understand that the
black has a small Edge according to the
math of our artificially intelligent
overlords because black is up a pawn but
I look at every long-term feature of
this position and I look at the B3 Pawn
it's going to be corralled that white
has the bishop pair black has lost the
famed King's Indian bishop and white is
going to get C5 at some point which is
the Breakthrough on the queen side we
always want so call me crazy
just don't call me Shirley I prefer
white is is math similar to maths there
it is a little bit it's similar yeah
okay just just clarifying that so I
don't know I mean I just tell me tell me
why I'm crazy I guess black is showing
why I'm crazy Jordan is being very
aggressive on the file but I I would
prefer white despite what the eval says
and remember the players don't see that
so anyway it'll be a bit of a race right
I mean Black's got some chances on the
king side as well here I mean uh David
even the next few moves will be critical
because black will try some attack some
assault against the white king if it
doesn't work then I totally agree with
Danny and uh I think a tourism now is
pretty urgent he has to stop black from
pushing a pawn to H4 he has to stop
black from maybe throwing some pieces
out the way and breaking through with
the Rooks those two stacked up black
Rooks on the f file uh they have two
Pawn slightly tender if white can
consolidate cover everything then what
is strategically winning it's fair it's
fair I guess I'm I'm just looking at the
long-term features in the chess human in
me is is coming out versus the computer
and I even if you play H4 I'm thinking
about taking it and sliding my Rook to
G3 I guess what I'll say is this there's
no way objectively that black isn't fine
because you can't argue with computers
and I but I would argue the instructive
point is that if black doesn't stay on
the grind on the king side and if black
doesn't deliver on the f file don't be
surprised if the eval bar switches
that's my point because white does have
a lot of those long-term features going
for him yeah I think I choose white as
well but uh not with a not with a lot of
confidence
I would go black all day long
you know I Am the Man in Black and I I
love
looking at my opponent's king putting
pieces near it and just attacking and uh
who cares what's going on the Queen's
side it doesn't matter the king's over
there Checkmate ends the game and
actually this move Harry four H4 I think
is really really quite dangerous right
because uh you want to keep things
blocked as you both mentioned uh but
it's very hard to do that so there is
you know I'm not sure how if white can
stop that I agree with you but I don't
see how white does and here is the
opportunity to play and he's played it
so we're gonna find out
Jordan ronfer is going for Eduardo there
is August King but time is off
well because with all the Strategic
trumps that white has including those
two Bishops the bishop are Advantage
black has to go for the kill right here
right now H4 a great start if white
tries to keep the position blocked on
the king side advancing the G Pawn can
we expect a sacrifice I would love to
see G4 I mean David brought up the
analysis before we could even say we
gotta show why that's a bad idea I'm
assuming Bishop takes there has to be a
bishop takes followed by Knight and F2
Falls and
and with it the house right yeah um so I
so I don't think we're gonna see G4 as
fun as it is to show
um yeah you see a position like this and
you just stop calculating with white you
just think okay I'm getting checkmated
if not I'll probably just lose material
so G4 I think would be short-sighted but
Danny mentioned another resource that
white could try just taking this one and
sliding across with the Rook a bit later
on what could be the downside here I
think it's going to be Knight H5 right
away right Tanya nodding her head next
to me I think she already saw it before
I did it and it not only because it it
goes to F4 but it holds G3 right so the
Rook can't come to G3 which makes
everything start to feel dysfunctional
so I love it 985 you're also threatening
slacks on the H3 Square Bishop H3 always
in the air opening up the F5 with impact
this could be super dangerous but with
all these lines that we're talking about
how then does white keep things solid on
the king side or is it just going to be
explosion if I if I had to guess no
engine in front of me some move like
Rook G1 something that sits on the
position because here's the thing if you
if you play Knight H5 before then I'll
have G4 or at least I'll have a chance
to get G4 you might you might still sack
actually and if you take G3 before the
Knight comes in maybe I can take back no
the computer doesn't like it either it's
yeah it's it's getting it's getting more
and more concrete which I guess shows
our modern chest similar to to Simon
kind of yesterday commenting that the
bishop pair must be good for black and I
happen to know that position so I was
like no this is good for aronian here
this is like me looking at the bishop
pair and the computer's like no no that
doesn't matter the f file the doubled
pawns are actually killing white here on
e4 and E5 and here comes Full Steam so
Simon it's a position after your own
heart yeah certainly I mean uh you know
the most important thing always is King
safety yeah um when both sides are
developed and that is the the key thing
here uh Black's King is very safe black
has more pieces on that area of the
board and this last move I love it it's
like a little lever it's just tickling
away a White's position little tickle
tickle open up open up the king and then
bang the black pieces will come through
and uh it's very hard for black uh sorry
for white to to keep his Kings safe now
and uh also I I think a position that
Jordan really thrives in Jordan loves
attacking he loves these exciting
positions and he and
um it's getting dangerous and white now
I feel
yeah I'm in the clock situation as well
it's incredibly dangerous now for to
rizaga just uh one more long thinking
him otherwise uh I think we might see
catastrophe over the next few moves
David you wanted white a couple of moves
ago are you still sticking to that I I
did mention it was not with confidence I
think I was swinging him I was looking
at the at the at the big picture not
seeing the tree that was falling on me
so sometimes we say look at the forest
through the trees sometimes you gotta
look at what's right in front of you and
the concrete aspects of this position
were that were the white can't really
coordinate and the more I look at it the
more I'm like duh duh Danny uh and also
by the way how have we not commented on
Jordan's shirt
what is going on so great the Hawaiian
shirt and daddy however
needs to defend this position with less
than three minutes on the clock yeah
it's it's getting worse and worse for
each race August so I was wrong white is
in trouble
I'm sorry we're all wrong sometimes
honey I'm wrong I'm wrong more than
right that's the truth
I'm always right this Ginger knows how
to attack I get lucky occasionally and
um well we're gonna I mean that that
night move you mentioned wasn't played
but this also seems quite it's quite
blunt isn't it he just wants to take
that pawn and attack I'm not closing the
book on each other yet for the wreck I
mean I think Jordan accurately if
accurately played puts this away but
this is a double-edged position we can
be biased by the eval the dark Square
Bishop is gone if black screws this up
the floodgates could switch and that's
one of the things you always have to be
worried about
I think it's just the fact that all of
Black's five pieces will be I mean
contributing to the attack and maybe
white start Square Bishop is the one
that cannot defend yeah so just gonna be
outnumbered simply yeah and I love it
you can slow burn this attack Rook H7
eight minutes against under two minutes
now
this is an uphill struggle I don't see
any obvious defensive moves and uh two
minutes is fine if your moves are
natural this is far from that type of
position right now and we've got to
remember it's only two games isn't it
that these guys play in the losers
bracket so losing with white in the
first game we've got your moving Danny
better late than never they say you did
get it yeah and by the way if the C file
opens up that is another line of attack
so you know I think the biggest problem
right now and as Tonya point out maybe
the biggest blunder is just on the clock
right right now the Judiciary Saga
regardless of the Dynamics on the board
is is getting himself in trouble off the
board I don't know if that was the
biggest blunder because right after he
played the move C5 it turns out I had a
bit of a reaction there David as if he's
just made a mistake what happened there
yeah he kind of looked up and winced
visibly and uh he does not look happy
maybe it's just the way the game's been
going I think this last move is probably
as good as any he's trying to cause the
distraction switch uh Jordan's Focus to
the ninja sometimes you give your
opponent a Juke no maybe maybe he saw
his clock for the first time yeah Mind
Games maybe maybe Wesley's cat bit him
under the table
speaking of Wesley by the way another
way you have to go there that game looks
like it's holding out but I'm just I'm
giving Wesley the nod and the evil bar
we can see on screen that despite being
worse he's holding on and maybe gonna
find his form slowly
I think this is the game we want to
stick to I agree I agree Eduardo just
under two minutes and a difficult
position to defend he's trying to create
a bit of chaos on the queen side a
distraction on the queen side but with
all of Jordan's forces directed towards
the king it's hotter Martin Jordan
getting distracted from that big goal of
checkmating White's King does he simply
go on to pick up that H Pawn open the H
line what's going on there yeah yeah why
not just be consistent normally once you
find a plan if you're confident it's a
good one just stick to it don't get
distracted don't kind of play Move by
move I think the only thing that's maybe
pausing uh or causing Jordan to pause
here is that he might trade one set of
Pawns on the queen side not sure who
that helps I think he's not sure sure
who that helps but yeah I think I would
just be too tempted to pick up but I I I
disagree about why he was thinking I
think Jordan was giving a very good
example for all the youngsters or chess
improvers watching of managing your time
versus taking your time what happened
here was he had gained an edge on the
clock and rather than blitzing as your
opponent gets under time pressure he
paused took a couple minutes because he
wants it because what's going to happen
now is Jordan wants to commit to the
winning line or at least the line that
he thinks is good but 40 turizaga knows
which line is coming so that your
opponent can't react in a forceful
manner right we've all all of us here
have heard it from coaches at different
times in our careers right I being the
weakest player Among Us so maybe I
stopped hearing it earlier but you know
what I'm talking about David can you say
that one more time I'm the weakest
player here I see one more time
the point is you manage your time when
you have an edge on the clock and that
allows you to to put your opponent in an
impossible spot right so now they're
trying to like look at this E3 Jordan
already calculated E3 before he played
Rook takes H4 that's my point and so
he's going to make it harder for
etorizaga to not just solve the problems
but do so with no time on the clock yeah
and that's often a very good strategy
against someone who is in time pressure
uh you kind of change the pace at
tourism he's kind of building up the
adrenaline he's like come on move move
that's uh up the speed let's say
Jordan's like slowing it down keeping
him guessing and okay he's thrown away a
poor njordan there must be a concrete
idea here he can give a night check this
must be the idea to drag White's Queen
onto a skirt it's going to be forked
attacked by Black Knight but some
complications there it's still very
messy it's actually quite messy I mean
it's one of those positions you see
White's dark Square Bishop if that can
ever come to life it could be white who
uh grabs the initiative I mean I think
Jordan's still doing okay I mean does he
dive in with a knight and grab some
material in the position I mean it
reminds me what Danny was saying there
very quickly this fantastic book called
uh chess for tigers and um uh if you
haven't got the book as well worth
getting and there was a little bit of
advice there that if you've got a better
position then you should not play
quickly you really shouldn't because why
what's the point you're only going to go
wrong if your opponent's sure to time if
your opponent's short of time and you're
worse then you can maybe try some
hustling techniques but
um in in this case there's yeah I agree
with Danny no reason to uh move quick
but yeah how did you evaluate this David
this position it's hard black has won
the exchange he did throw in that night
check forcing white to give up a rook
and due to the pin on the H file white
cannot regain the material but now I'm
looking at Queen's lights I'm not sure
to G3 or G5 which one is more attractive
initially I thought G5 you attack this
Rook attack this Pawn but Black's idea
must be to maybe swing the queen across
and some breakthroughs against the H3
pawn it looks like everything's covered
here for black and meanwhile Queen g3 at
least holds everything together forces
this black Rook back
maybe it just Retreats maybe this is uh
this is the issue I'm not sure which
Square again but looks like Jordan's got
everything covered and material up
that's for the pawn trade and you might
go in with the queen move you're
pointing out also let's update everyone
that the other game has in fact ended
peacefully in a draw sadasev versus
Wesley so it starts with the draw it's
the best of two it's only one more rapid
game remains for those two players but
it's all eyes on this wild position that
we have and the last move by Eduardo
durizaga with under 30 seconds on the
clock is it still tricky for black to
convert this and Jordan just found it
Rook H5 because again he earned his Edge
on the clock and now for the last
several moves he's been managing his
time well to Simon's point he's in a
better position so he's making sure that
he uh he lets his opponent suffer I mean
I think he's playing phenomenal like
I'll just like I think that maybe
initially we were a little worried about
this Knight G4 thing but the more we
look at it I think Jordan had calculated
it he managed his time appropriately I
think he's going to win with black and
uh and put it to rizaga on on edge and
we saw a feature chat there with praise
for Jordan's move of getting the Rook
the queen side Rook into the attack on
the F9 I think that's a great point
because you really want to bring all the
toys to the nursery bring the whole
party get the attack going and that Rook
on the F line is a dangerous piece I
love it and Rook H5 by the way that was
a phenomenal move right this this pin
and now and now after Queen G3 he'll I'm
assuming Play Bishop F5 but maybe he can
go funky maybe he can take H3 like I
don't know because if it takes F2 and
queen takes H3 yeah I mean there's some
crazy idea the reason I would say no is
because the queen takes G6 check but but
maybe that doesn't work maybe the black
queen just slides some blocks and you
have to Queens or yeah
boom and uh yeah the other line you were
showing Danny after all the white Bishop
takes
yeah enough for which order Rook takes
F2 maybe the king moves back uh when
it's out of danger maybe you go the
other order Rook takes Bishop first ah
okay and you win the queen okay you win
the queen uh here you force the white
king away deflect it and everything
falls the house it's so much easier to
suggest lines when I'm not in control of
The Mouse and the highlighter it's easy
to just focus on on these tactics and if
I make a mistake then you'll cover it up
it's no big deal
I'll try we've got each other's backs
here but uh okay he didn't go for that
it's only delayed it though maybe he can
go for it again this time Danny your
idea Bishop takes H3 it looks like uh he
did throw a rook in the way but White's
Rook now is off on a limb not
contributing to the defense it feels
like there's a breakthrough this so many
pieces just hovering around White's King
I mean when you've got a situation like
this you know with your P you can kind
of feel the the you know the position is
ready to you know to to flop for your
opponent and um that's why a move like
Bishop H3 should be high on the radar
but he hasn't played it yeah he didn't
find it he's he's still playing much
Karma here but I guess from a maturity
perspective we should applaud the fact
that if he didn't see a win he didn't go
for it because his opponent only has 15
seconds so he's continuing to grind it
out and again sorry I'm just I'm
applying Jordan's player overall I just
feel like he's handled this in a very
disciplined manner even if there was
objectively a better computer win yeah
that's the last move King H7 just
getting tucking the black king to safety
that is really mature really five four
he needs to make a move David he might
get flagged and he finally plays Rook C6
with just three seconds on the clock and
the King side falls apart it's over
Bishop G4 what's going to be the final
blow I like Bishop D1 because it looks
stupid
and I love stupid looking moves so but I
mean again the the black Rooks I love
how they've got to the H file I mean
it's really pretty and quite unique that
they're sort of way over there and um by
the way I love this feature where the
engine suggests that move I'm just
seeing it for the first time because I
don't I'm not looking at that that's
awesome just to quickly see what the
engine says is best yeah we can see the
more the engine thinks the more it
thinks black is winning and a similar
idea to your Simon the black Bishop got
out the way for the black Rook to attack
whites Queen some counter attacks
against the black queen but it's not
enough look at the perfect coordination
of Black's pieces uh everything on light
squares everything protecting each other
and White's Queen is gonna fall or it's
gonna be Checkmate this is a beautiful
game this is actually one of the one of
my favorite games I love the king's in
the defense I mean it's favored by
Kasparov by Bobby Fisher some of the
most aggressive most fun players out
there and uh I love seeing people play
it nowadays because the computer kind of
eats it but that's it he resigns as you
were saying what a game this has been by
Jordan van Forest killing it on the king
side literally there with his attack at
the end then he takes his lead which
means that Eduardo etorizaga will have
to win the next game on demand to force
a playoff that's the lead for Jordan the
other match ended in a draw that was a
tactical Masterpiece David what was the
big moment in that one yeah just a
really well-controlled game by Jordan
van forest and the way he ended it was
really instructive here as Danny was uh
pointing out Jordan had a big time
Advantage but finding the killer blue is
the hardest thing in chess and he had
calculated in advance that pawn to E3
wins material and this is the safest the
surest way of banking the advantage it
drags the White Queen to the E3 Square
where it gets forked by the Black Knight
and uh this check cost white material
you had to give up the exchange and as
we saw a bit later on black was able to
coordinate everything later bringing
this Rook into the attack as well and
eventually it was the white king that
was in Peril and uh yeah beautiful
technique from Jordan brand Forest
amazing technique amazing finish and an
amazing attacking game that by Jordan
can he keep up the pace in the final
round of the losers round one and there
we have our score line Wesley so
Vladimir fantasy of keep it even one
rapid game remaining another draw means
in Armageddon in Eduardo terizaga it is
who has to win on demand to take it to
the Armageddon it's going to be quite a
match that's coming up and we will be
back with round two action in just a few
thank you
it doesn't look like much but neither
would a Sicilian Defense to the
untrained eye this is a performance
enhancer you don't see it how about now
manage your air quality sharpen your
performance change the game with air
things
[Music]
seriously
aimchester's intelligent system that
analyzes your game prevents mistakes and
develops recommendations for improving
your skill
want to improve your game click the link
in the chess.com navigation bar to try
aim chest today and increase your rating
31 faster than standard tactics puzzles
when you sign up for aim chess our
powerful AI breaks down your latest
games and provides actionable insights
to immediately improve your game you
will also receive personalized lessons
created from your game history to help
you learn from your mistakes in a custom
made study plan to help you reach your
goals learn chess your way with aim
chess your digital chess coach
[Music]
unlock your up attention right now with
the aim chess analytics and lessons and
you can get your first month free with
code CCT
go.chess.com aim chess David how cool is
it and how important is it that you can
get targeted training to improve your
chess yeah Tanya I've got to say I love
aim chess these days I'm pretty busy I
do a lot of things and aim chess is just
a quick and effective way of pinpointing
weaknesses telling you what to work on
and just tailoring uh personalizing uh
all of that information it's uh it's
something I definitely recommend
especially for the busy players out
there I've tried it it's really cool you
definitely have to check it out and
right now Eduardo teruzaga who has to
check out what he needs to do in this
final round because he has to find a way
to beat Jordan a van forest in a
must-win situation to keep his chances
alive in the aim chess rapid but it
really felt that that game was an
all-jordan show yeah it's hard because
Jordan also won with black right and so
at this level getting the first move is
so huge in terms of their ability to
dictate the opening that will be played
and then therefore the types of middle
games and whether the game is going to
have any fights so also Jordan played
pretty darn good chess there so right
now my money would be on Jordan we saw
crazier things happened yesterday when
Notre Rebecca do satorophone with black
on command but uh I think I think
ichirizaga has an uphill fight yeah he's
got to pick a very sharp opening and
he's got to Hope Jordan is not playing
as well as he did in that last game as
well so being
yeah it's gonna be exciting and I'm also
looking forward to seeing uh Wesley so
back uh back at the table it feels like
he's stemmed the bleeding in that last
one and fair to save maybe a mistake to
swap Queens off if you could have maybe
sensed a bit of weakness there since
that Sue was a bit uncertain but uh yeah
that one I was gonna say that it's hard
to hard to say who that game was a win
for right when it comes to a draw we
sometimes debate well who won right uh
better say of Drew with black so you got
to be happy about that but Wesley so has
been on tilt and was so much worse in
the game that I would argue Wesley has
got to be taking a sigh of relief and
saying okay here we go
I can do this it's not going to be
enough because he needs to create his
own chances in the next game and he will
play with the black pieces we see
phariseev is the first one in waiting
for Wesley to arrive on camera there a
new room today a new day there will we
see some new openings by Wesley with
black
uh but Wesley plays loads of openings
and uh again we see the the best named
opening being played here clearly uh the
English opening uh I'm sure we're gonna
get along
Annie Danny you know women's chessable
course on the English that's the one
yeah
um but it's it's a nice uh it's a nice
actually opening to get a um not such a
theoretical game uh nowadays I mean a
lot of E4 stuff is worked out maybe it's
a bit more positional the English and
where's Wesley gone though is he hiding
in the cupboard or something Wesley
hello and um oh there he is running
Wesley he did look at that he's happy it
happened yesterday too remember that he
was uh Heidi was out and about hiding
and uh although yesterday there was some
sort of miscommunication that had
happened and so they restarted I'm not
sure if today Wesley was just late but
here he is now
huh where are those cats yeah it feels
like uh Something's Happened there but
okay a minute down he starts this game
Wesley so and he plays the move E6 and
the English opening I think the reason
we love it not just the name is because
it keeps lots of pieces on the board uh
no direct draws no uh early kind of
release of tension here and a fiancato
from G3 how will Wesley react now I see
so he won the global Chess Championship
right he's been on fire in so many of
the online events but Vladimir
Fellowship the big fish we've seen him
win events after events his phenomenal
performance in the protest League he was
the MVP of the League this year if this
match was to go down to the Armageddon
and we're talking about Mouse skills
who's faster there
wow um
cats and mouse it's Wesley yeah cat and
mouse I I would still give the nod to
Wesley um and again there's a reason his
class is what you know his reputation
there is what precedes him right um even
if there's been a been a few bumpy
moments over the last couple days so I
would still say Wesley is the favorite
but um but given what happened yesterday
right they're given that there's got to
be a little bit of a hangover in terms
of how he lost to Notre back I don't
think Wesley wants that so
you know I I'm I'm gonna I'm gonna plead
the fifth and say a coin flip giving
Wesley would normally have the edge but
right now Federal save has been playing
a little better
yeah so you think Wesley would want this
match decided in the rapid I I mean
right now he's black right so I think
what he wants is just to play a good
chess game and probably not lose
um but uh
but yeah I mean I I really do believe
there's something to the mindset that
they're in which is I just want to play
a good game right now because that's all
I can see we're starting with yeah
exactly so far
meanwhile Wesley took a pause there and
played the move C5 he wants to get his
Queen side developed uh White has very
uh kind of quick easy moves here white
just puts up on D3 we're gonna see
White's king castle to safety uh black
often has issues on the long diagonal
you look at white slight Square Bush one
G2 there are always tricks uh it's a bit
uh difficult here for Wesley so to
develop so
um yeah he's got to be careful I've seen
this go wrong several times even for
very strong Grand masters from the black
side
looks like a decent opening Choice from
Fred to save at least forcing Wesley to
think at this early stage
yeah I mean Black's pieces look a bit
funny here I mean the you look at the
the knight in front of the queen uh that
that night is just on a weird Square I
mean when you're developing when you're
doing stuff at the start of the game you
want to control the center you want to
get your king safe but you want to put
your pieces on good squares right and
that Knight is probably gonna have to
re-route because it gets in the way of
the bishop gets in the way of the queen
it doesn't have any effect on the center
as well so just looking at the pieces uh
White's pieces are a bit more harmonious
at the moment so uh yeah I think feather
Sev will be happy so far with the way
things are gone
found to say I'm happy in this opening
and one player who's happy in the other
match is Jordan van forest and their
final rapid game is about to lift off we
see iterizaga there he plays with the
black pieces the first game going down
to Jordan in quite a destructive manner
that was and Jordan starts with the
Queen spawn opening does he want to keep
things solid in this one yeah definitely
but um it's not also Jordan's style to
keep things solid so you gotta you've
got to be careful because you don't want
to say to yourself okay I've got to be
so solid then playing a really different
style to what you're used to playing
it's actually better to play your normal
way and Jordan's normal ways to play a
little bit crazy so so um yeah I'm
actually changing my mind here quite
quickly I agree and I think Lebon and
ronian spoke on this right during his
interview yesterday and it's it's really
something we should underestimate that
it's it's also hard to be in the spot
where it feels like you can go no wrong
right because now you're double you're
double guessing yourself on everything
and whether I should have played the
position I normally would and so I I
think Jordan will be okay and and you
know here he's playing a classical ninja
with the with the queens of C2 but um
but yeah it's difficult to be in a spot
where you feel like anything anything is
good for you but then maybe that
backfires what do you think David is
playing for a draw the worst way to play
for a draw yeah I've tried it myself
trust me too many times playing negative
chess passive chess especially against
the top guys in the world and they do
punish you uh if you take negative
decisions
and Jordan I must admit I've very rarely
seen him play this queen C2 move but he
does choose to plant all of his Pawns in
the center and actually that has a very
Jewish reputation in that line and uh
tourism has been forced to choose a
variation that doesn't allow anything I
was going to say the very Josh line is
the line with D5 and so ichirisaga
doesn't go for that as someone who plays
this system for black there are a lot of
very deep theoretical lines if you have
D5 and E5 and 94. so a good I think an
interesting call there by Jordan to play
something that's aggressive but also was
a bit baiting in terms of whether
iterizaga wants to play the best lines
which may be a draw so now look now look
black doesn't have the best lines but
that means white has an edge white has a
big Center and this is going to be a fun
game for him this move I'm quite
surprised about I mean this is a very
aggressive move from Jordan I mean it is
is obviously quite a natural move
gaining space attacking Black's knife
but he had a safe Advantage without
pushing that pawn and the pawn I mean is
the E Pawn the pawn in front of White's
king
um because you can overextend yourself
as well you know if you put a pawn into
your opponent's side of the board it can
become weak on the other hand white has
some attacking chances and here he goes
straight towards Black's King I guess
this may still be theory that I'm not
aware of I guess yeah at least until uh
White captured that pawn on D6 I was
still familiar with the position now
after Bishop to D3 like you said Simon
Just threats against the black king side
I think Jordan's just happy to develop
whether it's Theory or not he's just
happy to get that white king to safety
and
he's done nothing wrong he's got no
reason to be worse here with white still
lots of pieces on the board though and
wow a tourizaga doesn't react to a
threat against that black H7 Pawn he
just tries to break in the center while
White's King is still stranded I like
that move I don't even care what happens
I like that that is that is an
aggressive move if white takes H7 with
check we are going to be in for a fight
and uh interesting one to kind of invite
your opponent to go for when when you're
kind of playing at their psychological
whatever heartstrings brain brain tease
right what do you want to do
yeah and uh
the last move by through zaga is that
more determined because of the math
situation going completely all out all
in inviting white to take a very key
King Side Pawn
I mean I I think it looks like it also
kind of works though because there's a
lot of tactics here the white king is in
the center the C4 Pawn is hanging in a
lot of lines so David you've got the
analysis Board of what do you see here
yeah first he has to decide how to take
in the center usually you might want to
take with the pawn uh but now I think it
is just a clear sacrifice after Bishop
takes Pawn the black king has to move
and white does have time to evacuate
this bishop I'm not sure where you slide
back but even this is actually
complicated Black's Knight is going to
jump into the center White's King is
just one move too far away and if you do
castle in the position like this you
have to wonder what happens if black
tries to trap your Bishop so this is
mightily complicated and instead he
chooses to take with a knight the more
Dynamic option playing with pieces
rather than Pawns in the center and yeah
I would be too terrified I think to
capture this Pawn on H7 uh it just feels
like you losing too much time especially
with everything I was thinking of
because at the end of it now F3 is
hanging Knight D4 is coming if that
trade happens C4 is hanging
you're doing much better than me Danny
at the moment with the jokes but um yeah
I really like the way that um uh black
has played this I think he's played it
you know perfectly with the match
situation he's played it in a very
aggressive way as well and Jordan now
has has to really think as well I mean
does he grab that pawn or does he I
think I think Jordan would normally want
to grab that pawn knowing Jordan but
maybe it's just a bad move maybe it's
just uh he can't maybe it's just
impossible too slow you choose not to
Jordan he's just castled his King so now
it's black to move he didn't take up the
challenge uh maybe influenced by the
match situation and now firstly you can
play F5 to block this diagonal you can
also plant your knight into the center
in D4 uh it just looks like big success
this opening for black I loved F5 he
didn't go for it he played 94 first but
it may not matter maybe he follows with
the same idea but
no when you saw E5 you felt like it was
uh it was the right the right call to
the the challenge right he was up for
the challenge that being a teary Saga
knowing he has to win it's win or go
home literally for him in his aim chess
rapid campaign so uh so here we go this
is going to be a fun a fun game and uh
he's already up on the clock definitely
feeling confident there we see head in
hand that's suppose we see from eachery
Saga time to time so
here we go I'm excited for this one I
want to see him cheer again because uh
if you've been watching the show from
start we obviously had a video of how he
qualified for this event which which was
fantastic he got so emotional and it's
nice to see a bit of emotion in chess
because we don't always see it you know
chess players are supposed to be very
you know statue-like aren't they and not
give much away so I love it when a chess
player shows any kind of emotion you
know they're not you know inside chess
players are going bonkers so I I'd love
to see some more cheering at the board
is that something we want more of in
general do we want more cheering
cheerleaders
or celebrations we want to see all of
that and I think this is also such a big
moment for iterizaga to have made it to
division one because very often we we
know all these Grand Masters but again
and again we keep saying they're not
these big household names they don't get
invitations to these top level
tournaments and then when you got a
division two or you've got a planes
you've got these opportunities to
actually fight to play against the big
boys in division one it means so much
and I think that celebration was exactly
a reflection of that iterizaga one of
the strong Grand Masters finally getting
a chance to fight it out with the best
in the world 100 I mean it's been cases
in the past where uh some players have
actually turned up with cheerleaders
have you seen that I think there was I
can't remember the Russian player who
did it but he turned up a long time ago
is that something I thought you were
talking about Phil Hellmuth recently at
the World Series
no but should we get I agree with what
both of you said I think the emotion was
real this opportunity means so much to
him but also I would say that there's
something about the online format that
in this modern sort of evolution of the
game has been fun because we probably
wouldn't see players pump their fist and
scream in a quiet Hotel Ballroom
somewhere right the opportunity for
these guys to really Express their
emotions kind of comes out in the
comfort of their own home whether it's
Magnus put his leg up and whatever
whatever was going on yesterday the
Netflix and chill what's that or whether
it's the emotion and again obviously
we're in the we're in the business of
online chess and we're excited to see
where the game is going and growing but
I really believe that that there's
something really special about what we
get to see here because you don't see
those emotions every day you don't get
to know them in this way and when they
react it's like oh that chess player
he's not just a quiet guy yeah he really
cares absolutely and do you think that's
also because the players are so
unguarded when they're just they're sort
of playing in their own Solitude they've
got a camera in front of them but no one
around and then you forget chess players
who are so guarded usually about their
emotions not really expressing what's
going on internally but you tend to
forget in that moment and really let it
out yeah I mean they're guarded on the
outside but in the inside they're going
absolutely crazy you know it's like
there's roller coasters going on there
they're sitting there like this but if
you could get a glimpse into their mind
it would be an explosion explosion I
keep saying that I'm like I don't know
man you don't know okay maybe that's
just my mind maybe I'm just freaking
some people out here but uh but Danny if
you I was thinking I don't know why but
the cheerleading aspect I could see you
being a cheerleader but I was just
wondering who who would you how would
you be here for you I'll tell you that
you're there for anybody anyone who
needs a cheerleader I'm there I'm there
just call me call me um all right back
to some of the chefs here we've got
Knight B5 we're cheering for tactics
David I see you working hard over there
maybe maybe you got a thought about the
uh the nature of this position Knight to
B5 I still like black C4 is hanging
isn't it yeah it looks like Jordan's
trying to bail out I think he's just
trying to trade off as many pieces as
possible maybe uh the match situation
too much in his mind and uh black does
have some tasty options as you mentioned
Danny uh first of all we can see a pawn
being grabbed uh there's also the kind
of simple old man option that I might
choose just Knight takes Knight and play
with a slightly better Pawn structure
here with black here white has doubled B
pawns and uh black has a king side
majority thanks to this e-born maybe for
example you can play a move like Bishop
C5 and you have this long-term Advantage
you can try and grind down but uh yeah
the key move
Bishop takes C4 here I think the idea is
to play Knight takes Knight and if I'm
not mistaken Bishop takes D4 uh the
whole idea here is a trick if Queen
takes Bishop then the white Bishop
scoots out the way Bishop takes born
check forcing the black king to react
and the black queen Falls of course not
a huge material advantage but a queen
better than blacks pieces so he's
relying on tactics to keep this one
together Jordan right now I like it
critical moment here for Eduardo to take
this decision does he go upon grabbing
or does he trade the knights on the
board and now we see he's also as
confused as we are in the studio about
what approach to have and once again
it's the math situation that determines
so much of what's going on on the board
and what is objectively perhaps what's
the best move
totally agree I think that's why he's
giving pause as you said he's giving a
big thing because this is your
opportunity to either continue the fight
or allow a massive simplification and we
know which one he wants which one he has
to go for so
the uh yeah yeah big moment big moment
and while uh Eduardo has a thing to
decide which direction he wants to go in
let's quickly check in with fat assiev
against Wesley still Queens have been
traded off an end game there but there's
some tension on the king side David yeah
some tension on the king side white has
a slightly better Pawn structure black
has doubled f phones and feather saves
last move is saying okay let's lock
things down long term my night might be
superior to your bishop or at least more
flexible when attacking uh weak pawns
and big question for Wesley so is
whether he allows things to lock up or
whether he trades Bishop for Knight
that's the only kind of peace and
balance right now and it's always a big
decision any capture especially in
endgame so Simon what do you think
Bishop takes Knight or keep the tension
uh that night looks quite nice actually
I mean I I would be tempted to to take
it off and just try to simplify the
position we we well is that saying that
all Rook endings are drawn and you do
remove some of the danger by capturing a
knight uh okay exchanging one pair of
Pawns first seems okay
um I I would capture it I mean Danny
would you would you take it or would you
keep it okay because I I was going to
steal the old Rook endings were drawn
line you stole my thunder but you're
right I think that if Wesley is playing
for a draw even if objectively uh
there's there's good things for white
when you take the Knight I think it
makes sense to get that off the board
also those doubled isolated pawns scare
me those just don't look good they don't
look fun to defend and I feel like more
pieces on the board makes it a little
harder to to do so so
I would take C4 no he doesn't Wesley
wants to kick the bishop more it's
interesting because the one thing we
will say is
Wesley hasn't been on grade four maybe
we're thinking he's nervous and wants to
draw the bishop is a better piece than
the Knight as long as there are
opponents on both sides of the board and
the one thing that doesn't immediately
meet the eye is white has this three on
two majority right you have these three
pawns versus two so I'm wondering if you
can safely push B5 and open up the
bishop as long as C5 doesn't become too
tender maybe Wesley thinks there's a
little more to play for here yeah still
that decision persists to take or not to
take it feels like white tonight's gonna
be super strong though in the center on
the move on a square like E5
so yeah I think I would uh I think I
would take it right after all those
things I said I'm like I I don't want to
let that Knight live I uh I think my
king could get in trouble on F6 if the
Knight comes to E5 so I agree Bishop
takes E4 seems what to be with the
doctor ordered yeah this is dangerous
though isn't it it's certainly I think
dangerous to Wesley I mean just the pawn
structure uh I mean pieces okay both
sides have got some Brooks which could
do some damage here but if you just look
at the pawns it's clear to see that
white has the better Pawn structure
um you have better Pawns in the center
blacks pawns on the king side make me
feel a little bit sick and um you know
it's a bit dangerous for Wesley here he
could if he loses this he is out let's
just remind everyone that you know this
is a really tense game there's no more
Second Chances now you lose now you go
home
um and what is already home is me but
you know you get you get the idea you
get it he can play with his cats
I think he's flexing the chess.com
Global championship trophy in the
background if I can by making out one of
those things clearly so um
plays 95 and note that the bishop can't
take A2 because of B3 trapping it so
just a quick visualization there
um and uh so I really like 95 yeah now
we can show it also there's a falcon C6
there's a fork on C6 yep so you got
double problems here maybe he should
have taken that I think he should have
taken the Knight
yeah it's too late now that black uh
Bishop just sitting pretty in the middle
of the board but it's thinner well it's
not just looks uh glorious and it's
white who's playing for two results here
it feels like there's no risk at all for
fedisev okay King E6 nice move getting
ready to kick away that white knight by
pushing a pawn to F6 but it does allow
White's Rook to enter the seventh rank
maybe root to G7 uh comes to mind I
think it looks like a great thing to
come to mind Rook G7 is calling our name
not my name in particular
big fish
get that Rook into G7 but then are there
ideas for black to try to create some
contemplary of his own a David try and
challenge that Rook on the G line it's
the open only open Line in the position
you really want to be the one that grabs
it and yes you're giving up a Pawn on 87
but you want your rook in
for example Tanya if I take this Pawn
now you come in and it's a bit scary I'm
not sure where the white king goes front
of the pawn or back of the pawn maybe
you jump forward and try and hide on D2
and yeah counter play you can play a
move like F6 it's not one-way traffic
here that's for sure
I like it often you just have to go
inside right G7 yeah will he go passive
defending he pushes the Knight first
yeah okay
and big question do you have to step
back with the Knights but at least the
bishop can take uh again if it needs to
and another chance yeah another option
will be to block the seventh rank maybe
you can put the Rook on D7 and challenge
uh the piece that's infiltrated the G7
it was nice C4 but still your idea of
Rook D7 that's a that was a nice kind of
calm sometimes you have to be calm in
the face of danger and knights can scare
you right it looks like the Knight is
forking everything but actually there's
nothing to it here black is holding yeah
holding solid we shouldn't doubt Wesley
too much this is his type of position uh
where it's simple where it's just about
two three move ideas at a time
and uh it's very good with the Strategic
uh decision so I'm not gonna blame him
for not taking that night earlier it
looks like he's got another chance over
the next few moves
and if the Rooks come off the board
prediction time is this heading to an
Armageddon yes or no
Wesley is head in hand he's focused I
know we're talking about the moves on
the board and and being a little
critical but you can see how much he
wants it and cares I think he's going to
send this to overtime I think he's going
to hold this and we get free chess
yeah I agree with Danny and we are
agreeing far too much for my liking but
scary I do agree with Danny I think it
is uh heading that way I mean Wesley is
so far defending excellently it's not
over yet I mean maybe I'm basing this a
bit on the players because if Magnus was
white here I'd be like oh I'd be
thinking no way just resign just reside
that's it yeah just resign and actually
even here there's a lot of play left
right because I mean if the Rooks come
off the board it's probably still a draw
but I don't know I I would not be
comfortable being black here uh Black's
probably all right but those pawns are
still weak on the king side so it's it's
not over yeah
what do you reckon I mean you take
weight every time here right just
because uh it feels like black is the
one fighting for his life black doesn't
have too many active winning ideas but
yeah I still trust Wesley I still
believe
despite being slightly off form that
he's got this one under lock and key
anyway
didn't hang the ape on there I was just
about to say will you challenge The Rook
trade before the a pawn is defended
because you actually could have done it
because A2 would have traded for F5 so
anyway that was a a big decision I think
it's a decision that says again fedo
save also still playing for a win here
like you said David that you would you
would choose white uh but Wesley quickly
responded A5 and look there's no there's
no serious time disadvantage here yes
it's a minute but both of these players
are going to enter time pressure at the
same time so um
this game this game is exciting yeah it
just feels like a winning plan it's the
hardest thing for both players just so
blocked right now Tanya
absolutely David it is photos here but
with the slight advantage in the
position the better night and the better
Pawn structure will it be enough for him
to take this in the rapid potion
meanwhile in the other game action is on
Eduardo druzaga has he managed to create
chances for his comeback I see the eval
Bar says that black is indeed slightly
better hair piece activity David peace
activity better Pawn structure it's a
few small things that do add up and if
we do see a trade of Bishops we could
see something called the Irish pawns
where white has tripled Pawn stacked up
on the B file and yeah black has a poor
majority the danger here for iterizaga
is that too many pieces get traded it
comes down to a rook end game and as
you've all pointed out Rook end games
have that drawish tendency but yeah it
feels like now or never for a tourism he
needs something on the next few moves
maybe turning it into something more
tangible like a pawn game or he needs to
get into an end game that he can
guarantee there's still life left
Advantage objectively but is it enough
I'm not 100 sure
I think not a huge margin for error here
I mean he's done a great job though just
to get this position with the black
pieces I mean I I don't oh there we go
it is pretty that one I mean I wish
there was another Pawn just behind that
but uh three pawns is enough right and
uh it is called the Irish pawns and uh I
think it's because uh it happened in
Olympiad and uh an Irish player had the
free pawns and then he played against uh
someone who also had the free pawns and
he lost both times so it didn't really
work very well for him
um but I'm not sure I'd be I think
that's is that why they're called the
Irish pause I think it was Eamon Keon an
Irish player who had it but he might
have to fact check that at home but uh
they look pretty can we just sit back
and enjoy them for a moment yeah just
have a little glass of water and you
know look at those pawns Simon you're
saying pretty to me they look pretty
ugly yeah well that's what I mean yeah
pretty ugly yeah they don't look pretty
it's only a mother could love as they
say uh the the B3 Pawn is hanging but
iterizaga played Queen C7 it's kind of a
disciplined move there you he wants to
guard E5 guard d8 and guard the seventh
rank that was the only thing the queen
wasn't doing there right and and so now
the question is can white go for Rook D5
laugh in the face of the back ring
Checkmate we know that that can get you
in trouble sometimes
uh or does white find another move so I
I actually really like Queen G7 I agree
with Tanya the pawns are so ugly that
iterizaga can play this game out and at
some point have have very good practical
chances we'll likely win all three of
those pawns maybe even for just the A7
Bond so we'll see
I mean actually Queen end games look
very dangerous here for white king of
poor nine games at dead loss Rook end
games might be the only uh Solace here
but getting the Queens off is not going
to be easy until you mentioned it uh
Danny White's King needed some breathing
space so Milton's given it some lift but
Harry to the rescue always
always and that was the right Advance
too because that was more than just free
the free the back rank that was actually
H5 and H6 and I really like that idea
because it's it's the alpha zero plan
for the win and that's how Jordan
creates chances for his opponent to
blunder right you put the opponent H5
and H6 and now in the time Scramble with
only four minutes left eterizaga down on
the clock again that I really like this
move H4 I love it too and if black gets
greedy captures on B3 then suddenly you
could see the Contours of a mating
attack against the black king if there's
one lands on H6 serious counter play so
again I like what it's it's done he's
pushed his Harry Pawn uh his block this
always seems like a very good first
reaction I mean if anyone pushes their
uh their Harry Pawn towards you just
block it just block it you know I I try
this all the time I like move one two 50
30 70. I'm almost pushing Harry and if
my opponent ever blocks it I'm like okay
back to the drawing board but it it is
if you're at home and you're wondering
how to deal with Harry which probably
not a lot of people do wonder about but
just block it and uh good move right
this is a good move here at least I
think yeah yeah
I agree Simon you talked about Harry
what do you call uh triplets those bee
pawns right now oh that's a good
question yeah famous triplets the free
Musketeers because they're a bit Mucky
just made that up I don't know uh help
me bucket deers
yeah the free birdie tears
um we need some help there hello Barney
and birdie yeah Billy Barney but that's
not bad not bad all right well we are we
are clearly deliberate some high level
chess analysis but we didn't have
history you just made up a new Pond name
with the Musketeers if we go with it
um I think we need chat to chip in with
some better suggestions I think so yeah
yeah chat let us know help us out but uh
meanwhile yeah it's one-way traffic it's
a tourism here uh playing for the win
and minimal risk so dream scenario but
still you wouldn't in it and the big
question will it be enough is always the
burning one here for either Saga because
a draw will not cut it it will mean the
end of his Road in the aim chest rapid
he has to find a way to get more in this
position we will check back with this
let's go back to the end game that we
had with the Vladimir fettuccv against
Wesley so Vladimir photo save was the
one who was pushing for the advantage is
that still the scenario or has Wesley
made progress I don't think it is
anymore and it's funny because even
though it was a risky decision at the
time keeping the bishop versus the
Knight had ambition to it right and that
this is maybe the the idea Wesley
started long ago when he played team G7
King F6 look at the King on the queen
side there's a three on two majority we
talked about it and there's real chances
here especially when you now add guess
who's up on the clock whoa Wesley was
down a minute and a half now he's up a
minute and I don't know I mean maybe uh
maybe Armageddon isn't all that Wesley's
looking for here yeah so Wesley type of
position we've said it and uh there's
also this idiom that's uh even the worst
Bishop is as good as the best Knight and
flex Bishop controlling the White Knight
right now oh risky decision from FedEx
to put a Pawn on a light Square to block
Black's King's path towards the queen
side
feels like yeah Wesley's been making the
progress It's just again whether there's
a breakthrough or not Black's Bishop is
slightly tied down so can't go Pawn
hunting yet
do we see any breaks
the drama here it's funny because we had
a stat coming into this into this
matchup shockingly to all of us Wesley
so and Vladimir Fido save have never
played in Rapid in In classical rapid
but I pulled up because I know I've seen
these faces play each other before and
my memory was right that they both took
turns knocking each other out and the
fish a random World Chess Championship
on chess.com over the last few years in
2019 it was Wesley so who sent fedo save
home and everyone remembers he went on
to win actually here in Oslo beat Magnus
Carlson to become the first ever
fisherman and World Champion and then in
2022 a lot of people forgot that
phariseev was the one who sent him home
and so these two guys have a little bit
of a history maybe it wasn't in
classical traditional chess but these
two guys have a history of knocking each
other out so let's go as much it's fun
yeah it makes sense why the first one
ended in a draw and this looks like it
very well could be headed that way a
really nice Point made there that even
though white on the queen side has a
Pawn on the light Square it's difficult
for blacks Bishop to get there because
of the doubled pawns that black has on
the F line on the file with whitesnite
is it still a game though for two
results with Photoshop always having
these two pawns on the F line and the
Knight jumping to C4 as a resource
foreign
we all have to play endings I mean I I
kind of think it's free results now
right I mean uh yeah just because if you
look at the left-hand side of the board
the Queen side uh that that move that
whites had to play okay maybe they're
gonna go for a draw here could be could
be heading that way the game ends yeah I
mean well we're going to see how
ambitious fedexv is I guess now
um is FedEx going to keep trying to push
this one okay well my question is
whether Wesley is going to play Rook G6
that would be the one try for him
because if the trade happens the H Pawn
helps but we also have we have
excitement everywhere here yeah we let's
just wait to see if Fellowship decides
to actually repeat this position because
that means this game ends I agree if you
guys can't you do it's a big critical
moment here yeah I think it's going to
oh he's going for a win oh okay he
doesn't want the draw look at Wesley he
kind of perked up there and smiled a
little bit maybe that was good by him
too he's like all right you want more
let's do this thing does he want to
bring the Rook around to the the queen
side I mean that's the only thing I can
see here but this check makes a lot of
sense right wow so uh we might have a
draw another way though yeah yeah yeah
each spawn Under Fire
making his intentions very clear he
wants to go for the win in this end game
and the other player who needs to go for
the win is Eduardo teruzaga we're
getting big updates from our other game
Let's quickly jump to that one this is
going to go on for a while and here we
are can Eduardo do it in this queen Pawn
end game oh I'm not so sure the queen
side pawns still ugly they still exist
those uh bee pawns for white but they
are canceled out by blacks Queen side
pawns if you just assume that they all
cancel each other out then it would be a
draw three versus two on the king side
is actually a very simple draw in a uh
Queen and porn end game so it's all
about whether iterizaga can combine play
on both sides of the board can he slowly
pick up those weak white pawns while
maybe uh going for some checks against
the white king creating a passport on
the king side
I'm a bit skeptical I've got to say I I
am too I think that whatever chances had
whatever chances Eatery Saga had I think
left him when he actually traded traded
the Rooks earlier just because they
needed to keep as many pieces on the
board as he could I mean we're about to
see a repetition in front of us and not
the kind he tirizaga wants because he
doesn't get another chance in Armageddon
if this one's a draw
I absolutely hate Queen endings I really
really don't like them they're far too
complicated for my small mind uh I mean
whatever I get in them I'm never sure
where to put the Queen the king there's
so many checks only possibilities and
actually if you look at computers
computers are so good compared to the
best humans and that's where they really
show their dominance in in one aspect
over humans and queen endings and I mean
Magnus nepo are famous for their Queen
endings but they're really tricky to
play and obviously black has to try
everything here and here he goes he's
gonna try I do like that he's trying
he's got to try to get a some kind of
past pawn and uh the white King's very
exposed so it's always going to be loose
to a check there's a threat of that
Harry pawn it would be kind of poetic if
Harry came in and won the game I feel in
every game of chess so biased you're
always rooting for the age Pawn to have
the last say but Queen C4 was a very
good move by Jordan just holding the
fort literally like an invisible force
field and electric fence across the
fourth rank you shall not pass
now the downside for black is what as
well is that he's made his own King
slightly Weak by trading off those pawns
the black king is also susceptible to
some checks later on nothing yet I like
this move from a tourism when in doubt
just stop the opponent's checks just
centralize your queen but uh yeah still
the winning technique the winning uh
strategy here remains a mystery Queen
back to C2 Jordan just yo-yoing back and
forth waiting with the White Queen this
could go on forever it's probably got to
get his King in I guess at some point
black uh he doesn't want to move his
King Force he's going to try everything
else but I'd imagine he's got to get his
King and I mean let's remember if the
Queens just come off the board this is a
good way to evaluate things you should
be trying to do if you remove the Queens
from the board I think black is just
quite easily winning because
um black
um will get a pass Pawn on the king side
so uh so that's that's something to
worry about yeah something to worry
about meanwhile eturizaga may be setting
up some check mating ideas against the
white king which has sidelined itself on
H3 a bit strange here this one is going
to be a long
still two result game but needs the win
at all costs
Queen D3 just stopping any checks
Jordan's still in control three seconds
on the clock for Eduardo idrisaga he
needs to find a way to win this one
there is also a big action and big
update on the other board as the three
saga continues to fight in this queen
and pawn end game should we quickly just
check into yeah we we should because
there may have been a moment that could
have sent one of the players home that
wasn't played David if we if we can
quickly pull up analysis because now we
are truly deadlocked we see a 50 50
result but a few moments ago Wesley
actually blundered with the move Rook G7
check and for some reason fedosev in
this moment chose to retreat rather than
bring the king to H4 and the reason is
that once the king advances there's
threats of Rook D5 attacking both of the
pawns and it's actually not possible for
Wesley to deal with all of those threats
maybe he calculated rookie seven and
sort of panicked on the on the pawn
trade but this position had winning
chances
yeah this has big winning Chances with
that King activating and for some reason
the big fish in the big moment went
backwards it's pretty strange you've got
a usual King I mean it's the Forrest
Gump King yeah run run for us run yeah
the game Sorry front forest Run is the
other game
oh yeah you're just too quick today I'm
too slow today but yeah you've got to
use the king and the King's gotta run
into an opponent's position so
surprising he didn't consider this when
he's trying to win most of the game it's
funny because if we depending on what
happens maybe we'll get to ask him what
he calculated there if he ultimately
goes on to win but I think now we will
see a draw so that means that means we
should probably go back to the game that
is likely to send a player home but
indeed there was a big moment here we're
gonna get Armageddon I think between
these two and uh and there we have it
yeah just when in doubt go forward with
the King just go active I think is a
good rule in all end games if you have a
choice
but this is uh the other game I think
we've been here before this is the
second time we've seen this position
I said when in doubt go forward with the
King but is he doing here is there a
Checkmate is there some ideas
okay he moves okay where's the Checkmate
where's it's Queen H3
I I don't see it we're playing Guess the
Movie or maybe you can force the Queens
off when the king Retreats Queen G4 and
the Queens will come off Simon you're
getting your king and Portland game and
the King opponent is winning look at
iterizaga knows it he's perked up yeah
wow can you say double the Armageddon
double the fun not just
like Jordan
completely winning shaking his head in
disbelief
absolutely wild at Jordan play It's
funny by the way King H4 on both boards
for one of them it was correct for one
of them it was losing lol I literally
just said always push your king forward
if in doubts
commentators curse look at this everyone
the reason the king opponenting is
winning as Tonya said is black is
basically just up a free Pawn here it's
two on one and the double beep sorry
tripled b-pawns excuse me are useless
yeah they mean nothing at all right now
they're completely neutralized
results incoming wow we already have
result on the other game that one ended
in a draw so that's one Armageddon
confirmed and with this big blunder by
Jordan in a position that was he was so
in control we're heading for two armor
Gardens
bit disappointed though Edward is he
gonna do a crazy celebration come on I
want to see the chair I want to see the
chair at the end are we going to get it
it almost happened already with the the
way his body perked up I don't know that
he'll celebrate yet if he wins it or
again I'm gonna guess we see a big a big
fish yeah he's shaking right now he's
and he knows it and he's just advancing
the bond white spawns are too slow on
the queen side he's gonna Queen is
Jordan gonna resign
never resigned but uh
now would be a good moment yeah those
players know it but uh wow this is a
good time to resolve wow
I mean the bee pawns are triple but
they're not going to become free Queens
are they you know they're not going
anywhere I mean maybe if that pawn was
one square further for us it'd be a
little bit tricky but even then it's
probably still losing isn't it I think
he'll Chuck and take B4 and then we'll
see Jordan resign indeedy does with
Queen D2 I think after it takes B4 yeah
we will see the towel no okay now yeah
yeah fun will also decide the game
there's one more gone alive for black
and that's it Jordan resigns we are in
for double the fun as both these matches
go into Armageddon there we have the
bottle sip by iterizaga he survived the
scare he managed to win the game what a
comeback this was Jordan walking into
that one move blunder that David what
was the highlight for you well we have
to go through an action replay of that
blunder it was a commentator's curse
just as we were saying King H4 was the
winning move in the other Clash King H4
was the losing move in this one here it
was uh Jordan's move white to play and
any logical move any safe move such as
for example Queen to C3 check would have
kept the game alive it would have been a
long grind but King H4 was the losing
blunder walking onto a unfortunate
circuit here with the white king a check
forced It Forward another check forced
the king to sidestep but maybe this was
the check that Jordan had missed Queen
H3 forcing the white king away if you
step back when she thought is a killer
next move this Pawn drops with a check
so King E4 was forced and as we saw this
check was fatal anyway after the Queens
came off the board it was a simple case
of black much in the king forward and
winning the end game
King H4 being a decisive move in both
games Dani as you call that what are the
odds of that chances of that right and
we literally saw it in real time we were
following it it was one of those moments
where everyone had to be following it at
chess.com events because we couldn't
possibly keep up with the drama but King
H4 would have won for big fish and it
loses
for Jordan and we have uh we have double
art and get Armageddon I can't even say
it and I think I think same moment is
going to be double the fun let's take a
look at our score line what a donor on
it has been completely unexpected that
Wesley still Vladimir photos keeping it
peaceful two draws solid results there
goes into Armageddon but the big fight
on the Jordan board Jordan wins the
first one Eduardo wins the second one
manages to equalize the score and now we
will have the bids which will be coming
in soon and we're gonna have two armor
Gardens the fun is on in the losers
around round one but not just here it
was also a lot of fun when Magnus
Carlsen and David Howell took on each
other in an earthings challenge take a
look
yeah that really just looks like you're
moving upon like a knight
is this actually work
you tell me
I'm guessing I know you're guessing just
sometimes your guesses are right but
problem oh it's just a nice way to lose
the game
what's in my trap yeah Bishop D4 nice
he sees everything one thing is like the
play just this way but to watch this
must be
was the result of that game David that
looks like a lot of fun it was a lot of
fun uh yeah Magnus yeah I think he's
better at normal chest than he was with
everything's chest but yeah I won't
reveal anything yet you'll have to stay
tuned a smile though gives a little bit
away but you will find out what actually
happened and how it ended later today as
we'll say out the entire video of it
right now it is all about the Armageddon
that's coming up and we will come back
with all the aim chess action on the
other side of this break
foreign
[Music]
tonight
[Applause]
foreign
Meetup community and your local group on
meetup.com chess and get the chess
growing hashtag grow the game caddy
we've been having so much fun in
division one we've set ourselves up for
two armageddons and I believe you've got
a lot of fun updates from the other two
divisions as well that's right Tanya
earlier you asked me if we're gonna have
more night sacrifices and I came here
with a chess game in the division two we
can see here I'm in trouble to buy leads
against Jose Martinez Jose Martinez had
such an incredible chance to win the
second game now we can pull it the board
on the screen and we can check out that
game where he had a chance and probably
there was his chance as you can see now
he's losing the match fourth game is now
in progress so let's take a look now
can't wait to see what you have with us
Cathy this is the position take us
through yeah so here it is white to move
and the move that we're looking for is
Knight takes H6 it's a great sacrifice
but then when Pawn takes this night you
take the Rook F6
Queen text stroke and now the work on a
fade is not protected and white has way
too many pawns and it is winning
position however Jose decided not to
sacrifice the Knight here and instead of
this he played Knight to D6 and next he
gave the check and he decided to
sacrifice on H6 Bishop
so he changed a little bit strategy now
but this was a bad move now black takes
denied and white is again sacrifice in
the bishop on G7 and this is even worse
move after Queen D4 check this is very
as we're waiting for the Armageddon bids
by the players and of course the burning
question always is how low can you go
and how important is that going to be
for the players to try to get the black
pieces that's the big question David I'm
going to start with you how low can you
go no lower than around eight and a half
minutes we saw it yesterday around eight
minutes might be the golden number but
anything less than that it's just too
low it's too dangerous
so we saw yesterday not the best
Armageddon bid against Wesley so that's
The Sweet Spot you want to keep it
between eight and eight and a half
minutes that seems to be the sweet spot
and um I'm an important thing to
remember about Armageddon is that you
don't get any added time so in all the
other games there's time added on each
move but in Armageddon the time goes
very very quickly so losing on time is a
real possibility I think one of the
twists is considering what color you
might want to play I think for some
players there's also a bit of the
gamesmanship which is it's a must win
game and maybe I won't wait and more
time right and so I think that I think
that for some players they might
actually even be considering whether
they want the first move just depending
on the openings or the prep they might
have
and big reveal we are getting the bids
in for one of the matches and Vladimir
fellowship with 11 minute 24 seconds
goes down to Wesley's those bid within
eight minutes 27 seconds Wesley wins the
bid will start with 8 minutes 27 seconds
on the clock and the black pieces which
means with the white pieces Federal CF
has to win on demand Wesley gets the
draws but that's a big big margin there
I was gonna say like maybe that's a bid
that suggests fedo save was ready to
play white I mean he must have seen
Wesley bid 8 minutes and 12 seconds
yesterday so he knew Wesley was gonna do
something in that rain 11 minutes and 24
seconds says I'm okay playing white with
a Time match yeah he's confident isn't
he very confident there because uh
that's much higher than we've seen so
far uh so this is going to be yes really
exciting is he going to play the English
again don't you think I hope so I hope
so as well yeah I think it's just a
confident man he just packs himself
better safe he's been here before he's
done it before and uh he's probably
confident the way the games have been
going he has had the better of Wesley
for a lot of the first two games and he
just needs to put it together into a win
in this uh all decisive one now oh
Father served there with an aggressive
bid to try to get the white pieces he
said I'll be fine if I get black if I
have 11 minutes and 27 seconds when you
want it and it does reflect that he's
happy to start with the with the white
pieces regardless and we're also getting
the bids for the second match and a
similar storyline here Eduardo edruzaga
12 minutes 12 seconds that looks like a
one two one two random number for that
Jordan ran for us with 11 minutes and
three seconds this one also reflects
that both players fine with white again
it's funny not nearly as low as the bids
we saw yesterday or the one bit I guess
we saw yesterday
um I wanted to say maybe ferocet of saw
what Notre Beck did to Wesley when
Wesley was black and he wanted a he
wanted to maybe repeat that so that's
one thing to just quickly say about
Federal save but in this other match up
there again two very high bids
and David we've been seeing so many
armor Gardens throughout the Champions
Chester we've never seen these kind of
bids where the players are bidding over
11 minutes yeah I'm really surprised
maybe that's just a trend players more
confident in their white openings also
with uh The iterazaga Clash against
Jordan specifically both players one
with black but both players were happy
to have white in the Armageddon
strange Mind Games there
and we've got moves on the board as the
Vladimir photos here vastly saw
Armageddon does a kick off and it starts
with one Knight F3 no English this time
yeah I'm a bit surprised here I mean
like you're very confident with white
pieces then you play this load of boring
chunk hey this is this is the Hikaru
title Tuesday special speaking of title
Tuesday shout out to everyone playing it
today yeah I mean I don't know I mean
this stuff is tricky it's designed to
get weird positions and also it makes
your opponent think a little bit which
when they don't have a lot of time on
the clock maybe it's not the worst idea
maybe it is just very clever against
Wesley right because Wesley loves what
he knows his theory so well but he's
trying to get out of it quickly yeah
there's kind of plus points and negative
points the negative here is as Danny
says Hikaru plays this all the time in
Blitz and Wesley knows Hikaru really
well they've played each other countless
times so he will be aware of what he
should be doing Black's Bishop doing a
bit of a dance here uh the positive side
is it will cost Wesley a bit of time a
lot of pieces left on the board and then
Armageddon that tends to help so reverse
trumpowski here anyone who plays the
trumpowski you get these crazy lines
where the Knight comes to E4 and G5 so
not exactly the same and I I kind of
like white a little better here than
normally where black gets but a funny a
funny and weird position yeah it's
basically if you do a comparison white
just has this extra move B3 yeah and uh
it looks like it should be useful but
yeah interesting comparison there Danny
useful to try and get that Queen side
Bishop to develop on the long diagonal
also a really nice approach with no
increment on the clock it's sort of
getting Wesley into a zone that he might
not be super familiar with get him to
think early on so that the seconds run
by but Wesley so far keeping a close eye
on his clock and making moves quickly
and that's exactly what he needs to do
but this is getting quite crazy and
Harry the H1 as well Simon's celebrating
in the studio it's always a good move
right always
um it makes a lot of sense here because
uh there is a big threat now you're
threatening to just trap uh the bishop
on G6 and black only has one option
Black's got to fight that night there
he's gotta ask the question to the White
Knight what are you gonna do trying to
and now obviously when you see that B3
move coming into into good use and yeah
it's a very interesting position the
more I'm looking it's the more I'm like
uh yeah I'm actually glad they they kind
of went out of Mainline Theory to get
something a little bit more funky funky
chess uh non-theoretical yeah fresh
territory for both players and for
fathership he has to win with the white
pieces the other Armageddon is about to
start in just a few moments Eduardo
there is I got the English in this one
against Jordan Barn forest and once
again for Eduardo durazaga with white he
has to win the game on demand did you
guys did you guys as the English
gentleman here did you tell everybody it
was time to play play the opening named
after your countrymen I don't know I
mean but another King's Indian is going
to be on the board even though Jordan
Jordan did some good things in that
first game in this exact same line
although now we're getting a little
different we'll see nope same line I'm
surprised that white keeps pushing his
pawn and Center actually uh I have to
say David after that game did mention to
me that uh there's a move that I'd be
scared of eyes black just take the pawn
off keep it simple because you're giving
kind of black what he wants here uh
maybe it's the the computer's Top Choice
maybe it's the best move but just black
should be I you know Black's getting
everything he wants in this position I'm
really wondering why Jerry Saga went for
the same line I can't wait to see the
Improvement because the only thing that
justifies going for an approach where
you you know you got your bleep kicked
in in the first the first time that you
had this position if you're just joining
us Jordan won a really great game
appreciating the bleep there is
more often than I should admit but I
bleeped myself out and now we're getting
the same line what does eturizaga have
in store that's going to be an
improvement on the first game he lost
that's a big question right because that
felt like a Jordan van for a show that
attack was run forest run and that's
exactly what he did there David are we
seeing any any deviations from game one
there's been a small move order
deviation and uh it's not sure how much
of a difference it's going to make we
will see very similar ideas of black
playing on the king side a bit later on
white trying to cause some distraction
on the queen side here we go just again
slow build up but uh yeah odds to see a
tourizaga surely the scars of that
previous game uh will have a
psychological impact but he looks
confident he's played quite quick up to
this point both players have burned
around one minute and we will see when
white eventually decides to break on the
queen side there we go and featured chat
coming in hot with the uh making sure
ichirizaga has turned off auto Queen
just in case yesterday repeats itself if
you see the position on our board here
in the studio whoa we have a different
line and a different move order
yeah and whoa means something different
here uh oh Jordan leans in he knows he
messed that up
great I'm scared for that night at the
edge of the board there's no way home
for that black knight and you mentioned
look at it to rizaga he suddenly leaned
in Jordan head in hands is Jordan in
trouble yeah suddenly a tourism kind of
perked up he was like flexing he was
like yeah I caught you I've tricked you
and uh it feels like in the break
between the previous games and this one
he's done a bit of homework and he's set
a trap suddenly like you say Tanya it's
all about this Black Knight on A4 it's
trapped there's no way home and that
might have been brilliant yeah it might
have simply been brilliant maybe uh Eva
Eduardo or maybe someone he knows said
okay you can repeat this line but here's
a great idea just attack that Knight
quickly and come in with this idea uh
because he could have done something
very similar in in the game that he he
actually lost and the the problem is
Dave is pointing out here is that the
Black Knight is just stranded
um you know it's a very simple idea
switch to Rook take the Knight go a
piece up and wow I mean that that could
be it simply could be the end of Jordan
we could just see a walkover in this
game almost I don't see any way to get
this night out to uh uh kind of just
extra extricate this night from A4 if
the pawn pushes forward then firstly
what can take this Pawn secondly you
could just capture here maybe and go
after the night anyway and okay the
evaluation bar goes down slightly but
still winning for white Jordan has to
try this and there we go he does play
the move C6 I also mentioned this Pawn
is up for grabs if he needs to uh if he
wants to play it safe and just go up
material into razaga huge success in the
opening fascinating I've been I've been
sitting here just speedily going through
the variations comparing this game in
Armageddon to the first game they had
and really a very tricky little move
order Changed by ichirizaga you're right
he did hit the prep when he played H3 in
King H2 just to throw off Jordan there
anyway we we obviously have other games
to get to we have two very exciting
games but really impressed with the
aturi's August Choice gutsy move and one
that looks like it might be about to pay
off yeah that's move number 18 and
Eduardo terizaga in driver seat has
managed to trap Jordan's Knight at the
edge of the board he's gonna end up
winning material in this position we'll
come back and check in how he manages to
convert Dan Jordan save this one let's
jump over to the other Armageddon as
action and hot action is on in this one
that's a crazy opening David yeah a
crazy opening and it almost looks like a
mirror image of the previous game as
another closed blocked Pawn structure in
the center here White Knight on C4 looks
nice and pretty but might get kicked
around as well uh we do have white with
the bishop pair but that tends to count
for Less when the center is closed and
I'm struggling to choose a side I love
this last move from FedEx open up the
position for your Bishops and Simons he
still has a four or five minute
Advantage here yeah and that that is
massive you know if uh if one side in
Armageddon gets under like three minutes
it's time to panic because they don't
get any extra time and uh Wesley is
getting very close to to to that point
uh White's breaking out here I mean I
still think Wesley has an okay position
he's got a good hold with his Knights
his Knight now attacking the bishop is
ready to come into the Central Square so
it's seems just very finely balanced at
the moment could go either way this one
I think it's an interesting strategy
right now because you see that Federal
saves plan of playing something that
Wesley wouldn't be prepared for is
paying off on the clock but on the board
you also objectively would say that
Wesley's doing okay right it's a
fighting game and he's got plenty of
chances so the gamble isn't full is in
full swing here and um I think you
called it Simon if something doesn't
happen good for Wesley in the next few
or four minutes now you're in trouble
because you're getting under that three
minute Mark it's an Armageddon this is
Casino style chess uh Danny right here
with the bishop pair an open position
and Wesley so with five and a half
minutes on the clock I'm gonna say it
this is gonna be flagging penetrating
Bishops there going across the board
aren't they the white Bishops they're
just really stopping Black from getting
the king safe as well this is maybe an
issue right yeah could well be an issue
for the black king FedEx just uh moves
his Queen forward he's hinting that he
might Castle on the queen side a bit
dangerous over there as well but keeping
his shot his options open and yeah Tanya
you said flagging in a blocked Pawn
structure that's the perfect scenario
it's going to take the opponent so long
to break through so long to trade
everything off uh we could get well get
to that point later but uh Wesley
dealing with the issue that Simon
mentioned blocking the light squared
Bishop so that the black king can run
over to safety later on on C8
still very tense so far Philadelphia's
gamble of fighting for the white pieces
seems to be paying off it's uh it's
paying off he's up on the clock he's
he's also doing fine on the board
um this exchange here if both Kings end
up castling long
um I think actually both they make the
players feel better with what's on the
board but maybe it makes Wesley feel
worse with with the clock because
because now he's uh he's just down on
time and there isn't a lot of fight in
this position
there's a lot of fight in this position
and we want to jump back to this but
let's get a quick look at the other
board we left it feeling thinking that
the three Saga completely in driver's
seat trapping a knight on the board but
David it's still alive it's it's still
alive and it's actually just given up
its life in order to just give white
some beautiful tactics right now I think
a tourism is calculated perfectly we
look at the evaluation bar it says
totally winning white right now is a
piece for two pawns down but look at
this next move bang E5 the white light
Square Bishop has opened up and the
black queen has run but both of Black's
Knights look a bit loose or it feels
like this one is hanging by a thread
maybe white can just play a quiet move
here and it feels like so many threats
black surely won't be able to survive
all of them
so I mean we're seeing the same momentum
of yesterday
the person who has to win wins with
black gets the white pieces in
Armageddon and right now is getting the
job done yeah I mean very impressive
play from white I mean especially uh I
think you mentioned this Danny that he
lost horribly with the same opening a
couple of games ago but he repeats it he
finds a nice way to change things up and
gets a dominating position and the only
thing he's got to do here is just put
the ball in the back of the net and uh
how does he do that does he grab the
Rook here is that a good idea I mean
that weakens his King a little bit it's
a bit risky going for that or or you
know just you still got to be accurate
in this position yeah I would lose this
obviously
I don't think so Simon I think you would
clean this up and I think white should
take the Rook why not yeah free material
and uh right now the material balance is
rook and two pawns for white versus two
nights but Black's problems do lie with
those Knights for example I'm wondering
how black extricates this one it looks
like it's falling off the board next
move the problem for black is you'd love
to go on an attack against the white
king you'd love to land your knight in
G4 but as soon as the black queen moves
away there's no more pin along the
e-file and suddenly this Knight drops
off too and yeah I just don't see how
you can hold this together you can push
a pawn forward maybe keep this Knight
alive by retreating but this looks
hopeless just trade off these Rooks
bring the White Queen forward this looks
over
like just uh yeah never put a knight in
the corner of the board just no
coordination at all in Black's Army he
has taken oh no he hasn't taken the Rook
yet I mean David if knights in the room
are dim what are knights in the corner
what are they they're just really stupid
aren't they I mean there's that
expression nights on the rim of the
board as we see black snipe there is dim
but that night is just another night
it's not a night it's a very bad night I
mean uh very very bad night what's the
definition of this when is a knight a
pony one is it a unicorn and one is it a
dragon what is it a donkey when is it a
donkey that's a donkey that is
definitely a donkey nothing against
donkeys lovely animals but that is a
donkey of the night but they're slow and
yeah they're not the the speediest of
steeds
true edge of the board it's about to
fall off the world right there and we
see he hasn't yet taken a decision
taking his time here thinking about this
moment he probably does feel that it's
critical calculates a fuel line and it's
in the bag will we see the classic fist
bump
I think we will and I think now
ichirisaga is doing what Jordan did to
him in the game we were applauding right
he's managing his clock because normally
when you have the edge on time in these
Armageddon battles you want to flex it
but if your opponent gives you a winning
position you're still playing chess
right you just want to win the game on
the board so he tirizaga taking a beat
he's going to calculate it through
um I just saw the eval bar swing wildly
and so is favor so I'm not gonna lie I'm
I'm my eye caught the fact that black is
maybe winning in the other board but uh
iterizaga looks like he should be
getting the job done here let's take a
look at that uh let's bring up a
Fantasia versus Wesley saw as we do see
a wild swing there and wow David
white is down in exchange what's going
on here I see a Pawn on G6 this is crazy
yeah this is crazy of did blunder he did
uh initially let this one get out of her
hand just giving up a Pawn on the queen
side allowing The Black Queen in but
suddenly things have switched things
have turned potentially because he's
trapped that black queen and given up
some material this one the evaluation
bar the computer says black is winning
but it's a key moment now there's some
huge threats and look at this beautiful
move I was about to say maybe this is
the only winning move giving away a pawn
uh actually White Queen didn't go and
grab this Pawn
first taking some other points with
track there's a queen a queen coming to
H1 if you're not checking an H2 Pawn
that um you're a wizard Harry
yeah he found the key move he's just
trying to deflect away the White Queen
from any attacks and then the Blackford
will enter the action and I think
White's King will be doomed
and the problem is why he can't even get
a draw here
um because that's not enough white has
to win uh to go through because it's
Armageddon and that means Perpetual
checks you know they don't count you
know that's I didn't even realize that
Simon you just you called it right there
this queen D4 Queen D5 it's over at this
point the eval bar is almost irrelevant
because White's only chance to stop a
queen is to take a perpetual
and that's not good enough I have black
ones you can even try for more by going
a king to B8 but instead look at this
black does want more in this position
but we see the evalubar creep up that
last move David was not a big mistake I
think it was a safe move but not the
best one it felt like there was a win
for black I didn't quite see it but uh
yeah retreating with the queen suddenly
the White Knight is coming out to a
really beautiful Square on C4 gosh
suddenly all three results possible
again
investing back in trouble especially
when you remember he has no increment
and he's under three minutes a night is
the worst piece I would want to face in
this scenario
to win this match uh he was close to
winning one inaccuracy and fatassia back
in the game but still a big clock
Advantage for fedorship
and uh I did just check Wesley was
winning but it wasn't super easy uh
maybe not so natural for a human to keep
the black queen offside so retreating
the black queen was a mistake and now
the game is alive again it's funny
though because I like what Wesley did
the moment he played Rook G7 I I wanted
to applaud it because he said look I
just need a draw so let me just let me
just repeat moves here and make white do
something risky with E5 right make white
mess up the position and by by making
sure I don't beat myself on the clock uh
both of us trying to beat each other on
the clock the other one looks like it's
about to finish let's see if we can get
to the finish of that game as iterizaga
he's close to taking this match will
this be one of the biggest comebacks
that we've seen yeah impressive stuff
from ituruzaga he played a move that
wasn't on my radar a beautiful move
actually just two turns ago let's jump
in and show this uh the current position
has changed slightly and it's because if
we backtrack in this position where I
was predicting Bishop takes Rook which
was strong as well he found another
nasty blow Bishop takes H6 instead
jumping out the way so that the Rooks
connect and protect each other meaning
that this Knight is attacked if the
bishop was captured for example then
Pawn takes Knight is now possible and
next move white crashes through uh at
the very least can take this Rook anyway
so Bishop takes Pawn beautiful blow
winning move and after a bishop trade I
think the same thing still winning just
uh take this rook and take it in the
corner and now this Knight will fall
over the next few times still black is
paralyzed yeah I mean I I guess black
can hold on to that Knight by pushing
his Pawn uh in that position so I mean
it's disgusting it's probably losing but
um it's maybe
maybe playable I say that and I don't
really believe what I'm saying uh but
you you can't lose that Knight and these
these nights are just terrible anyway uh
wise pawns too strong it should be
winning but it's still I'm I'm a bit
surprised your evaluation bar is so high
in this position
um I guess it just reflects the material
balance it's rook and four pawns if I'm
counting correctly it's a lot of points
yeah
each other's back on the edge of the
board though right those donkeys got to
stick together when they're they go in
the uphill climb
yeah I think the only source of counter
play we should mention is that this Pawn
is hanging yeah and uh black could
launch a mating attack if white isn't
careful so uh still got to keep your eye
on the ball and wow your didn't go for
tactics Knight takes Pawn uh played
threatens a nasty night Fork but this is
blocked by Queen's E4 a double attack
and this could be the death knell for
black yeah how do you defend the Rook
the Knight and the Knight on A4 can't
and uh now I think you can just take
this Knight if I'm not mistaken and go
into a very safe position two extra
Pawns
maybe that's better Rook takes Knight
will be met by a nasty night check but
you just take this one off the board as
well and two extra points for white this
should be the end psychologically that's
interesting by Jordan because do you
really want to go for this when you know
black has drawing chances and you're
also now down on the clock look at
what's happened in this Armageddon
switcherooski if that's a thing to say I
mean I I actually I'm applauding Jordan
for the Practical sort of decision here
because that's a psychologically
difficult thing to do to invite a major
piece ending where you know there's
drawing chances I suppose white could
take the night here couldn't he as well
and just I mean in the middle and do the
same thing as you just said but yeah
you're right I mean it's uh it's it is
two Pawns in the ending though I mean
um so it's it should be winning for
white but I mean we're component endings
there's always some chances maybe that's
the most practical move Queen takes
Knight and there we go it's on the board
small drawings chances for black but the
problem is white has majorities on both
flanks
and what's going to grind this one out
we will check back on this the other
Armageddon I think it's about to end
let's quickly jump over to our other
game Wesley so against fedosiev
this one it looks like it's about to end
in a draw which means Wesley will go
through and ferocia will be eliminated I
mean an eye on it and Wesley Found A
Swindle that gave up The Rook for the
night in the pawn to get this queen and
pawn ending so first of all huge props
to Wesley for doing that knowing the
odds of the game or that a draw means he
wins
um and uh I think I think with that he's
is he pre-moving he borderline can right
that's how easy the position is so
Wesley using the Practical Dynamic of
the arm record of the Armageddon format
to force a draw the only danger is his
clock right and he's and he should have
enough time here I mean uh let's
remember there's no increment so you
know fedexv has got to not hit the 50
move Rule and win on time
um and it I think I mean of course it's
a draw even if you even if you lose a
pawn here it's probably very close to a
draw which you can't lose what happens
if the 50 move rule gets hit
automatically it'll be automatically
cleaned and I was just about to check on
the moves of that because they're
actually pretty close to it yeah they
actually don't have many more moves for
last porn capture uh was on move 72 so
we're already just a few moves away from
that 50 move rule 37 needs to move upon
or capture a piece in the next five
moves otherwise this game's
automatically a draw
well wow he's going forward with the
King but he's run out of time three more
moves and we're gonna see any result any
second now
[Laughter]
since the game ends in a draw you have
to feel for a feathers here right now it
means it is the end of the road for
Vladimir in the aim chess rapid
Fellowship taking it and he continues
his run action is still on here action
still on here Randy it's an Infamous for
component game we'll find out the truth
behind where the overall component games
are drawn but here it looks like white
has
a big Advantage pushing that Beast Pawn
forward one more Square will paralyze
the black pieces Black's Rook now is
eternally stuck behind that pass pawn
and the black king will be stuck on this
Square pretty much can white Now
activate his King it looks like it
should be a simple process of just
attacking the black Rook forcing the
black Rook back and the white king
activates white will be able to create a
pass Pawn on the king side here be
careful which Pawn you push later but it
feels like this should be winning
I think a matter of time now yeah it
must be winning and of course at this
level uh you know um I I think they know
we're going to know how to convert it
into win the white king getting very
active here it's got some squares it can
jump into on the king side and it's
heading toward those squares and as
David says you just gotta you've got to
be careful what porn uh you use because
to advance as white because in some
situations you you can fall into a draw
position I mean maybe you advance
um you can maybe Advance either the H
Pawn or DF Pawn to win this one as long
as you take with the King but it's you
just have to be a little bit accurate
but we should probably show the
instructor point of why the black king
is frozen there just for people tuning
in saying why can't the black king run
over and help and I think it's an
important tactic that maybe not all of
our viewers know that if black moves
they can go ahead there's this back door
trick where the Rook slides over and now
when when you get a queen you win so
black has to take the pawn and that
allows a skewer so this is a a backdoor
Rook skewer that every every player
that's a mouse slip sorry but every
player must know this one and so that
that Dynamic is exactly why the end game
is winning for white because the black
king is frozen in the corner as as Simon
pointed out that said there there are
some tricky things here because
it's not exactly clear how to force the
king out of the corner either right
white has to advance the right pawns and
make the right exchange and and here
here we see H4 has been played yeah yes
I think all you do you go F5 and G5
right but I mean we're probably gonna
we're probably gonna see this happen and
uh It's tricky because if you didn't
know how to win this ending if you
didn't have the experience then you
could easily still draw this but these
guys are such high level that they know
exactly what to aim for and that's very
important you need to know the positions
to aim for and how to get there and uh
the clock one and a half minutes it's
borderline I would say uh you should
still have enough time but you need to
make the Breakthrough quickly you can't
just wait for 20 moves and then uh push
the pawn so already it's like a big
decision he's trapped his own King as
well you can't move the white Rook you
lose your V Pawn you can't move the king
you'll get checkmated so you have to
commit now the audience defending well
gotta say I think this is just winning
those in it the winning plan as long as
you because you're going to get a past
Pawn very shortly and that's the the key
people and actually forcing to go in the
position that Dany actually pointed out
and uh black will shortly have to move
his King away from the safe Zone what I
was going to say earlier when you said
if you don't know this end game
um you're gonna find out because if
you've never seen in a game like this
converted this is really really well
done by uterizaga when that g-pawn
pushes you'll have to take it as black
and then white will sacrifice the F Pawn
forcing the exact same trick that we
showed earlier where the Rook can leave
the B8 square with Tempo so you're about
to see some instructive chests here if
you didn't know this Rook ending you can
add it to your book yeah Freddie the
f-bond that's the passer you want to
invite the back door tactic that you
pointed out earlier with the Rook moving
out of the way clearing the way for the
bee pawn and it seems like Eduardo knows
exactly what he's doing but will 70
seconds be enough to pull it off
at this point yes because I think this
breakthrough is happening next move you
can almost remove G5 don't do it just in
case black takes the white V Pawn but uh
yeah G5 is the Breakthrough and with one
minute left that pawn is going to cost
black is Rook it's just about whether
you can Checkmate later with a rook uh
in time so one minute should be fine but
yeah very instructive as you mentioned
Tanya Freddy the f porn does it but if
you were left with just a g Pawn with
white Black's king would be fine perched
where it is so now we're gonna see the
Breakthrough G5
and Black's King will be dislodged from
G7 guaranteed over the next move or two
is Jordan gonna try to fly tiger I was
just gonna ask that question yeah it's
not gonna happen though is it I mean
Jordan doesn't like resigning right too
early and why not you know this is your
last chance you're going to be out of
the competition and uh it's uh it's
Armageddon it's Armageddon you know you
might as well play but he is he's well
aware that he's in a diabolical
situation here there's no way out now
and great great great technique here at
the end we call it technique and I hate
that because it's like you know you see
so many books you see so many videos and
one player just says it's just a matter
of technique when they get a winning
position and I've lost so many games
when it should just be a matter of
technique but the white king now just
has to attack the rook and it's 57
seconds game over yeah he has managed to
create Freddy the F Pawn as a passer
it's all about oh I think Jordan will
try to flag and will it be enough time
and now you can move the Rope the back
door attack as Danny called it in the
game can't pick up the people and you
lose the Rook will Jordan play this
I'm serious if he plays Rook H4 here
okay no
I'm waiting for a chance for him to take
advantage of the only move is the is to
pre-move Rook H7 I don't know I'm trying
to get inside Jordan's head here if if
the white king had gone to F4 black
could flavor it takes B7 and uh that
would have been a draw
one trap oh that's a nice yeah nice
trick David but uh the white King has
gone the whole way around like we'll
lose this rook and turizaga he actually
resigns he's got it already over you're
in one oh sorry wow Jordan
forgotten and look at the relief on him
what a match this has been he's getting
ready right now and we hope he joins us
soon what a match what a comeback by
teresaga we saw it twice right we saw a
player yesterday win with black on
command and then win with white in the
Armageddon this time we saw ichirizaga
win with black and then win with white
on command just absolutely awesome but
no one's done the crazy celebration as
we saw in the in his road to this event
so I did it last time feels like I
shouldn't be doing it again
oh God
that's what the kind of thing we're
thinking too soon because there's still
a lot of Chess to be played by three
Saga but he gets the job done today it
was a topsy derby match David take us
through the big moment yeah I just want
to recap that beautiful end game
technique from iterazaga some great
tactics earlier on to get the winning
Advantage but the way he finished it off
was textbook and there was just one trap
we mentioned it here white is checked if
you go to the wrong Square then actually
suddenly black is able to draw Rook
takes Pawn watch out for stalemate
resources this check no longer works
because after Rook takes Rook this is
stalemate and a dead draw uh instead of
course iterizago with great technique
marched his King over towards the black
rook and eventually we saw Jordan resign
Rook takes Pawn is met by a skewer on
the seventh Rank and that's why we need
to know our end game skills
what a win that was precision and a full
board awareness thereby teresaga Jordan
van first did not try and flag him there
sportsmanship and let's take a look at
the bracket as we will be starting with
the winner semi-finals match up in the
losers bracket it is Wesley so and
Eduardo iterizaga who moved forward to
the losers quarterfinals it's end of the
road for feather save and Jordan van
Forest it's been a tough week for Jordan
with the duck Championship losing in the
final in the playoff to Anish yesterday
a tough day against Magnus and today it
was so close but it didn't work out yeah
I know I think I said yesterday it's a
bit of out of The Frying Pan Into the
Fire for Jordan right after losing to a
niche in the Dutch championship and then
getting paired with the world champion
most people go to the losers bracket
when they're paired with Magnus Carlson
and Jordan of course was one of them and
uh so obviously we know Jordan's a great
player he's an exciting player we love
watching him but yeah a tough week right
now for the Dutchman
meanwhile the others of course continue
their run in the aim chess drafted and
Wesley so he's so winning in the
Armageddon also a great result and
exactly the confidence boost he needed
yeah confidence boost for Wesley just
the fact that he was able to stay solid
and make good decisions at Key moments
but he will still need to up his game
and uh this is the first step for him
Psy which was the more exciting
Armageddon for you
and I don't know both great weren't they
um I mean
it's hard to pick I can't really pick I
mean I just love Armageddon because you
never know what's gonna happen and uh
the time's ticking down they've both got
to a minute there I actually liked that
ending I don't normally say that I don't
normally get to the ending so I normally
either sacrifice all my pieces or or
Checkmate so it was nice to see an
ending for a change I'll give you the
car you you said you thought etorizaga
was going to get this one because of the
format for whatever reason and I was
with I was with David I thought that
Jordan would be the favorite but good
call on that ejuries August stuck it out
he did he did really well yeah I mean
his nerves were fantastic and uh just
the way uh that he did that preparation
I think that was the key thing because
he lost that game and then he found an
improvement as a little little lesson
for everyone there that you know we all
we all lose but we've got to find a way
to improve if we get the same thing
again so uh and it and it worked very
well so yeah perfect got him in the
opening perfectly about three zaga he
lost the first
Jordan run for us and then one here's a
second game and then finally taking it
in the Armageddon and we are being
joined by the man himself Eduardo
welcome and congratulations
thanks hi guys how are you we're doing
good how are you doing after this crazy
match that you just played
yesterday was a very tough match against
Favi but then I I try to to forget
everything about yesterday
about the the auto Queen and
some
mistake in the preparation in the second
game with white and then I have to play
and I start today with a with losing
this game with white I don't know but I
think I was playing better with black
than with white
was a very good game I think he missed
Knight B5 and and then everything comes
not easy but they have to calculate some
light but it was comfortable I think
watch Eduardo and we were talking about
that
Improvement is that something that you
prepared between the rounds
yeah yeah I have just five minutes I
checked this H3 uh yes just to after
default have the E3 Square for the
bishop
because if not that he has an id4 but
yeah I look just one two minutes then my
daughter come the puppy puppy Daddy
Daddy and I have to
to hit him yeah and then I come back to
the game
that's awesome
come back in the match as well Edwards
how are you enjoying your debut your
first time in division one of the aim
chess rapid
it's an amazing
I was so really nervous now but uh about
the game but it was an amazing
experience for me I
in I played three play-ins and then in
the first two I have some chances to get
at least a match to
to play for the division one but then I
lost always the last round and then I
have to play for the division two and I
always lost this match and I played the
division three but in the last one I
have this match again in parkhan was
amazing
for me and and then I I'm here and I
wanna do well here and I think with this
match uh at least I'm
trying to to do some some things in
division one
uh match against Barham that went down
to the wire and your emotions were out
and it was just such a cool moment to
watch as well and you were waiting for
the fist bump today as well as you made
this big comeback
yeah but the I think the the celebration
against Farhan was very special and of
course because naturally but because I
went with
0.009 seconds it was
uh but it tense game which sacrifice the
rook and I don't know
I don't I I was thinking in the game I
after move 60 I will have some increment
I don't know why I think this because
these are my head on and then
and there is no rule for for this but I
was thinking because I was playing
another tournament with this Rule and I
was playing slowly in the last uh 20
moves and then I realized I have no
increment and I have to play fast fast
the last five seconds and I think I I
won this game because I I give him two
checks and the checks in with premovies
the the trick I think to to have more
seconds than than it's very was a very
special for me
this tournaments and I wanna thanks of
course all of you for this opportunity
for all of us to have the chance to play
against the super elite players and it
was amazing not only for me I think for
every people in in the tournament
that's really nice to hear and Eduardo
you're putting up such a great fight in
the show here and before we let you go
my final question I think everyone in
chat wants to know have you changed your
auto promotion on chess.com today
yes because yesterday with eight seconds
left in the clock I try to change but I
don't find and and then I look in
Twitter Danny put it with Alt with Alta
and then promo I can get the the Knight
but okay this is a
learning for me yesterday
uh congratulations for your weekly today
Eduardo and we look forward to having
you back with us tomorrow
thanks thanks guys
Eduardo Teresa with a convincing win in
the Armageddon continues his run at the
am chest rapid it is elimination for
fedociev and Jordan man Forest we've
still got big action coming up as we
will be starting the winner semi-final
with some big big matchups don't go
anywhere we'll be back in just a few
[Music]
the most elite bullet tournament returns
you don't want to miss the fourth ever
bullet Chess Championship featuring
Magnus Carlson for the first time he'll
join reigning champ Hikaru Nakamura 2021
champion alireza ferrugia and more to
fight for their share of the 100 000
prize fund it all kicks off on July 17th
at 9am Pacific
use exclamation point BCC in chat for
all the details
don't miss your chance to win Diamond
membership this Friday
the chess.com Discord server is hosting
an arena with four Diamond memberships
up for grabs
to stake your claim join the Discord at
go.chess.com forward slash Discord and
connect your Discord to your chess.com
account
use exclamation point Discord in chat
now for more
and it's time for the winner semi-finals
two epic matchups a clash of generations
between not the backup dosage of and
live on our onion and the big one that
we've all been waiting to see Fabiano
caruana taking on Magnus Carlson this is
their head-to-head score in Rapid with
10 wins to Fabi 18 wins to Magnus he
leads there but the last time that they
played David it was Fabi who won against
Magnus yeah and those types of things
are important these Trends in
head-to-heads Magnus of course overall
he's got the best head-to-head against
most players in the world but Fabi he's
been upping his game into like we've
been saying consistently now on the tour
he's been mightily impressive
it's always hard to bet against Magnus
whenever he's playing can Fabi do it
today Head to Head between not the back
of the satrobe and Levon aronian they
haven't played each other as many times
but we see it is Levon experience here
right now leading against the youth is
this one equally close to call
yeah I think so definitely I mean uh
naughty Beck is just getting better
every single time he plays I mean he won
the last last one of these events so uh
uh he's he's the youth against the
experienced player so uh yeah too close
to call for me yeah I think Lavon though
if he plays like he did yesterday uh he
he'll he'll be okay although sometimes
you know when you get yourself in
trouble and then it takes Armory getting
to win you end up really carrying that
momentum so we'll see how neuterbeck is
ultimately we'll get to that in a minute
because the first of our uh of our
winners bracket battles look at this
playing fast playing on prep no more A6
for Magnus Carlson yeah we didn't he
couldn't get away with it against this
guy but we get such a cool opening
more importantly none of the rosly more
that we saw in the world
show and there I thought Fabi was
extremely still on the camera but good
to know that everything's fine the
camera is working and uh G4 on the board
David yeah G4 for the score as they say
uh very aggressive play from Fabiano
throwing all pawns forward now on the
king side just preempting a decision by
the black king now Black's King should
not ever get attempted to Castle
kingside because it's going to be
walking straight into an attack and uh
Magnus still as black has to decide how
to develop his pieces this is super
exciting speaking of developments Magnus
Carlson has added the Sicilian as a
regular part of his repertoire really
since the 2018 World Championship that
he had against against Fabiano caruana
but we didn't necessarily see this time
on off Paulson system we saw a lot of
svechnikov for those who don't haven't
gotten this memo Fabiano caruana is
probably the world's most feared player
on the white side of these English
attacking type of systems he's so well
prepared he he you know mvl avoids the
night or against Fabiano that should
tell you right and MBL doesn't avoid the
night off against anybody so this is
gonna be awesome to see Magnus played H6
which was the first move to kind of
threw Fabi off before he remembered his
prep and uh if this ends up being a
battle that we also see in game three I
just can't wait to see the preparation
and the things we're going to learn I'm
like a kid in a candy store here because
I played this position as white so I
can't wait to see what happens so many
opening Dynamics here it was it Garo who
said that Fabiano is one of the best if
not the best prepared player in the
world now apparently that Crown belongs
to Anish Guri according to Hikaru but
the opening battle continues in this one
we are also going to have opening moves
in our other matchup not a backup to
satrobe taking on Lavon aronia and the
players are ready to start live in San
Sebastian in the room with all the chess
books and the chessboards behind it
moves on the board it's the king spawn
opening see sport opening and wow we'll
see what we call the Four Knights here
no Spanish no Italian game yet uh we
might see a big decision now from Abdul
sator of what's he going to go for
levon's of course known as one of the
world's leading experts on the black
side of these E5 positions Rock Solid
and okay crazy stuff already Knight
takes E4 this is a temporary peace
sacrifice based on the fact that if the
white knight had captured this Black
Knight black would have played D5 four
king two minor pieces regaining the
material and after just castles love it
love it
you know I I love a sacrifice and um you
it's so rare to see see this kind of
Chess at this level because most things
have been worked out I mean at lower
level you can sacrifice a lot more in
the opening uh because uh your opponent
is less likely to know what to do
um so it's quite rare and of course
white gets great compensation here
because of the development he's castled
black hasn't castled White's got more
pieces out so this is also going to be
uh I mean I I'm assuming I don't know
his position but Theory would obviously
say that black is okay here so I'm also
very interested to see what uh White's
got up his sleeve here this is the
classic center fork truck I mean Knight
takes E4 followed by D5 for black this
is something you teach kids when you're
first you're first trying to show them
tactics that can happen in double King
pong games so um obviously you know the
theory for these guys goes deeper than
uh than following for basic Center trick
says David is showing on the board but I
like black as well Simon I agree and I I
wonder it's funny because notary pausing
before Bishop C4 makes me wonder if he's
double checked double checking double
guessing himself we know that he used to
play the scotch before switching to the
Italian so
um maybe getting his lines mixed up a
little bit again this is a fine white
can play this way it's more of a long
form compensation now you're
highlighting one of the potential tricks
on the board check made on F7 but it's
also a good opening for black yeah and
actually uh I think Eric Rosen will be
happy here because it's basically the
Stafford Gambit but what has an extra
Tempo white has uh castled King side
which is playable maybe is playable
actually often the idea there is to push
your H4 forward and attack on the wings
but uh it's interesting white has
gambited the pawn but has great Central
play uh along the e-file along this
diagonal and if we look at nordebec's
time this is the first real time he's
thinking after the move H6 just been
played uh so it does feel like
preparation it feels like he's just uh
wow going for checkmate mate in one
threaten now on F7 yeah he's gambiting
he's Safford Gambit lives okay I'm
sitting here thinking like what's going
on here but now I'm like okay obviously
the kid came prepared for this and I
think from a practical perspective if
you're getting a sharp well-prepared
Gambit that's how you rack up W's right
especially in Rapid shots yeah maybe
against weaker opposition than level
neuronian though who looks like he's
defending three
confidently right now I'm expecting him
to play the move D6 and protect his
extra Pawn on E5 this one uh really
tense already and I just want to mention
a bit of symmetry because we've seen a
sacrifice of the E4 Pawn in this game
and in the carowana against Carlson game
both sides white has sacrificed upon and
going on the attack early doors such
exciting game so far really exciting
100 and we do have material deficit
already out of the opening David you
mentioned it there has been a pawn
sacrifice in the Fabi Magnus game as
well let's head over to that one and see
as the opening develops Fabiano caruana
against Magnus Carlsen a wild position
out of the opening why it's going on the
king side Black's King is in the center
what on Earth is going on here yeah
white has gampty the pawn just like the
other game in return for Tempe that
means you gain one or two sometimes
three moves even for the sacrifice
material and here white as we see nice
safe King on C1 and uh White's piece is
looking very active it looks like you've
got some Pawn breaks as well if I recall
correctly though Magnus had this
position just last uh just a few days
ago in Zagreb which makes me wonder what
is Fabiano I was going to say it's funny
because Fabiano is the one who's super
well prepared in these systems is white
but Magnus is the one up two minutes on
the clock and as you put it out yeah he
had this position in Zagreb just a few
days ago so uh Bobby's fobby is sort of
balls in your court right to show what
you prepared you have to know that
Magnus is going for these lines these
days
it's a very interesting option here as
well I mean uh I I love these positions
because they're so rich full of
possibilities and you know um you know
just reminds me of the games are my
favorite player Michael Tau and uh you
know white might be thinking here I can
attack that Knight but maybe the Knight
can jump all the way into C3 if that
happens you know does this just just
these uh possibilities that are just so
uh so crazy and so in depth here that we
could see
um I mean uh it's it's could well just
really come to life it's already a life
and the other thing is like you know
Magnus historically didn't really play
like this right he's only started to
play like this when he's
maybe not you know holding on to that
world championship title as much he's
playing a lot Freer he always used to
play quite safe not taking too many
risks but this is a incredibly risky way
to play right this this kind of setup
first thing would you say because do you
think that's also
all she wear to really fight against
something you want to get him into that
Mikhail tall Deep Dark Forest of
complications early on where the part is
narrow enough for just one player to get
out is that the kind of position that
you should be aiming for against Magnus
I would have definitely said yes but
then when I've seen Magnus get into
those positions he just crushes his
opponents as well so I'm not really sure
how you beat Magnus but I think if uh
you know I think it is one of the better
ways to try especially your Fabiano
you've got to complicate it you've got
to go there on the attack you've got to
try to make things messy because he's
just so hard to beat in solid structures
it's nearly impossible and I would argue
that I don't know that Magnus has
switched to some of the sharpest some of
the sharpest lines known to theory in
these Sicilians really has anything to
do with him giving up the world
championship title at all I think he
should be applauded for almost kind of
Reinventing his approach to the opening
and I remember talking to Fabi about
this in 2021 and the comments we made
similar comments about how Magnus plays
openings that aren't that well prepared
or is kind of safe and he's like you
know I think people underestimate just
how well prepared you have to be to
avoid everyone's preparation and Magnus
not necessarily being known as a deep
opening theoretician amongst the top
players they all kind of call BS to that
they're like Magnus is actually the
hardest worker most ruthless opening
preparer and it's because he believes in
his skills that he tends to avoid some
of the sharpest prep but I really as I
looked at what Magnus has done with the
black pieces over the last few years I'm
just super impressed David because he
started to embrace some of the sharpest
lines known to man and know them really
well and get points with black as he did
against Fabi where Fabi didn't see the
special cough coming in 2018 so I don't
know that I'm not trying to say I
disagree but I disagree with you I don't
think there's anything to do with the
world championship I think Magnus just
has really reinvented his approach in
the first stage of things in the last
few years of his career yeah yeah I mean
it feels like he knows everything that
everyone else knows and he knows how to
avoid that and uh some fresh ideas uh to
boot and Tanya you mentioned taking him
into a deep dark Forest I mean Jordan
tried that yesterday he took him into a
deep dark van for us but it didn't work
so LOL yeah right now this one is a
complicated position and Danny you're
right these days he kind of relies on
opening preparation more computers more
and he has a great team around him of
course Magnus he said recently in a
training camp that uh now more than ever
has he relied on these sharp variations
because that's the only way to do it at
the top level and uh meanwhile he's
still pulling up he hasn't been
checkmated yet Black's King is still in
the center but it's up to Fabi to prove
the compensation yeah I mean I I think
it's a great thing that he's done in
general I mean if you look at a lot of
players I mean I've just taken players
who play a lot of Chess on the British
circuit who may be getting a bit older
and they just play the same chess all
the time and they're never trying to
take any risks and they're never getting
better and I think the first thing you
can do if you're stuck in a rut is to
change the style try something different
so if you're a very aggressive player
play some endings if you're playing the
same openings for years on end just try
something else and uh this is this is
great to see Magnus always trying to
improve himself actually you know he's
trying to get better he's trying to try
different things out and uh he he's
obviously very good at all all positions
that's that's wise the best player ever
can we say that anyone agree with that
I'm gonna say it best player ever you'll
get a lot of disagreements I mean yeah
the goat debate across all genres you
know is there for a reason but uh yeah
anyway Magnus is up on a clock for up on
the clock for a reason he's prepared
where's he gonna put the Knight is uh
is the question yeah and big question uh
you don't have too much choice if you
jump to the center uh on D5 you'll
simply get captured and I think white
will regain the pawn with interest white
will be very happy there and so that
rules out the central jump which is
maybe the ideal one uh jumping to the
edge of the board feels like you'll get
pinned maybe it's not the end of the
world you can defend your knight here
quite stable for now but knowing Magnus
I've seen him in similar positions drop
his Knight back and try to bring it
round to a nice outpost on F5 a bit
later on it looks like you're taking
Liberties you're undeveloping your
pieces but actually this Black Brook is
pretty much developed anyway on an open
file this bishop can come out later and
if white doesn't strike now then you
will bring your knight to a better
Outpost later he just makes just look
easy like this oh it's not that hard if
you didn't know Magnus was playing this
and you just saw this random position
what would we guess the ELO here guess
the ELO let's play guess the ELO with
Levy Rosman I have no idea I have no
idea but not not 28
50 bleep whatever he is not one number
one and one number three right blacks
Auto setting up for the next game all
the pieces retreating but you Retreat to
move forward this one's fire on the
board but the other one is also heating
up let's get a quick look into not a
back up the satro taking on love on our
onion David take it away I can't make
the head or tails of this position wow
just uh wow is my only reaction here I'm
trying to do a quick count white has
sacrificed a bishop a whole piece here
and it's going on the attack Black's
King's still stranded in the center
Abdus look at the clock times he's only
used just over a minute here still deep
in preparation almost double levon's
time on the clock and I think we need to
do an action replay to show how this
piece was sacrificed and wow maybe it
plundered from left on the Rune we see
the evaluation bar shoot up after this
last move I'm not sure what level's got
in mind because it looks like white has
a very strong and simple reply uh so
let's jump in I expect him to tutorial
to pause because it feels like he might
be finally out of his preparation after
this last move but that also means Levon
hasn't played the top computer choice
and uh let's do a rewind we left it here
in this position it looks like black is
just about to Castle to safety but I'm
just a tour of through a spanner in the
works by playing Knight to D4 this
Knight cannot be captured by a pawn due
to a pin on the e-file the Black Knight
retreated but now bang F4 blowing open
the center allowing a fork a double
attack looks again like a guess the ELO
beginner blunder but uh this was all a
calculated risk Pawn takes pawn and
after the queen retreats E6 move of the
day so far giving up the White Queen wow
Pawn takes Queen oh it might hurt that
in your pipe and smoke it is a
disposition what is this position this
is the Irish pawns on Whiskey this is
the really drunk version
but they're not all the same color over
there you've got a white Pawn on D7
where it doesn't belong checkmating the
black king absolutely amazing and the
other thing is we took the other way you
checked me the other way David right so
it's incredible he takes the other way
uh I'm not sure about the channel
you win the black queen uh so we let's
just catch up with the game we saw
Knight takes porn but this was all part
of the plan sacrificing a bishop now on
C6 spectacular stuff and uh after a few
more moves we saw the black queen was
out to attack this Rook on H1 a nasty
counter threat but this was dealt with
rookie four and Levon he blundered with
Bishop E7 and he's about to get punished
after The Rook slides across to F1 now
attacking this black queen we see a few
more moves Knight takes Bishop the black
king is still stuck in the center piece
down but you're about to crash through
on D6 amazing preparation this is I was
just going to say all according to
playing as the comment David made a few
moves ago and amazing preparation this
is this is so impressive this is showing
up with a Gambit walking right into the
the Stafford Gambit on drugs shout out
to Eric Rosen there
um but the good kind of of whatever
whatever helpful pill you're taking and
uh just like that Notre back is uh
on a roll
yeah beautiful stuff yeah and incredible
I mean like uh this is this is the way
to do things nowadays you know I mean
I totally agree it's we might just have
resignation right now I've never seen
this you just brushed like that oh my
God we have a result Levon Blanca Rook
resigns on the spot but the position was
already busted not in fact taking a lead
in just 21 moves in his game
Masterpiece uh demolition job
I just want to let I'm sitting here
Frozen I want to let you finish your
thoughts Simon because we've been
cutting you off and the game ended so
abruptly but yeah this is insane no I
mean I I just uh brilliant preparation I
mean I I was about to say I think this
is the way that you should do things
nowadays I mean don't play main lines
try to find some Sidelines that people
forget you know this is I mean I don't
know when the last time this Gambit was
played run them on your computer do your
own research okay if your opponent plays
perfectly maybe it's a draw okay but
that's fine you know you can trick them
out if they don't play perfectly you can
have these brilliances and uh when was
the last time aronian got I I never say
this aronian absolutely destroyed he got
completely smashed in that game and
never seen it before yeah so I don't
remember it and Lavon feeling it he
hasn't moved he's checking what went
wrong there he hasn't left his computer
screen I think he's in as much disbelief
as all of us in the studio right now 21
moves that's a miniature the last time I
checked under 25 moves I think was the
official whatever
Guinness I'm getting called out by my
world record attempts these days so
we'll get it we'll get someone to check
on that whether 25 moves is still a
miniature but uh that was awesome Notre
back abducator off for the win he is the
world rapid Champion we need to stop
talking about this kid like he's a
rising star he's he's currently the last
person to win a Champions chess Tour
event he might be on the way to uh to
doing the same thing here
now it's reminiscent of Magnus
calculated risks this opening for sure
is not sound objectively black has
probably multiple ways to get to a
playable position but you're testing
your opponent and it's rapid chests and
that's the way to rack up those wins
just uh push your opponent to the brink
give them problems that they don't
normally have to face and uh yeah wow
more action ahead
what a great start to the to this this
was going to be the matchup of the day
sorry Simon go ahead no no I mean
they're brilliant both games are so so
fascinating I mean uh well you know that
last one but look at this what's
happening here this is this is
completely Bonkers as well right
completely mad just a weird position
white is down a whole pawn and still has
the luxury to slow play it fabiana's
last move he did Grimace slightly there
but uh just pushing his Pawn to B3 maybe
creating an Escape Route for the white
Bishop to retreat from the center of the
board and yeah black needs to catch up
on development we should probably show
why Rook takes F4 maybe isn't as good as
it first looks um just because
there is a battery on the C file and C2
is hanging with checks so when you kind
of laugh in the face of danger we should
show what's going on with Rook takes F4
deflecting the queen queen takes C2
check but it's one of those funny
Sicilian positions where you gotta
calculate to the end because just
because you get a scary check may not
actually mean you have anything left in
the tank and this is reminiscent of a
lot of night or type positions white is
actually happen here of the exchange so
anyway so that's why Magnus didn't go
for that
um he just played 97 yeah uh nice to
take that Danny and that's going to be
on the radar for the next few moves
right uh that type of tactic might not
work now but it might work a bit later
on you've got to watch out and I think
that's why Fabi as well pushed his Pawn
forward because there might be some
background checkmates against the white
king
uh if you're not too careful so now
first of all you have to deal with this
Black Knight coming out you see the
evaluation bus slightly on black side
means there's nothing immediate for
white and if you don't have a
breakthrough you might just find
yourself a pawn down later on just like
a very successful opening for black I've
got to say at least at this early stage
on a superficial level looks like a
clear point to the good yeah
it it does now yeah I mean I I don't
think white has managed to generate
enough threats in the position I mean
how does white even generate a fret in
this position and if black can get his
Knight and Bishop into the game okay his
King's always going to be in the middle
but it doesn't seem to be in too much
trouble there Black's got enough counter
play against White's King as well so
this is uh this is starting a field to
go in magnus's favor how many cheers
does it take for a former world champion
to win as Black versus Fabiano caruana
that was a mouthful but he's got a lot
of you added another chair since
yesterday
[Laughter]
he's got three four if you include the
one he's sitting on it's just dominating
with those chairs I mean someone buy
Fabby some chairs just put them in the
background you know stack them up I mean
his chair game is very strong and his
leg game was strong yesterday as well so
he's uh he's got the game and David
we've seen you on one of those chairs
and Magnus is streaming
nothing
in that group The Stream with Magnus
yeah they call me the patter in the
background and uh yeah it's fun often
I'm just observing admiring the play but
uh yeah magnusi likes the support
whether the chairs are empty whether
they're full I think it really motivates
him and uh these days he's obsessed with
playing online plays nearly every title
Tuesday event plays all these Champions
chess tour events uh that's kind of his
happy place right now where we see him
and it's really showing on the board it
must be fun to be in a room where you're
a weaker chess player okay
I'm in those rooms a lot so how does
that feel I think that's why I moved to
Norway I was getting too big for my
boots in the UK keeps me grounded here
surrounded by genius like uh like Magnus
yeah
five he's just put his pieces on good
squares that black knight is immovable
almost that black Rook on H4 gives
really annoying pressure and Black's
other pieces look like they're covering
some key squares Fabi needs another
Knight he needs a light squared Bishop
but he lacks those pieces to create an
attack with does one of those chairs
actually have your name on David is it
the howl chair oh you know right it
should tell when I get a close-up of
those chairs maybe I'll add another
chair I'll add in a fifth or sixth chair
yeah
I wanted to analyze a little bit of
Chess here if that's okay I wanted I
wanted to look at whether
whether Favi what is the plan here for
white right it's it's not black is
better and Magnus has certainly won the
battle to this point but I wonder if
there's a way to go for Knight E5 if you
could land the Knight on E5 right now
obviously that would be a good thing
forking the queen in the D7 Pawn so how
is Knight D3 met is what I was wondering
and if you if you play D6
yeah this is this is kind of what I was
hoping for the B4 Pawn would fall so you
can't meet E5 with that
sorry you can't defendify with that so I
was sitting here like what exactly is
magnus's move here I don't think he's
taking F3 with the queen because again I
think 95 would be two would be too much
although it's funny the computer says
maybe that so I was analyzing this in my
head and couldn't figure out maybe it is
Queen takes F3 and black maintains The
Edge laughing in the face of danger what
a weird move but anyway I expect Bobby
to play Knight D3 and if you if you
can't play Queen takes F3
maybe this isn't so easy so but as we
just saw maybe maybe Magnus can take on
F3 taking on F3 looks so scary I mean
only Mad Men or Geniuses take on F3 here
but uh yeah if you survive unfortunately
white just can't get the Knight out of
the way quickly enough yeah Magnus might
be both
that's true and your call on the board
Danny Knight to D3 I think the only safe
way to uh kind of uh stop 95 might be to
play Bishop to D6
to kind of trade off at night if it ever
lands on the Square and this was going
to be my last idea was to say If you
defend this way now is Rook H1 possible
because even though F3 is hanging with
the bishop developed I'm threatening
things like Rook h8 at the end of these
lines so
I know I'm the international master in
the room my job here isn't to analyze
chess but my brain feels so free with
you controlling the mouse that I think
that this is maybe what we're gonna see
I think Knight D3 is the strongest move
it was played by Fabi and now Magnus is
gonna is gonna use his time to make sure
he takes the right approach because
this this is the the big moment to keep
his advantage or not
it's true it feels like a key moment if
Magnus plays the right way we think
maybe take you on F3 then he keeps the
advantage but it will take notes of
steal and okay he Dodges any
complications he plays Bishop to D6 and
I think Danny your move might well just
appear on the board you need to get rid
of this active Rook if you want to break
through
um black stuff I want to show the full
line we got the analysis I was looking
at Rook H1 takes takes Queen takes F3
shake and bake on h8 and after Bishop f8
I have Queen takes B4 this was my uh
utilizer it doesn't work thank you oh
Queen D1 I forgot C2 is hanging at the
end yeah counter attack Okay so
so maybe in this position at least
you've created this pin maybe you can uh
go for the Slow Burn attack I don't
quite see it yet
how to break through what a weird
position weird weird stuff evaluation
Bar says it's roughly level here that's
frustrating AF as foggy as the kids say
that's frustrating AF
I'm pretty sure that's what AF stands
for I've been using it a lot around the
house these days I hope that's okay yeah
that's definitely what it stands for
sounds good to me five more
yeah Hobbies maybe you just jump into
the center attack the queen again I'm
gonna go back to B7 complicated stuff
and here at least you haven't
maybe tricks Danny uh with projects yes
yes I only saw it when the evaluation
button came up okay and again it's so
easy looking at these positions with the
evaluation bar but it's not easy but it
it makes it you get an indication when a
move goes wrong but imagine you're
sitting there trying to calculate these
out you don't know if the moves good or
bad are set by calculator it brings in a
whole different dimension and uh you
know this is it's an incredible position
I think we're seeing the five maybe
should have gone for that whole line we
were just showing and I know that we
don't dive into that deep or complicated
of analysis that often but I think in
this case it's appropriate because we're
sort of setting the table here for just
how important that position was and how
deep maybe kifabi needed to calculate in
order to keep the pressure he doesn't go
for Rook H1 he settles on 95 and now
this position looks easy for black
because where's the threat I'm up a pawn
I've got a dominant Knight on F5 you've
got a dark squared Bishop that can't
touch it so I think that that position
was the critical one and I think Magnus
is going to get the first game yeah he
can grab a second Pawn if he wants to be
greedy here we talked about Queen takes
F3 earlier it looks like a decent moment
to do that and uh yeah we often see
these top games these top players
they're all so good they're often games
like this are decided on just a just one
or two moves critical moments here and
then I think you're right Danny that
might have been the one
where it slipped away from Fabiana and
One That Got Away you know
yeah the knight's just too strong here
right and uh Black's already material up
and I think black's threats are probably
as strong as white threats as well so uh
I I I think Fabi has missed this chance
doesn't need to complicate uh the
position just shows you how good Magnus
is though right as well because uh you
know he's playing this fearsome attacker
in these positions and he just
calculates all his way through playing
the perfect moves you know he's he's
good I knew that guy not bad not many
people go on that Sicilian he's under
four minutes right now though and it
feels like he's been making one accurate
move after another but it's still
complicated magnus's King is still in
the center the players have no idea
about the eval bar they don't know who's
winning who's better who's not and yes
Sabi in the back seat right now but it's
far from over and given the clock
situation we can expect turn around here
yeah I totally I think that time
scrambles happen to uh to the best of
them even the world's best but uh
I guess I'm I'm having a hard time
seeing threats for white that's my
problem you know what really kills me is
that night on F5 that 995 is guarding
and controlling everything it is a pain
and you know what
um so what what would you call the night
though is it a it's not quite a unicorn
I don't know because they don't exist
they don't exist although you just
quoted a dragon so now you're the pot
calling the kettle black here
um with uh that could be a dragon knight
okay but our Dragon Bishop but let's get
a vote and chat which is more real a
dragon or a unicorn I mean let's chat
this one I think the best I've seen both
of my student days
haven't you ever haven't you seen that
there's an antelope there's like an
antelope that has a horn on it like in
that there's like a daddy I'm sure I've
seen that before yeah there's like a
real animal with that looks like a
unicorn I think that's David says it
this is Misty this is a stallion on the
board right now that night on F5 not
only a great defensive piece but also an
attacking piece controlling so many
squares and Sonic trying to create
threats here it's exactly what he's
doing touching the one minute Mark any
chances so far be here
it's tough to say uh there's going to be
chances for Fabi look at what Magnus has
done so cool Karma collected here just
putting his King on D7 we saw him do it
actually against Jordan yesterday and uh
here it looks like the king is just well
guarded by this wall of Pawns in front
of it and those pawns supported by that
black knight yeah we have this Ryan
Knights on F5 with right this Black
Knight is uh just controlling everything
and I think Tony was right to call out
that okay both sides are getting under
time pressure it's not over like
magnus's team in the center but I agree
the reason why it's hard is because it's
one of those positions that's even worse
than the math says it is because white
has no threats here The Rook on bh4
guards B4 the queen is guarding
everything I'm like what is Fabi gonna
do now he's under I guess he's he's
under a minute
so uh
hmm I'm having a hard time seeing it I'm
just I'm just so impressed with Magnus
diving into Where Angels Fear To Tread
right the white side of the Sicilian is
where Fabiano caruana usually gets a lot
of wins Magnus is like I got you here we
go into the prep he hasn't got any
squares to move his pieces I mean like
try to find a square where white can
move a piece to without exchanging
something off uh there's not really any
squares you know I mean his pieces are
huddling in Middle uh you don't want to
exchange pieces off with your white hair
because any ending is just even easier
for Magnus to win and your Bishop is
useless it's just uh fighting against a
brick wall and that diagonal
um so it just seems like there's there's
not really anything white can do I mean
that that is a a major problem here I
mean he can't create Frets I mean the
only thing he might try you know is move
his Rook one square to the right but
that's just a mini mini idea that's not
going to work back can get the Queens
off at some point it looks pretty
hopeless to me yeah you know I'm I mean
I just can't see anything white can do
the one thing that White House going for
him is that the Queens are still on the
board
yeah the Queens come off you know you
can resign so as long as as long as
there's pressure on the D file and
there's a king in the center there's
chances Magnus could make a blunder
right because he is human
yeah the one thing I would do here I
mean Magnus he'll find us more
sophisticated uh move for sure but the
one thing I would do is just defend
everything just put a rook on C6 and say
you shall not pass and just cover all of
these pawns and uh I don't see anything
ever going wrong there but he finds a uh
maybe even stronger move trying to force
those Rooks off the board Simon you said
any trades help and that seems to be the
case and unfortunately it's hard to keep
this Rook on the board because if you
slide it across attack that black queen
the other move you mentioned now a queen
trade is guaranteed and that will end
the game two extra points for black yeah
are we
okay he plays Rook H2 at least the White
Queen has more squares to flee to if you
try to trade off now that's desperation
his only chance is to keep keep their
pieces on the board and I hope the
Magnus does something wrong uh but it's
it's quite rare and Magnus does
something wrong
um and you know uh there's you know
Magnus can even try exchanging Queens
here I like your move David just moving
The Rook up two squares that's a class
move that's the kind of move I probably
wouldn't play because I just don't have
that class I'm kind of looking at
forcing the issue but just if your
opponent can't do anything as well as
white car white can't really do anything
then just uh improve everything as much
as you can defend things before you
before you go into overdrive and
finishing the game off so uh but yeah
there's many options here time though
yeah okay let's tick in but yeah they're
both about to be under a minute so let's
uh let's hold the phone yeah for a
minute yeah we have seen Magnus over the
last 12 months occasionally
uncharacteristically make one with
blunders and of course the mouth slips
there's other ways that Fabi can get
back into this game and okay D5 looks
fine planting a Pawn on a very safe
Square still lacking ideas here for Fabi
to break through that White Queen it
just needs to land somewhere on the
queen side somewhere Behind Enemy Lines
to give black a check but still how to
break through I think D5 has a concrete
thread he wants to play 93 and Bobby
didn't stop it because the Knight was
guarding D6 and so now you can go to E3
without Queen taking which Forks the D1
rook and the C2 Pawn it's funny he
didn't look strong maybe he'll land it
now you couldn't even take that pawn
with a bishop because Rook D4 was just
game over immediately so uh you know he
he's he's dropping buckets like I drop
ELO points and uh and they're looking
finishing it off in style take C2
beautiful dress here I'm going to take
sport the white King has to move
and you can just go You Can Do Magic
meetings yeah rookie one is coming it's
too many tempting options aren't they I
mean like you can probably resigned what
a finish and with that Fabiano Carolina
goes down in game one Magnus Carlsen
continues his heart feisty Farm what a
week he's had winning the grand Chester
takes his match against Jordan in three
games and today it takes the first game
with the black pieces no idea who can
stop this guy that game was phenomenal
David start to finish too many moments
to pick from but what stood out to you
yeah I just want to show one quick
maneuver an instruction maneuver and
then want to show that checkmate at the
end that Magnus finished off with and it
was here most uh Immortals would be
wanting to put the Knight on an active
square but Magnus realized sometimes you
have to go back in order to go forward
and uh for me 98 was the star move of
the game just reread this Knight to E7
and later to F5 where we saw it was just
an incredibly strong piece and we did
see this Knight do the damage later on
as well it was this position if we fast
forward towards the end where that black
knight did jump into the white uh Camp
here and it just destroyed everything by
sacrificing itself on C2 after Queen
takes Pawn Fabiana resigned after Rook
takes Rook due to the fact that Queen
takes Rook is met by a nasty check the
King has to step forward and this is
Checkmate just from start to finish a
really clean game from Magnus
what a game that was and what a journey
that night had a samurai knows when to
retreat goes back to be the finishing
piece finally with that final move that
David just showed us and with that round
one is in the books Let's Take a look at
our storyline so far in the winners
semi-finals two decisive games two big
wins there and in dominating style not a
back up to such a crushing Levon aronian
out of the opening and the same
narrative in Magnus Carlsen taking the
big win against Fabiano caruana and the
Fight Continues with three more rapid
games remaining we will be back after
this break
foreign
it doesn't look like much but neither
would a Sicilian Defense to the
untrained eye this is a performance
enhancer you don't see it how about now
manage your air quality sharpen your
performance change the game with air
things
it's a big game coming up but right now
it's the big moment that we've all been
waiting for finally we find out what
happened when Magnus Carlsen and David
Howell took the air things challenge
let's go
Magnus and myself are going to be taking
on the air things challenge we're going
to play chess but with a Twist all of
the pieces are air things devices what
air things devices here black Air things
devices and we don't know what the
pieces are so we might be able to rely
on patent recognition in the first few
moves but we will definitely lose our
way somewhere along the lines we also
have a big crowd here so I'm feeling the
pressure
he's too calm I don't like it
did not expect that one it's not a very
good move
that was nice you can see on the other
side that it's upon I thought that was
my queen good to know
yeah that really just looks like you're
moving upon like a night
does this actually work
you tell me I'm guessing I know you're
guessing just sometimes your guesses are
right that's the problem oh I just saw a
nice way to lose the game
I spotted my trap yeah I wish it's day
four you know
he sees everything
yeah I missed that one
I kind of played safe
[Music]
one thing is like they play just this
way but to watch this must be
good
I was hoping for 92 Queen F1 oh my God
that was me yeah okay the game goes on
Queen F4 was over there oh that's true
okay
both missing stuff now 20 seconds
against nine seconds what do you mean
queen of four you mean air things to add
seconds oh
foreign
[Music]
this is a new Queen
if you say so
oh my God
just for the final position
king queen hopefully and the rest are
pawns yeah that's my queen but it's not
doing much the position is very open I
think that helped a lot like if we
played a closer game it would have been
a lot harder
ah there that looks like a lot of fun
but did you get flagged there in the end
dirty flag Magnus dirty player no but it
was a lot of fun actually and we managed
to keep track of the pieces better than
I thought we would I'm just annoyed that
I actually won the second game but they
cut that out what happened there
wow we will get an update on what
happened in that second game between
Magnus and David in the air things
challenge now it might be difficult to
play chess with atings but it's the
easiest to keep a track on your air
quality with earthings and this is your
chance to get 35 off on the air things
weight plus all you got to do is go on
go.chess.com
for that 35 off and we've still got
action on as only one game is done in
division one we saw phenomenal results
attacking chess there and we're getting
an update from catty that that's exactly
the storyline that we had in the other
two divisions aggressive play of
been too much to be honest to see
another night Sacrifice from Martinez at
this time it was really bad but it
turned out that it worked well for him
he won that fourth game so these two
went to the Armageddon game and in the
Armageddon I'm in tabatabai was with
white pieces he had 15 minutes versus
seven and he won the game starting from
the beginning until the end he dominated
Amin Tabata by continues to fight for
the qualification in the first Division
and he's on the way to win 10 000 USA
dollars oh and I saw Dan last there as
well with the 3-0 win so some big wins
coming up there Kathy this kid is
Unstoppable he's just 16 years old and
he's beating everyone on the way today
with 3-0 he beat Grandmaster David para
fian and yesterday he knocked down
Grandmaster Parham we know he's not easy
to knock down with three two one so
Dennis is also Unstoppable I mean with
the chest airplane you can't even call
them kids anymore let
us seeing in division two honest Eduardo
durizaga mentioned this is such a big
opportunity for the players to make it
to division one by winning division two
because it really is a breakout moment
in their career and Ketty also some
breakout performances in division three
that's right in division three Tanya we
have to get ready for this look at this
drama here Christian needed to win this
game with extra two queens but you know
what he flocked himself here he couldn't
win he was trying to remove all the bees
he had extra two quiz two times in this
game but well with one king and more
time on the clock Raul momodov is the
one who will fight to get five thousand
dollars that's the first prize in the
third division oh wow and Alexander
Grisha he's the former World Blitz
Champion he's one who comes under so
much time pressure but we never actually
see him getting flagged that was
shocking we're two queens
yeah that's brutal oh my God the
surprises and the shocks continue and
catty also you Yankee there with a great
result and we see right now the talk is
all about not to back up the satrobe and
Magnus Carlsen winning their first game
and look at those aim chess stats that
we have David opening accuracy 100 and
we saw some impressive prep by him today
yeah impressive stuff opening accuracy
means he never makes a mistake or at
least a mistake that the computer would
judge as a blunder in the opening and
Advantage capitalization I think this is
where is really world class winning 93
of games where he has an advantage of
over plus one and a half which is
incredible you've got to say resourceful
two and in general just a dangerous
player you see the end game stats there
as well
comparable with Magnus Carlson himself
yeah very good and let's just remind
everyone you can all check out your
stats as well just by going to aim chess
and running them on your own games but
uh incredibly impressive there I'd be
afraid to see how my stats compare to
any of those stats yeah um so that but
that was insanely impressive and
exciting to see and yeah awesome to see
the MTS view of how the player profile
breaks down and
you have 90 percent
super consistent and that's the key at
this top level just to never blunders
but wait there is more action coming up
and we have got a head-to-head between
Magnus Carlton and Fabiano caruana
talking about stats decisive games 99
100 there what do you make of these
thoughts Danny wow I'm looking at this
for the first time and I'm I'm excited
it's interesting to see that the uh the
way that it breaks down from an average
centipun loss my my brain jumps to that
just to see in terms of their move
accuracy and the average Centerpoint
loss that they might have there
obviously as far as how many games are
in the end game if I'm reading that
right that means Bobby's playing 68 of
his of his games or reaching the end
game and for for Magnus is 59 it's an
interesting stat I almost would have
thought it would be the opposite Magnus
so well known for taking people into the
end game and then getting the job done
but uh there you go and the clocks are
ticking again Fabiano's strike back
after what happened in game one it's not
just about the score line but the style
in which a Magnus crushed with the black
pieces and of course don't forget to get
your own aim chest stats to get that
targeted training and your analytics in
right now for Magnus Carlton and there's
joy in the studio as we have another
English it's the day of the
I I wasn't prepared to do that you never
put a man on the spot for an accent that
he doesn't voluntarily bring forward
I feel better but all right we've got an
English
um not the same King's Indian
transposition we saw in your urine's
battle versus uh itari Saga this is a
this is an even more obscure line with
this E5 being met by D4 yeah it's
interesting to me it shows that Fabi
wanted to maybe play for a win or at
least get a very complex position uh
from the start just the way black is set
up on his first two moves but this is
throwing a spanner in the works what
Magnus has done very direct he's willing
to bring his Queen up uh even at the
cost of a couple of Tempe in order to
open up the center and white might well
just let be left with extra space Simon
uh you're a resident English opening
expert you've got chessable courses on
this what do you think uh magnus's
Choice yeah I mean it's actually known
as D4 move quite well I mean it was
actually a game where also Kasparov
played this way I think with the black
pieces and destroyed uh maybe Google
um in something like 20 moose but
generally the structure is quite good
for white
um because white can get this hold in
the center but Black's pieces are quite
active at the moment so if white can
stabilize this position get his King
side developed then I feel he should
have a small advantage
um because yeah Black's just a bit
cramped
and you know who else destroyed the
player in 20 moves it was Magnus Carlson
in this last game that we saw
psychologically how difficult is that
for Fabi
well the the uh the game where Magnus
one is black yeah I mean this is hard to
overcome and and uh now Fabi has black
and by the way look look at the first
game we had Magnus winning in the
theoretical Sicilian now Magnus is
avoiding Theory with this sort of
obscure game is white but once again up
on the clock so Magnus bringing out the
Full Slate of preparation and uh and
tricks here to throw fobby off his game
and another player who in round one
bought out all the prep and a great
gameplay was not about
aronian is getting ready to fight it out
in round two we did see Levon not move
from his screen after what happened in
game one checking what went wrong so it
doesn't happen again but once again
similar psychological battles the
players are fighting a king spawn
opening we've got moves on the board we
have moves on the board and wow Petrov
defensive tour of seems to have so many
bows to his string these days choosing
one of the most solid openings in chess
as black but no surprise to level of
ronin we see a trade of Pawns in the
center
total symmetry right now both sides will
Castle over the next couple of moves and
can live on a roni and create something
from this position tends to end up quite
sterile unless you can find uh find
something some fireworks yeah I don't
think norabeck is winning this one in 20
moves but now that he's on the black
side of a Petrov where uh Lavon will
know his stuff here so this might be a
dub that goes the other way and this
match stays close even if it's in an
opposite fashion where where Lavon takes
it into a long symmetrical battle but
we'll see now it's going to be one of
those open sharp pet drops these aren't
the uh the tamus positions looks like
he's playing copycat chess sir here
Danny just copying every move that Levon
aronian makes uh when in doubt just copy
the opponent copy your opponent that is
actually not advice I'm not trying that
at home or maybe only try that at home a
lot of tension there in the center
perhaps for not a bag it's just about
keeping it solid with the black pieces
he doesn't want the game to get too
chaotic and I want to get the body
language expert in on this because I
like how Danny's pointing to side
not a back right is a beast on the board
but on camera often looks
fidgety and a little nervous going on
there Psy am I actually the expert to
you that means it's you when did that
happen right now
um yeah I mean I I think naughty bakes
just very confident you've got to be
confident uh to get to this level you
know you can't have too many doubts and
uh he normally has this pose the same
thing I don't think he gives too much
away
um on the other hand aronian stretch
that's what it is it's the Iranian
stretch when he stretches ah he's like a
gorilla isn't he not calling him he
actually looks like a gorilla but you
know he's like ah
this is going the wrong way why did you
ask me to be the body
I love it I will point out that Levon is
uh is kind of relaxed here lean back a
little bit
um and uh he's he's an experienced Pro
so I don't think he carries over any
feelings of the previous loss here I
know that you know everyone's human and
they do a little bit but I don't know
that he lets it bother him too much so
uh probably probably off to a good start
here and I will mention that a little
bit of nuts not too much can be useful
it helps you stay in the moment it helps
you stay alert to yeah tactics tricks
and the kind of ever-changing nature of
the game uh so I think I'm too sort of
he's just clearly got a good balance
here and nothing seems to fluster him
too much but meanwhile we do see almost
a symmetrical position but now slightly
different white tonight
still in the center of the board black
snake has been forced to retreat and I'm
loving the position of White's Bishops
white start Square Bishop pins one of
the Black Knights whites light squared
Bishop points towards the black king
side so it feels like F2 satorov is
facing some pressure it also almost uh
looks like the central pawns the white
porn 25 the black Pawn on D4 it's like
they're the wrong way round which is a
bit of a uh kind of optical illusion
here but uh we're intense position Danny
I'm looking at him wondering who will
blink first right a bit of a staring
contest there on the D file I mean
G5 is possible to take D5 that's not a
move I would recommend because I would
anticipate the position to open up and
ultimately favor white
um but uh yeah and the computer says
yeah that's not a pawn you want to take
there we go concrete concrete problems
are happening here very quickly even on
King G7 I'm sure there's more wow look
at that
I had calculated zero of this just
instinctively thought G5 would probably
not be not be the safest decision
um but your instincts are right there
instincts are right so this wouldn't
work so then if we go back to the live
position all right Bishop B7 there's a
safe way to unpin the Knight create the
threat of Knight takes D5 you say safe
but the evolvar just creeped up what
happened there is this an inaccuracy by
notabeck at least according to the uh
evaluation bar I couldn't the computer
here Bishop E7 it looks natural to a
human to break this pin and you looks
like you're going after this Pawn as
well but wow irony reacts instantly it's
this opening preparation he's only spent
just over a minute he's hoping to line
up on this diagonal and creep in later
with a Checkmate I think he's trying to
get his revenge you know like after the
last game it's like naughty Beck you
crush me now let me have a go a little
boy and uh he's like and he could well
just be crushing him he just look at
WISE pieces wise pieces are fantastic
and that that idea you're showing on the
board there David the queen coming in
it's one of the first ideas in chess
that I ever learned well well worth
remembering at home get the novel power
going and just trying to fire it in
towards your opponent's king but White's
pieces are just so good here yeah
they're they're just flooding the board
in on great positions and maybe naughty
Beckett maybe he's just losing it's
possible whenever I play Bishop C2 to
make an obvious threat of Checkmate it's
not as good as it is right here when
when Levon aronian does it because this
actually is a very simple move and
you're threatening the most obvious
threat on the board Queen D3 in a
battery for checkmate but there actually
doesn't seem to be an easy solution to
this especially because in so many of
those lines the Knight on E5 will
sacrifice on G6 and blow things open so
it's horrible I mean you can try Knight
A6 I'm thinking but I mean it it's it it
looks really scary if I was black here
I'd be uh doing something in my pants
yeah and thanks for that mental image
Simon leave that to the imagination kids
that's oh don't think about it anyway
just leave it there I think we need to
uh utilize a tool that Danny mentioned
earlier I think we need to check with
the computer how fine is the margin for
error here for Abdul sotorov to me it
Feels Like Only move territory already
otherwise you might well just get
checkmated on that diagonal so maybe we
can see what the engine suggests wow it
says only one move to minimize the
damage anything else gives white an
advantage of over plus two which is
significant at this level and we see the
most logical move or the best move for
black here is to capture whites Pawn on
D5 with the knight in the center there
anything else I'm going to say the
second move there unnatural playing the
pawn to D3 it looks like you're just
asking what to take a pawn for free and
land on a very nice Square the third
move also maybe one of the most natural
in the position but
dangerous and objectively already
powerful for aronian we could see
Revenge immediately here Tanya
big trouble right out of the opening
he's taking this moment to think he of
course realizes just how big a moment he
is this is for him one bad move and it
could be all over we've been talking
about different options apart from that
night jumping on to D5 which are which
is our engine suggestions and I think
David you have to show us what the
problem is if black was to make a move
like that Knight jumping to A6 can white
actually build an attack by first
picking up the defender yeah I think
you're right Tanya if you find the right
move order there for white if you for
example remove that Defender as you
mentioned and then set up the threat
this is just simply deadly black can
block this diagonal with a pawn but
there will always be sacrifices for
example Knight takes upon here and this
will end I'm pretty sure on a Checkmate
I don't see it yet but it feels like
this black king won't survive much
longer feels like yeah maybe this one
yeah yeah slide in I'm wondering where
the Checkmate is after this
put that in your pipe and smoke it
that's how you get the job done oh
that's beautiful beautiful stuff there's
lots of checks there but uh instructive
nonetheless instead okay he did find the
second best move there Abdus tour
according to the computer not the best
Knight takes Pawn I think the idea here
was to block this diagonal with the F
Pawn but this doesn't look human this
just looks too weakening yeah you didn't
go for this instead uh yeah okay putting
the pawn on D3 I thought this wasn't
human either inviting the queen to D3 uh
with a gain of time but his whole idea
was to offer this queen trade and of
course this kid's not human it's
actually fascinating that he found that
I I I agree with you Simon what a great
find and when you see it on the board it
makes a lot of sense you bring the queen
to D3 so that when you take back the
pawn you get to offer a queen trade but
that's not an easy move to play when
your opponent wanted to bring their
Queen to D3 you give up the pawn and
invite danger but uh what an interesting
find of course white is still better
here as long as uh aronian finds the
right move would you say that this the
way he's played the last few moves not
about D3 Queen D3 and queen D5 this sort
of a resource it's sort of like a
glimpse into his genius
I mean he's the guy is as as Simon said
he's not human I mean he is human
um and and he's not cheating um you know
I can I can share because I get to share
funny stories like this and and I I
shared a story during the candidates
that I remember the first time a super
GM who will go unnamed accused all the
Rosa farooja of cheating
and I had to be like no he's not
cheating like he's just gonna be one of
the best players in the world someday
and I will say I remember the first time
that we were running in-depth reports on
a youngster who was coming out of
Uzbekistan and getting accused by people
as a cheater and they will go unnamed
and we didn't want to try their own
reports and uh and we said no this guy's
clean he's just very very good and at 11
years old now no Rebecca abdusa turov
has uh has become a world rapid Champion
so he's
he's uh he's a talented kid no longer a
kid I was just wondering how many times
those reports are being run many people
how many times you've been questioning
not many people have accused you of Jews
okay just just clarifying yeah okay
I will say that I wonder why that is
yeah nobody it's interesting and again I
don't even say that to disparage the
super GMS who've done that because they
care a lot and they're playing in in
high stakes online chess and they they
worry and they Wonder but we do a lot of
things there and uh and yeah Notre back
was clean we knew it when he was young
and he continues to deliver
so plan what you're saying is when
you're clean and if you're accused of
cheating that's a sign of how good you
are that's what I'm saying people are
talking about the fact that you can't
play like this like it's inhuman chess
and that's the kind of stuff that we're
seeing by uh this genius in front of us
not a back up to such off he became a
world rapid Champion when he was just 17
years old he is an Olympic gold medalist
already he's already won a Champions
chess Tour event does he have all the
makings and all the ingredients to be a
future world I I definitely think so I
think I think there a lot of young men
coming out of India who might have
something to say about that but if I had
to BET right now as far as the Next
Generation I mean you might be looking
at at one right there and and yeah I
mean these uh this guy didn't have a lot
of chances to prove just how talented he
was you had a global pandemic you had
all kinds of things happening where you
don't get over the board invites and so
I'm not gonna lie me and the entire
chess.com cheat detection team were
sitting there silently nodding and proud
when he went and won the world rapid
Championship because we're like oh now
he's winning over the board against all
of you guys now what do you think right
because this is a guy who didn't have an
opportunity to say like no I'm a monster
and here he is delivering in the highest
stage and now they know that he's uh he
might be one of the one of the futures
definitely one of the future uh
potential world champions out there so
not a backup disorder and in this
tournament as well the man to beat right
now can love on our Indians strike back
we will check back in with this game now
that this has calmed down let's take
this moment to go back to the other big
matchup Fabiano against Magnus Fabi
after being destroyed in game two how do
you assess his chances in this one David
yeah looks like a very tense middle game
a kind of uh just on a first look here I
prefer white just because it looks like
you have a beautiful night in the center
White's Queen Rook centralized White's
fiancated Bishops pointing at uh some
really nice diagonals butts black is
solid no significant weaknesses and
Simon you must be happy to see the black
H Pawn on H5 maybe the makings of a
attack against the white king a bit
later on yeah I mean even though saying
that I mean I I think black's done
everything he can he's got his Rook on
the open file he's got the H Pawn like
trying to nibble but just in general I
mean I used to play these kind of
positions all the time when I was a kid
as white and just in general they were
always very uncomfortable to play uh
that Rook is on a very weird Square Now
isn't it the first question I mean it's
like can you trap that rook and I think
fabby's doing the right things he's got
to play a bit tactically here he can't
go passive because if he goes passive
white can easily uh take over the
position here but uh what about that
Rook move interesting huh it's a
mysterious provocative yeah he's asking
Magnus to go and hit this rook and did
you see Magnus lean in for a minute he
was like wait is that legal you can
actually do this and now Magnus is
leaning back realizing that uh Fabi has
done some great calculation uh of course
one of fabi's strong points and the
reason I was surprised by quiet it's not
just because it's a weird Square it's
because also it's inviting the pawn to
C5 using this pin along the D file
Black's Pawn cannot go and grab this
Pawn because your queen falls behind and
you lose a rook in the process after
this trade uh the idea here for Fabiano
must be Rook B5 just giving up opponent
and now I'm not sure I see it but it
must be something to do with this Knight
you've given up a pawn
where is the compensation White's pieces
are a bit loose a bit clumsy here
especially this piece on B4
do you guys see anything here it's one
of those long-term compensation
positions I think because B3 is is
tender and not going anywhere right so
maybe there's a simple move like Bishop
E6 again don't quote me if the engine
yells okay the engine yells but maybe
not that loud I mean the point is I'm
I'm looking at the same thing right
white is up a pawn but the knight's
awkward the B3 Pawn is awkward White's
black snide is centralized well there so
Queen B6 as well
maybe that's the move okay it's the
night in the pawn but yeah similar maybe
it is it's really complicated isn't it
actually I mean yeah too many pieces on
the ball for me at the moment to
calculate too many pieces on the board
with it we let uh we let Carlson and
carlana I guess yeah one thing I will
notice is the clock has now evened up
when we first joined this this game a
few moments ago Magnus had a two minute
time Edge and so
good sign for carwana there yeah it
feels like Magnus is not quite all in
but if he doesn't go for the C5 push
then his Knight on B4 is Clumsy anyway
so it feels like if you're being
consistent you've said a you might as
well say B this was the whole idea
behind magnus's play but uh yeah let's
leave him with that dilemma David if you
want to pass awesome move here to Black
is there a direct threat that Fabi has
in the position
ooh have you spotted something Tanya
maybe it feels like something's loose
for white so I wouldn't be surprised if
there's a tactical shot
just beep on hanging and this strange
Rook lift by Fabiano very creative play
right there uh putting that rook in the
strange spot to create his chances we
saw a feature chat there earlier saying
is there a nicer guy than Fabi I think I
saw it too I wanted to call it out but
Bobby is is a knight is a nice guy and I
agree he's a a likable guy and uh
and yeah not just uh not just for the
catchers that he wears I love I love
he's got a great wardrobe probably has
an underrated wardrobe can we just call
that out yeah and I do love his podcast
I know his podcast is great if you told
me two three years ago that Fabi would
start a podcast I'd be like
come on but it's great I love it c
squared podcast go check it out Google
it right now if you didn't know Fabiano
caruana had a podcast just Google Bobby
on a car wanna chess podcast you'll get
it it's the best big question here to be
world number one to become world
champion do you need to have a little
bit of that Killer Instinct that bad
guys freaking you definitely you're
seeing fobby's too nice
seems like you're setting that one out
Tanya I think it helps right I mean if
you look at the world champions of the
past they're all a bit like mean aren't
they like Gary Kasparov you know he he
could like
yeah yeah you're right yeah he might be
the exception to the rule Fisher he had
a bit of a bit of a streak didn't he I
think I think matches is a bit of an
underrated competitor not I mean Magnus
doesn't have the same reputation for
intimidating his opponents like Gary did
at the board but Magnus I mean I think
part of what drove Magnus is he wanted
to be the best in the world and uh and
he went after it yeah he lets the trust
he did he sure does most of the time
most of the time how are we gonna go
there are we
I like it we have a big move here David
what's going on yeah let's still have
the chest to speak for itself in this
one Magnus has just stayed Magnus has
just played a really ambitious move but
then look at magnus's reaction he looked
away for a second
wow and all the pieces suddenly
disappear blink and you miss it we have
to go for an action replay there there
are some crazy tactics Magnus didn't
elect the most ambitious move if we
backtrack uh to this position he didn't
play C5 instead Bishop D4 and both
players had calculated this mess it
looks on the face of things that black
can Fork these two pieces but remember
after Bishop takes Pawn there is still
this pin along the D file white would be
winning here so uh Fabiano found a
really nice resource Knight takes Port
attacking the White Queen and after a
trade of Bishops it turns out that if
Queen takes Bishop this Knight is simply
hanging and uh let's quickly catch up
instead Magnus got rid of this Knight
Knight takes Pawn gaining time against
the black queen throwing itself on the
fire and uh after this trade we see C5
the White Queen Retreats and Fabi
activates level pawns level material but
I think if anyone I would choose black
big threats now Rook B2 and some Targets
on the second rank maybe the idea of H4
Simon and uh yeah Magnus is a bit
passive here
I really like what fabby's done in this
game I mean it's it's really positive
play with the black piece is against you
know uh one of the well the best player
in the world and uh it's not easy to get
anything and uh you know if anyone's
better here it's black right Black's got
the more active pieces he's got more
things he can do that white Pawn on the
explosive Square C4 is uh is is weakened
yeah it's just a little bit scary for
the Magnus here so and I so far we do
the do the shift in his seat and again
Bobby likes to call us out when we read
too much into body language but there
was a confident at the end of the
forcing combo you know when you kind of
check yourself and you're happy that you
didn't blunder anything you kind of did
one of these and looked at the clock and
all right like I think he's feeling like
this might be an opportunity he's now
got an almost in fact he does have a two
minute Edge on the clock
so uh we'll see if Bobby can return the
favor and get a win with black
check yourself before you wreck yourself
that's what they say I'm just trying to
think what that's from but anyway
um yeah it's it's it's looking looking
like a chance at least uh for Fabiano
though but saying that white really
doesn't have too many weaknesses here I
mean he's only got that pawn on the
left-hand side on C4 which is a real
weakness so Black's gonna have to create
another uh another area to attack on and
maybe that's where the H Pawn does come
in maybe now is a great time to push the
H Pawn and just open up the the white
king a little bit more this normal kind
of lever you play uh to do that
what do you think David is this the
moment to go for the attack on the king
side trying to create a bit of uh
tactics there with H4 yeah I would be
extremely tempted uh very interested in
it and there we go Fabi uh before great
call yeah before it's too late before
white gets to maybe look up that side of
the board he says okay come forward
create some dark Square weaknesses
Black's Bishop now is going to take a
step into the center removing white
Bishop which is actually White's blue
right now holding everything together
and yeah it feels like things are
turning in fabby's favor still some
serious pressure Magnus needs to be
accurate now I like that move because it
was a very ensure that I get to play for
two results kind of move right he wasn't
keeping anything dynamic or spicy not
going to let that light score Bishop
stay yes The Rook ending might have
drawing chances for Magnus but only one
player could possibly win that and
that's funny right so that's a very like
I'm gonna grind this out and make sure
that you have no winning chances and if
anyone can win it's me Bobby playing a
Flawless game so far can he make more of
this position we're going to take this
moment to jump into the other board it
was one where we thought love on our
Union will strike right back out of the
opening but a lot of Trades have
happened and how do you evaluate this
position David Wow Let's do a quick
count white has won two points white has
a pawn majority on both sides of the
board on both flanks but black has a
compensation in the bishop pair and
black to Rook on the second rank stands
very actively and big decision now what
to do with the threat against blacks
bishop and B4 you can Retreat that dark
Square Bishop you can trade it off for
white tonight but it feels like
exchanges will benefit aronia and it
feels like that will just guide him
closer to the winner I I agree exchanges
will benefit irony and I think I think
Notre back will play Bishop A5 but if we
can I want to quickly bring up the
analysis board and show a move where
even though the computer called it a
mistake I actually agree with Notre
Beck's decision given the Practical
pressure he was facing if you back up to
where he played Bishop F5 on move 20
David just following the game over here
Bishop F5 was called a mistake because
it concretely lose is a pond but let's
see what happened in the game it allowed
Rook F3 and the F6 Pawn to fall but if
you if you back up before Bishop 5 and
assess what would black do otherwise
you're facing the double the e-file
Brooks rookie seven is coming the F7
Pawn is going to be under Fire he took
his time here and recognized his best
chance was to give up a second Pawn to
make sure he got the bishop here and got
the Rook active and if we go over the
next few moves it's exactly what he did
the next few moves were blitzed out very
quickly he played King G7 and Rook D2
and I again I think Levon is pushing but
if you're defending a bad position and
only down one Pawn versus this position
here
and oh wait did he take let's see oh he
did and now okay interesting he's also
chosen to get the Rooks on the second
rank I thought he would play Bishop A5
to Bishop B6 to hit the F2 pawn and keep
the bishop here I think that might have
been actually better but um okay either
way I think he took an active approach
even if he loses the game I think it was
a solid defensive decision yeah it makes
a lot of sense Danny and the top players
they're very well versed in the fact
that it's actually going active even at
the custom material uh is often the way
forward and yeah at least in Practical
terms it looks difficult for Iranian to
try and convert this he plays the move
Rook to A6 and wondering what he has in
store uh if the Rook does come down to
B2
I mean there's also ideas maybe like
Rook C8 trying to win this Pawn if the
whole Queen side disappears if these two
white pawns are full at the cost of
Black's A7 Pawn then you think uh most
likely it's going to be a draw with just
the king side uh so some uh hope here
for Abdul sotorov to hold this game
despite the two-point deficit silent
yeah no I agreed I mean I I think he
he's so tough to beat uh this naughty
Beck I mean I've seen him play so many
games now here and elsewhere and he's
just such a fighter and you know we're
talking about future world champions and
there's so many of them right I mean
we've got the whole of India now pretty
much is coming from the entire country
you could be like one of those one of
those million you know kids who are just
phenomenally good and work so hard but
and there's something about naughty Beck
which is quite special as there are many
other kids and I it would not surprise
me at all if he if he kept going kept
improving and proving like that more
moves on the board here though and
aronian keeping his to point advantage
keeping the pressure there but not a bag
with his aim just start of a 65 accuracy
in end games can you hold this one is
this closer to a draw or a Levon win
Danny I I'm thinking it's closer to a
draw because my first thought was Rook
A2 could have been met by Rook E3 but
actually no Rook C1 would have been a
big problem so actually yeah so now that
now that I know that uh white White's
Rooks can't really work together
I feel like there must be some way for
black to Corral that a pawn I admit I
don't I don't see it but David already
pointed out and we always have to see
the the forest through the trees the big
picture if the apone disappears that
three on two is likely not going to win
not just because it's hard to win only
one Pawn that Bishop is the wrong color
corner of of of the pawn structure over
there so very good drawing chances for
black
um and and I like this move here I think
I think Notre Beck has actively defended
the game shout out to diberetsky right
taking taking the leaf out of the book
He's actively defended oh we're the kind
of endgame player that we've seen by
notderberg in this game that aim chest
start from 65 we might even see that go
up higher and right now let's take this
moment to jump back to our other game
Magnus versus Fabi and it's a it's only
the heavy pieces on the board and Magnus
picking up a pawn there but the king
feeling slightly unsafe wow yeah more
than slightly after this Lost Queen jump
maybe Magnus missed this one some severe
threats now on the third rank Black's
Queen Black's Rooker lined up Ma massive
threats on the board how does Magnus
defend he's a pull-up but okay he gives
a check and there we go the queen is
going to come back and hold everything
together only 90 seconds as well I guess
a minute 39 but I'm
looking at that C4 will fall F4 will
fall
a will the king fall will the king fall
who's King white does have threats as
well
d8 and queen h8 mates and Black's King
suddenly for the first time in this game
not feeling comfortable
yeah if white gets G5 and queen H6 and
Rook d8 I mean that's Checkmate yeah I
mean these kind of complicated positions
Simon how much do those extra seconds on
the clock matter they matter a lot right
and Fabiano has those extra seconds at
the moment so he I mean this is in chess
essentially you can move quite quickly a
lot of the time and generally you only
get like let's say three critical
moments and in those moments you have to
spend more time because you need to
calculate through them but other times
some of the moves can be pretty obvious
and this is certainly a critical moment
here because uh there's pawns on pre the
queen can come in with a check there's
so many possibilities that black can
play in
um if Fabi picks the right one I'm
expecting keep the pressure on I mean
again having the evaluation bar there
sometimes I wish it would just go away
because if I was looking at this now I'd
be like black must be doing well right
if I was playing I'd be thinking black
must be doing well because I can take
pawns I can do stuff but the evaluation
bars just say
nothing to worry about right he took the
pawn on H4 and he's like I'm holding the
whole fort down yeah break this down for
us white is up two pawns but the eval
bar stays level what does that actually
mean well I think that black can't black
can't win back those pawns and maintain
the pressure that that Bobby has on the
third rank so yes you could take like
those two pawns but by the way if we do
account white has five of them right now
so if you win back two pawns the count
is even if you keep the pressure
optically it looks dangerous but where's
the beef right where's The Knockout blow
as David is showing on the board so I
think that it's yeah it's it's hard
sometimes when the computers make chess
look easy and and and we we hate them
but uh but the truth is I think you know
in some ways they give some clarity
through the smoke which is white can't
well I'm sorry black can't do everything
you can't keep the pressure and win all
the pawns back and I love what you're
highlighting David you also don't want
to blunder because maybe maybe Magnus
plays Rook what happens if Queen AJ is
coming over yeah I think the Saving
Grace is that Queen takes H3 I was like
what happened okay why was white was
about to win but no Queen takes H3 yeah
stopping Queen to h8 Checkmate because
the black queen protects a bit of an
x-ray there and this will lead to uh
what's gonna be it's actually a slightly
difficult endgame for white so maybe
still some pressure here looks like this
is on the board what does Magnus try
instead uh if he goes for that variation
just to show it again then uh black is
going to win a pawn black is going to go
up one maybe still a draw but okay this
is incoming it's on the board and from
being two pawns done Fabiano caruana
goes into a rook Pawn ending upon up oh
you better say I think it's yeah King G2
games a Tempo then you can guard the G4
Pawn I think F3 is the move and you give
up the C4 Pawn Yeah he goes no he
doesn't that's the analysis board yeah
and we'll reach an endgame such as this
one where Magnus is the one fighting for
his life fighting for the draw so still
some hard work ahead an alias 45 seconds
Bobby's trying to Magnus Magnus
so if Magnus was black would you be like
winning for black just resign tough
would be yeah yeah it's pretty funny how
you sort of Judge it on the players
somehow and uh Magnus pulling up just
resign I would resign I'd resign against
Beaufort and basically I mean I'd just
be like yeah I've had enough I mean I
hate defending these Grim endings I mean
again the evaluation bar is just
annoying me it's a pawn but the
evaluation Bar says no it's not a pawn
it's equal why why we're almost in the
territory as humans where the computers
have taken their dominance one step
further with the table base win which is
for those who don't speak table based
fluently it is currently trying to solve
chess backwards to forward and I think
we're at eight pieces now eight total
pieces so nine will be next you're
solving you know billions of possible
positions so you'll look at this
position and just have a result it'll
just tell you it's not there yet but I
mean we're getting there Simon so more
lack of fun coming wow
we are going
to India other game the fun does
continue as it's not only Fabi who's
upon up but Levon aronian has also
managed to snatch up some material we
will get back to this as Magnus is
playing on seconds but David let's get a
quick update from you what are the
chances of 11 striking back in this one
I think pretty decent chances he has
this past a point why it's a pawn
survived somehow we weren't so sure
about that he has had to give back a
Pawn on the king side but having one
extra pawns better than nothing the one
downside here for 11 aronian is that his
Bishop for now is a bit stuck protecting
uh the white king so I'm gonna say it's
gonna be 50 50 between a draw and a win
for Iranian that's really putting it on
the fence isn't it
I'm not committing to anything
future politician right there yeah
politically correct answer very good
answer I love this move King G6 by the
way because he might play F5 and if you
take King G5 maybe just kind of putting
the the freeze on the position to take
away the rook's x-ray vision or or
dominance of the fifth Rank and just a
fun idea to show okay but even so the
Eva bar creeps up because of the pawn
but like what do you do next and this is
black is holding the second rank your
Rook is frozen to guarding both the A
and F pawns so anyway we'll see oh Notre
break does play F5 although he just
makes the trade it's on the board simple
idea wow and lebanaronian is pushing in
this one but it's gonna be a longer game
Let's head back to Magnus playing on
seconds can he hold that end game David
oh it looks like Magnus has built a nice
formation here just caging the black
king black is still a pawn up but if you
can't bring your king into the game
then it won't be enough it shouldn't be
enough here the black rook and pawn
alone cannot do the damage and white
king is just about holding uh the pawns
together so Fabi he might try something
similar uh to what ituruzaga tried uh
early against Jordan van Forest just
putting the black Rook down to the first
Rank and pushing the black C Pawn but I
think when would you're kind of playing
without this King now shouldn't be
enough
agreed yeah I mean I I think you know
Magnus one of the best well the the best
end game player ever and he knows what
kind of positions to head towards and
the King just coming over to take that
pawn more pawns get in exchange well
that's much more likely to become a
drawer as well
uh draw looking very lightly now I was
about to say that we came here thinking
Magnus was down to seconds Fabiano down
to eight seconds as well so don't don't
let this get away from you Fabi that
would be the worst thing possible if
Magnus found a way to do a Time scramble
swindle he
it looked like something was not quite
all right I I think he was I think he
thought there was there was lag but
there wasn't I think he was like oh
that's Fabiana moved I think sometimes
the players get nervous in those cases
where they're they're worried that uh
the moves aren't registering but
repetition coming off on the this one
ends in a draw Magna is shaking his head
in relief uh Fabiano caruana
disappointed it was his chance to get
this one he did push maximum as much as
he could but it was never enough and of
course the end game touched the end game
Maestro Magnus Carlton holds this we've
got action still on on the other board
let's jump straight to that live on here
still fighting for the win still
fighting and uh there are Bishops on the
board this time so not a pure Rook end
game that increases levon's chances of
winning uh having an extra combination
of pieces there however Black's Bishop
is so well placed in the center of the
board keeps an eye on the promotion
square of the white porn and okay the
black King's coming in something similar
to what you mentioned Danny yeah trying
to close a meeting that's around the
white king potentially I was going to
say with Levon under time pressure here
you know stranger things have happened
than than a weird result like that so
Lavon should push but be careful because
now look Rook A1 has a concrete threat
potentially a bishop D3 the king gets
out and Notre brick says yeah but I'm
going to check you back for a draw we
might even just liter oh no Lavon wants
more
wow so Bishop D3 doesn't Force the a
pawn to be lost all because of A8 Queen
aha so you lose the bishop I was Bishop
D3 would not work here because white
would sacrifice the queen in order to
win the minor piece so Notre break
doesn't fall for that trick
backs up yeah permanent the white Bishop
is just immobilized right now so you
need to somehow work some magic to get
the white king out of the second rank
without just uh without it being checked
and yeah it's lucky there because white
does have a H Pawn and it promotes on a
dark Square on h8 so even if you win a
piece if you win the black Bishop if the
Rooks disappear Black's King is going to
run to h8 and we call it opposite color
bishop and Wrongs rook's Pawn there
and yeah it's just not going to be
enough I think this one's going to be a
drop they're both very short on time now
as well so I mean Lev can obviously rely
on some tricks but I think they're just
repeating draw draw looking very lightly
now and uh this would be a great save
from lordy Beck I mean just uh being
under this much pressure it's not just
about crushing like it in the last game
it's about defending when things are
tough and that's something I've just
never capable of doing you know I just
get very despondent when I get in a bad
position as I'm sure a lot of people do
11 left still trying here and of course
he's got to but
um he's got to be a little bit careful
this is a nice trip I love too again
pointing out if the Rook makes the
mistake of holding the second rank white
will sacrifice The Rook for the bishop
and then get a queen so so Notre pick
rightfully lets the king out of his cage
Lev's not giving up and I think love is
an underrated tricky I know he's not
known as the online Bullet or time
Scrambler but I've seen him pull a few a
few tricks so let's see let's see what
happens here in this time scramble you
managed to untangle himself get his
pieces active the king is coming out
this is far from over
I agree and uh he's not gonna give up
right he's going to push everything to
the Limit here I still think Notre
Brick's defense has been awesome and and
I love the moment earlier we talked
about where he chose the active defense
to kind of get out but but now you gotta
hold you gotta hold with seconds for
Lavon 14 seconds for not to back
what's going to happen here what are our
predictions in this end game will not
back hold this
I think yes because material is
disappearing he now has counter play for
the first time in a while at least in
terms of Pawns there we go one drops and
it might become a race at the very very
maximum here it feels like Levon he's
going to get rook and Bishop versus Rook
where Black's Bishop will sacrifice
itself for that far Advanced White a
pawn and uh that one
it's a hard defense but it should be a
draw so uh we'll see if we get that far
Levon meanwhile he's achieved step one
God his pieces three but is it enough
still no clear path to promotion for
that white apron and Black's got counter
play it's a race you made a good point
that you can't even offer the trader
Bishops here because if you trade
Bishops black can sacrifice The Rook for
the pawn and now you have a Quarter Pawn
so I think I think Notre back has seen
the worst of it I think he's holding and
Levon is sort of checking for good
measure but
I think we're gonna have a rook Bishop
what's this drug do not trade drugs wait
I'll try not wait why can't you just
change huh I thought you would just
stick Bishop A6 Bishop oh yeah he's but
he's too slow now but I I also had a
mini
a bit of eval preemptive panic attack
but it didn't happen I just think it's
so impressive how he's held this game
yeah you know let's let's remember he
was he's gonna hold it now I mean it's
uh Queen's gonna be Queens at the same
time but it's uh you know he's two pawns
down against uh such a brilliant in-game
player and uh it just impresses me more
and more the more I see him play yeah
and just Kings on the board and the same
storyline love on our onion here
disappointed that he did not get the win
he was the one pushing throughout the
game with amazing defense resourceful
play there by not a back he's relieved
with the outcome it ends in a king
versus King which means that Magnus
Carlsen and not about keep their lead
love on our onion he did stop the
bleeding after round one you know it's
funny I I think he made a great point
that uh Lavon was pushing and so is
fobby in the other game and it's funny
both of those players would be feeling
better than Levon looks on camera if not
for the previous result right Bobby was
pushing as black against Magnus Carlsen
the entire game just came up just short
that's that's something you normally
feel good about Lavon almost one is
white and put the kid Under Pressure but
again because they both lost in the
first round neither of them went away
from that feeling good yeah I was a
fighting chest thereby the players in
the winners semi-finals David what was
the moment that stood out for you yeah I
Just Want To Praise In general the high
quality of that round in both of the
matchups and actually the one moment
that made a big impression on me was
here Levon aronian keeping the game
going after some great active defense
from Abdul sotorov and after Rook C2 it
looks like black is ganging up on the
second rank if you push this Pawn
forward now the trick that Abdul satorov
had in mind was really really nice the
bishop to D3 would have been the move
sacrificing and deflecting away the
white Bishop on F1 and we would have
seen a Perpetual check here instead
Levon aronian found a way to keep the
game going he pushed his Pawn forward
brought his Rook the whole way around
and the whole way back to keep the fight
alive but eventually Abdul satorov with
great tenacious defense holding the fort
just really high level game yeah I think
both players played um incredibly high
level in both of those matches and you
know it keeps the lead for Magnus and
for nordi Beck and you know how did you
beat them you know if you can't win
those positions you know what what you
need to win and and it's going to be
it's going to be tough to to break down
their defenses that's the big question
and the question that right now Fabi and
love have to find a way to answer we
just do rapid games remaining this is
where we stand in the winner semi-finals
NADA back and Magnus keep their lead but
it could have been a very different
narrative with the chest that we saw in
game two it's clear now we're in for a
big game three and we will be back with
all the aim chess a rapid action in just
a few moments
[Music]
thank you
want to improve your game click the link
in the chess.com navigation bar to try
aim chest today and increase your rating
31 faster than standard tactics puzzles
when you sign up for aim chess our
powerful AI breaks down your latest
games and provides actionable insights
to immediately improve your game you
will also receive personalized lessons
created from your game history to help
you learn from your mistakes in a custom
made study plan to help you reach your
goals
learn chess your way with aim chess your
digital chess coach
[Music]
it's your moment to get that targeted
training in
with the aim chess analytics and lessons
and we also have some great stats on the
players by aim chess let's take a look
at all the strengths and weaknesses and
there we have it opening accuracy of a
100 Pine nutty backup Decatur some
incredible prep there and end game
accuracy of 65 great end gameplay buying
order back in that previous round two
defending and holding a difficult end
game and David I'm just thinking with
aim chess all these stats that we get
the weaknesses and the strengths you can
use it to improve your own game but you
can also use it to prepare against your
opponent that's right aim chess is
really cool in the fact that you can
enter your opponent's games you can
enter their online usernames and you see
exactly their openings exactly their
style their preferences and especially
at this Elite level gives a real boost
but I think Club level even beginners
it's uh just a shortcut it's just a it's
like having a personal trainer in a way
and yeah highly recommend it's great it
reminds me of top trumps you ever play
that where you see their scores and
you've got to try to work out which
score they're going to be weak at and
trying to Target that area and well it's
very hard to Target these guys and I
need to uh I need to work out myself uh
what my scores are when I get back I
don't do you think they'll be as good as
that Tanya or up there somewhere it's
very close
you're such a great politician I love it
both of you are fantastic let me try it
wow but you can get your M chess uh
stats to start that targeted training
and improve your chance in ninja speed
right now it is Fast and Furious chess
in the AM chess rapid as we go into
round three that's coming up Lavon
aronian Fabiano caruana have to win a
game to level their match and we've got
moves on the board Fabi once again
starting with the King spawn opening a
sicilian and this time a repeat of the
2018 World Championship Match David wow
Deja Vu but Magnus didn't employ this
move in the 2018 World Championship
Match it's only become fashionable
recently actually thanks to the efforts
of Mr Carlson himself but yeah
interesting Tanya that uh we're back
there five whole years later and they're
still debating this exact opening
oh I remember that one it was so close
I'm not sure who won the opening debate
it felt like Fabi was always putting
pressure as white uh in that world
championship match but this time it
looks like Magnus is confident
looks like he's ready to put his leg up
again just like yesterday is that his
tail do we think when he gets his leg
over
[Laughter]
Magnus the teapot and then he's
confident yes so uh he's got he's got
the teapot arm right he's just ready to
pour and get his leg out and then he's
going to be doing well yeah he's up a
point in the match she's saying bring me
the tea yes yeah bring bring me the
money show me the money this is we saw
this yesterday with this opening it is
quite a peculiar position uh because uh
you know this bishop of blacks in front
of the pawn I mean you know again if you
had to do guess the ELO here I mean uh I
I wouldn't be convinced it was uh Magnus
Carlson uh to be honest and um okay he's
unraveling now but you look at his time
on the clock and he's uh he's more than
well prepared right he's been here
before I'm also just fascinated by the
fact that Favi is the first one to
change his approach in the opening in
this battle of heavyweights right
Bobby's not interested in another open
Sicilian decides to go back to this
bishop B5
rosalimo thing that he's tried before so
always just kind of looking at the game
within the game there and uh again a
point for Magnus Carlson in terms of the
prep that he brought to this match
yeah and interesting because a few years
ago the conventional wisdom was don't
play slower positions against Magnus
he'll slowly work his magic slowly
outplay you but these days Magnus is so
good at the direct type of Chess when
it's just a battle of knowledge that
Fabi has been forced to resort to this
type of slow
Slow Burn just maneuvering pieces it's
almost reminiscent of a King's Pawn
opening E4 E5 where it is just about
Pawn breaks where you maneuver your
pieces and here we go Fabi trying to
undermine Black's Queen side there's
some pressure there's a threat on the
a-file and uh Simon who do you think is
going to thrive in this type of closed
middle game
I am what are both very good at these
kind of positions I mean I you know it's
very hard to beat Magnus in such a
structure but maybe this is uh fabi's
last chance I mean this is at last white
unless he wins you know otherwise if he
doesn't win this game he's gonna have to
win uh with the black pieces and that's
going to be really tough because Magnus
as we've seen can really dictate the
game and send it in a direction he wants
to send it especially when he's got the
white pieces so I think you know Fabby
has to push here as much as he can and
he he does have better squares he can
move his pieces into so I'd prefer to be
white if I had to pick a side here ah
Fabiano caruano with his final weight of
the match this is round three he has to
level the score by winning at least one
game in the match he needs to do it in
this one if he can because he plays
Black in the fourth round it's the same
storyline here as Levon aronian playing
Black has to try to level the score or
at least make sure things don't go out
of control if not a back takes a win
with white that's much over for Lev do
you think not a back is he going to try
to push hard will he take extra risks
here
I don't think he needs to I think he
just you know there he won't try that
same opening again I really you know
he's got a victory from it maybe he'll
go D4 just go back to his normal play uh
okay if Lev gets equality and it's a
draw still okay he's half point up
there's no no reason to risk it here at
all yeah but at the same time I would
say don't change your style yet right I
mean there's two full games left in the
match right and uh you shouldn't be
neglectful of the fact that you're up
again but you shouldn't do anything
crazy either right stick with your style
stick with the stick with the game plan
so wow so sell for the kill David yeah
some Mind Games here Levon rarely
switches it up usually he's very
consistent with uh E4 E5 as black and
Abdul sotorov meets it very quickly with
this modern trendy line of bringing your
queen out just again disobeying all
chess wisdom and losing to Tempe with
your queen in order to get this Pawn
structure with white having slightly
more space in the center so again it
feels like left slightly out of his
comfort zone he's paused here just for
uh what is it around 20 seconds so far
as he tries to get to grips with this
new position is this the Carlson
variation is it something that Magnus
first first came up with I think with
the white putting the queen here the
bishop here like you said it looks
clumsy but it has has a lot of point
right so yeah it's similar to the
constant Sicilian I think is Magnus uh
bring his Queen out to D4 and then back
to D2 and often trying to thinkato on
the queen side but same idea is just to
get this maroxy binder I think we'll see
now and uh or in the next couple of
moves of white just controlling as much
space as possible and yes clumsy
development but you have a grip on the
position and I'm not sure who this will
face but look at the clock times both
players super Speedy up to this point I
love that we're calling it The Carlson
Sicilian here the Innovations are
happening more and more by by top
players not necessarily they're not
getting move one named after them
anymore right because all those are
taken
um but you are seeing with preparation
David a lot of players get creative
right because here's what happens you're
you're at home
with the neural Nets and the lilas and
the stock fishes and they're like look
at this position this is equal and
you're like well why are more people
playing this like who cares about the
fact that it says I couldn't bring my
queen out or this isn't the most trendy
variation of the open Sicilian it's an
equal position where there's surely a
ton of resources for both sides and it's
just it's exciting because I think again
for all of us 20 years ago computers
were sort of putting the nail in the
coffin and announcing the death of the
game because people were afraid to make
mistakes now I think you have players
playing more creatively and and looking
for more chances like this than ever
before because the computers are like
you can play any position any position
is playable any position is playable and
we saw earlier the aim chess start for
not a bag opening accuracy of a hundred
percent
crazy opening preparation the kids these
days David how do you handle that what
is anti-young player chess that's why I
want to retire these kids are too good
in the opening uh Magnus Carlsen coined
this uh term kind of old Manchester
young player Chess at least it's just
getting a position where all the pieces
are on the board you can slowly
strategically outmaneuver them and it's
often just taking a position that the
computer does say is worse and yeah
nowadays just like Danny said the
computer says everything is equal that's
kind of 20 years ago it was like oh
everything's equal now it's like
everything's equal come on let's go and
actually Magnus takes it one step
further playing something that does lead
to a disadvantage objectively but is
provocative I I love that you said that
because Fabiano karawana when he joined
us in 2021 for the World Championship
coverage for Yonder Palm Desi versus
Magnus Carlson he he said the same thing
he said that a lot of high-level prep
these days the secret is that you're
looking for a position that is
objectively somewhere between like 0.25
and even like 0.49 like a half a cent
upon worse because your opponent will go
for this and if you went a little bit
deeper maybe there's a resource you
always have this Force draw line but
maybe there's a resource that they don't
understand and that's where your biggest
opportunities come is in players
thinking they have some sort of
comfortable Edge but you understand the
position better so just fascinating to
see how how players are leveraging
modern engines and and new psychology to
take on these positions yeah I think I
think that's also why a lot of people
may be watching this
you shouldn't play like these guys you
know you shouldn't play the same
openings because uh if you you know this
is this is a trend I see that you know
players may be rated around 1200 they're
like you know they watch Magnus cast and
play and they're like oh yeah he's the
world champion I'm going to play that
opening but you shouldn't because it's
it's a totally different game that
they're playing I mean uh you have to go
through the basics first you have to
develop your pieces you have to learn
all those other openings before you can
get the subtleties that they're doing
and uh you know not not copying is not
always good copying the top players in
the opening not always a good plan for
example I wouldn't recommend you play
like this as white
um because you you know you're going
against a lot of principles and uh
unless you really know what you're
trying to achieve in the middle game it
doesn't make any sense basically so yeah
that's a really great point to make uh
Simon because 186 with black is
definitely not something you want to
recommend to the kids out there but with
all these top players and all these
great chess players then is it a better
idea for uh chess fans to actually study
their game more to understand middle
game Concepts and end games rather than
follow them for the opening 100 I mean I
I think they say something like 94 of
all chess books are on the opening and
there's again so many lower rated
players maybe players watching this if
you get an opening book an opening
course and they get to move like 8 10
let's say 12 and then they have no idea
what they're doing next and it's so
important to know why are you playing
this opening you've got to ask yourself
the whys and the where's you know why am
I playing this move what am I trying to
get in the middle game where are my
pieces going where are my opponents
pieces going and if you don't know the
answers to those questions uh you're not
learning chess in the right way
um so yeah I would say there was a good
step 94 of books were written on the
opening and 94 of chess players are
wasting their time studying way too many
openings and not nearly enough other
chess Concepts so let's say my books no
it's been buying them please yeah it's
really cute I think I think players
latch onto that because they feel like
the opening is something that kind of
makes you feel good you can control it
because you're trying a new trick and
and you're like I'm learning a new thing
but really you know chess players pay
their bills and make their money on how
they maneuver and coordinate their
pieces and so studying positions like
this and then seeing how Abdul satura
might coordinate the white pieces or how
LeBron tackles it or the things that are
really are really uh the things you need
to know yeah it's all about the why
behind the move and that last move by
another back stepping out of that Bishop
the black Bishop range freeing up the B
Pawn to move further this is going to be
a fun strategic fight let's take this
moment to jump back to our other game
three from the winners semi-finals
bracket and wow what do we have here
David quite a fun position out of the
Spanish yeah fun it was from a sicilian
time
it looks like a Spanish
and uh yeah it's just a weird position
I'm looking at Black's pieces it's like
Magnus is playing Fisher random chess
chest 960 all the Blackness or the black
Rank and Fabiano's saying okay you go
back I'm gonna go forward and he's going
for checkmate or at least uh an attack a
blitz attack against the black king and
uh I can't blame him it looks dangerous
to me White's Rook as well on the a file
don't forget that side of the board it
might come up to the seventh Rank and
some serious threats starting to mount
up that's insane we started with the
swashnikov how do we end up with such
well actually we started with a rasa
limo that became a special cough
structure that then became a Spanish and
so it gets even weirder you're totally
right and I think it's funny the the
computer if we want to bring up the
analysis board first started to give
black a little bit of an edge when Favi
played the move that all of us would
have played he played Knight G5 a couple
moves ago to start the attack and launch
pieces toward the king side and the
computer's like no don't play this way
like I just you know I don't like you no
but I love what Bobby's doing here at
least from the perspective that in the
match he needs to get a win you're going
to put some pressure you're up a little
bit on the clock Rook a seven watch out
right full board awareness
there's a party there I'm invited let's
let's do it it's not for the first time
um
sorry Daddy it's just too good
opportunity not to say that wasn't it
I'm so excited to be invited now I'm
back to standing in the corner I've been
there don't worry anyway but no the
pressure there is is is is good and I
agree this looks like a Spanish where
white has some decent chances by the way
the Knight will come to G3 The Rook will
come to A7 again it's superficial we're
just sort of pointing out that there's
that there's General energy that is
building toward the king side but it
looks like an easier position for white
to play yeah I'm just super confused
that the engine thinks black is maybe
slightly better there's no obvious moves
for black here that I can see maybe you
can put a bishop on B6 just to stop that
one idea but what next for black and uh
maybe you can push this Pawn at some
point but again super risky to open up
lines squares around the black king
I'm Gladys Magnus here playing not me
and I think we can sense how difficult
it is because he's spending a lot of
time and wow after a long think there F5
he's breaking out he's uh who's
attacking who on the king side some
awkward tension as well between the
Queens on this diagonal getting shot all
you need to do is make Bishops jump here
don't you I mean if if white can move
his dark Square bishop and play Bishop
takes pawn it would be just the end of
the game uh and that looks it looks so
scary for black right Black's just
opened his King up more and uh again we
were talking about critical moments and
this is one of the one one of those
moments it's like white if he finds the
right thing well you know could be very
dangerous so many pieces coming in
I get I don't understand how black can
be doing all right here looks looks but
I guess it's one of the positions where
again this this generation who who grew
up using computers versus the one that
that uh had to learn to adapt I think
these guys have grown up using prep like
this I'm sure that they both know the
position is probably pretty complex and
that you know unless there's a concrete
blow like I can play this position
because I agree with you Simon it looks
very dangerous but I'm sure Magnus is
like where's the money show me the money
right there's nothing here I play F5 and
uh my pieces will come to life who's
attacking who but it's not the tipos
anymore Simon well it kind of is it's
the mini t-post they still got the arm
out and I might need to run to the
bathroom in a minute Post Yeah so I've
slightly opened my body language toward
the toward the exit door not that I
would know anything about that
I'm at F5 that was a brave move by
Magnus allowing fabi's light Squad
Bishop into the attack taking away his
quest from his own King but Magnus has
ideas of his own what I'm looking at is
magnus's background right now pieces
track stacked over there feels like
setting up for a Fisher random game to
me
quickly as possible
um there might be some threats in the
position as well Black's pawns are
slightly loose uh slightly tender there
I'm expecting magnets at some point to
start bringing his Bishops out the Black
Knights look like they're well placed at
the moment holding a lot of things
together again that tension between the
Queens with that Knight and the weight
I'm not sure who's gonna break it or how
it's going to be broken that's it again
just in Practical terms I think fabi's
position is so much easier to play uh
ideas of swinging that Rook up the a
file White's Knight in the center is
glorious the other night's gonna spring
forward Magnus has no easy moves and uh
that's why he's burning so much time on
the clock four minute difference almost
I I love that you said that because that
was the point I was just going to jump
on is that the clock is indicative of
who's a little more comfortable when we
can't make sense of it and the engine is
like it's roughly equal which doesn't
mean it's a draw it just means it's
complicated even for an engine the time
says that Magnus is a little
uncomfortable the D6 Pawn is the only
concrete sort of weakness on the board
right it's it's under a little bit of
pressure
I spy with my little night eye right and
and that means that there could be
tactics because that F5 Knight is is it
has a job to do so anyway interesting
Magnus does Play Bishop B7
I don't know that there's any concrete
thing to do here the engine also
suggests there isn't otherwise it'd be
going crazy but like Knight G3 I want to
invite a Trader that night because if
you take I get a pawn that also guards
F4 D6 is hanging now like maybe maybe
anyway just those those are ideas go
ahead Tonya question you know the idea
you mentioned you want to get that
Bishop 86 sacrifice in G4 will be
completely crazy here because black has
the option to actually pick up that
Bishop
it's
yeah I mean it's kind of the first move
I think you should look at G4 right
because you're trying to force the issue
and you're just trying to um take on H6
so I suppose it's the same as Danny's
idea isn't it bring the Knight out and
get rid of the night I mean uh it's the
kind of move which I've played far too
often G4 you know I've played it to Four
Seasons yeah then I've then I've made so
many holes around my king I I
immediately regret it but
um it's it's maybe an idea but bring I
mean it's so complex this position right
all the pieces remain on the board
um Black's King looks very weak Black's
got a great Center though and it's so
hard to work out um what's happening
here yeah I'm liking Danny's Knight G3
just solid safe and asks questions at
the same time that's all you can want to
remove pretty much so hey Barbie to
think this time you should keep that
pressure on the clock right it's a big
part of this format the clock is the
17th piece as they say and uh you've
never heard that before that was genius
I've never heard that I didn't come up
with it I don't know who said it but it
really struck I struck a chord there
because I think in these formats you
really have to pay as much attention to
your time management as you do to your
peace management
I I love it like I've heard of like the
12th man in like in like football like
the fan isn't part of the game or the
stadium but I've never heard that the
clock is the 17th piece there you go I
think we need to steal that I like that
yeah I'm gonna remember that one guys
oh that's that's true it could play a
big factor later on and that's actually
why I think Magnus and Hikaru have such
a big Edge often in these time formats
just because they're so quick so sharp
and they always have half an eye on the
clock but uh Fabi meanwhile in the tank
for a couple of minutes
she was like put that Knight on G3 pass
the move back to Magnus Magnus now is
for sure going to be calculating what to
do in advance so
um yeah a bit of time to think unless
Fab is calculating A variation such as
G4 or something similar to that maybe
not that move exactly maybe he's just
going to keep his dark Square Bishop
step it back one square and preserve it
for some sacrifices on H6 later yeah key
moment now you get nervous if you're a
Barbie fan that he's overthinking it uh
you know you've got
you've got a four minute time Edge on
the clock you had one anyway and uh
and so sometimes you know when you know
that you're better you you can you know
take a lot of time because you don't
want the moment to slip and in the
process you are overestimating your
advantage now you're back to equal on
the clock and not using the 17th piece
as Tanya would say right not using the
clock as a weapon no but it's really
true at this level those edges are the
things that pay off right so the clock
is a weapon you can't yeah you know you
can't make it um an adversary you gotta
you gotta have it on your side yeah
you've got to have it as your friend and
you might not realize it with seven
minutes on the clock but in those
crucial critical moments those extra
seconds they really help finding the
right path and right now with the clocks
getting Level it feels like Magnus has
steered his way out of too much trouble
I feel the same way I still like Knight
fg3 I I still think it's a good move for
for Fabiano but um
but he's he's thinking about it and so
yeah the clock is getting even the clock
is now even
um you know no no 17 feet anymore
well it's still the 17th piece it's just
no longer an advantage yeah he'll wish
he had one or two of these minutes back
a bit later on in 10 minutes time uh
yeah four minutes none of my feeling is
that he'll he'll play Knight fg3 but
wish he played it three minutes ago yeah
I think Magnus said this himself didn't
he said uh you know when when he makes
his worst moves it's when he has his
longest things right so he actually when
he when he thinks for over a certain
period of time he's not playing what he
his natural instinct is telling him and
these guys have such great Natural
Instincts you don't really need to doubt
what you're you're you know your inner
self is saying you know and there you go
yeah he did play it but he again he
should have played it faster and I think
again like we're not even guessing it
from the it felt like a natural movement
like because I'm looking at the 1905
which guards D6 and I I think
okay Magnus responds right away and I'm
not you know chess is not easy they're
obviously they would they would be
blindfolded but you just you can you can
observe when there's maybe something
psychological going on and it felt like
Fabi was overthinking the position from
watching it yeah it's like Uncle yasa
who always says same move but faster is
better and uh
for me uh yeah not H4 really nice move
by Magnus but it might have taken him
longer if he hadn't had that four
minutes except Abby was like he was just
sitting there thinking of and again
that's why again a lot of we're just
quoting Sean players today but like you
want to think on your opponent's clock
that's one thing that the top players do
super well Magnus thought a lot and
worked hard on his opponent's clock and
uh it's that Knight H4 blitzed out
Knight H4 he was ready for it so yeah he
was ready for it and with the Queens off
the board the pressure has gone down on
black the clocks are Level we will jump
back to this but let's get an update on
our other match not the back Abdul satro
wow that all things on the board just a
pair of bonds have been traded off this
is big tension and which is four minutes
on the clock that's going to be a 17th
piece for Abdul satrov can I just say
something in honor of Kaya
[Laughter]
but yeah I mean the bar is going mental
right I mean it it's just saying that
White's winning here and the black's
getting all of uh his pieces pushed back
and there's also a major problem with
that pawn in the middle of the board uh
White's ganging up on it um that last
move okay maybe there's other options
but it seems very pleasant for white
this position doesn't it so beautiful
position and it's no surprise if you
just look at the general kind of outline
of the position all of Black's pieces
are on his first two ranks uh Let's
ignore the pawns for now White's piece
is beautifully centralized beautifully
coordinated and the pawns are stepping
forward and it's going to be a big
attack and the clock says it all uh
again we we say look at the bar and look
at the clock right those two things are
very
you know indicative of what's going on
here when we left it although I'm
sitting here watching the games on on
chess.com's events events portal and I
and I want to point out that there
really haven't been any big Mistakes by
irony which really goes even more toward
notabeck's credit that he's just been
slowly outplaying this position the
space Advantage is just like
like he's just marching forward here and
he's just continuing to increase
um the the pressure so you got you gotta
love the way he's playing
yeah this is what they call the Hedgehog
formation as black when you kind of just
line up on your first three ranks and
often it's a bit prickly if you step too
far forward then black can counter
attack but here just looks like black is
passive Knights on the rim we've said uh
just Grim all the time and that Knight
on A7 looks horribly misplaced feels
like white at some point it's going to
combine the kind of central pressure
with a king side attack it's just uh how
to do that for a booster but he has a
five minute kind of surplus here to uh
to kind of find something Knight of six
though let's not write level off it's a
tricky position for both sides that's
yeah looks like the youngster afterwards
he's done everything right so far in
this game a lot of strategic trumps in
White's position space Advantage the
Rooks lined up D6 a big weakness for
Lavon aronian and four minutes on the
clock here if not a back manages to win
this one he actually wraps up the mat
Simon
yeah he does indeed yeah and he's just
he seems to be getting stronger and
stronger right I mean like uh his
confidence is growing and he's uh picked
a great opening here just grinding away
bit by bit and uh I wouldn't be
surprised if he just uh puts this in the
you know finishes it off now uh maybe
the only danger is that he overpresses
here do we think Danny I I was just
gonna say that you just you know
two peas in the potential or you can
just not you can embrace it no but
someone someone pointed out that one of
the other things to not underestimate I
think you're saying is like this is a
hedgehog type of position and sometimes
in those positions the one things we
know about computers is they they have
an equation with which they're
evaluating which is space and black
really has no weaknesses here like right
I mean you can put the Knight on C8 and
you can kind of wait a little bit and if
white does get crazy with moves like G4
in hedgehogs black will strike with D5
or B5 at some point the position becomes
open and and that's when things can get
spicy so I think one of the things we
should be careful about is not really
the thing I actually hate the most about
Lev's position is on the clock I hate
how much time he's down that's really
his biggest disadvantage because on the
board the space Advantage is there but
where's where's the concrete knockout
black is always a little worse according
to the computers in a hedgehog structure
um I'm gonna say it again I mean looking
at the cameras and the players in front
it looks like Lev's the one who's got
the lead in the match and not a brick
extra danced right now
yo he's a he's uh he's fidgety he but
he's focused he's fidgety but focused
you know there's a lot of kids like that
around around chess halls around the
world you know some of them have to
still sit on phone books while they beat
you through that little baby Focus
Legend another FFL famous
focused
fidgety Legend I was wondering what you
were trying to say I don't even know I
don't even know half the people know
what what the ffls were referring to but
shout out to you gotta
um
and he is playing division two I think
isn't he I don't mind
I don't know how he did today but he was
in division two
and me while he drops back the bishop
Abdus and still a great position the one
problem is that the onus is on him with
the extra extra space here to step
forward at some point so he will have to
take a few minutes there to calculate
and make sure he steps forward at the
right time and really initiates that
chaos
under four minutes he should be playing
quickly too he just needs to wrap up
into that ball like a hedgehog would and
hope that when the Breakthrough
eventually arrives that it's mishtimed
but yeah still liking White's position
okay nice solid move there holding lots
of things together
you know the bar goes up but and again I
don't have a ninja move I'm kind of like
where what's the reason what's the
reason was the and otherwise I just
think that it's the engines getting
excited about what we taught them to get
excited about which is space yeah and uh
we'll see how they use it I mean this is
where I I often go wrong in a position
like this I just want to play I just
want to finish it off all this
maneuvering Bishop backward and fours
putting a little bit of pressure on my
opponent at some point I just get
impatient and I just want to go F5 you
know I'm just like right and at some
point you do have to play a move like
this right
um if you want to win but
um it's obviously quite anti-positional
something like that because you're given
a big Square in the center but
still tempted I mean I don't know I mean
David you probably wouldn't go for that
would you you're this is where I've got
to learn I've got to learn from David
I'm a coward Simon not a cowards you you
do things you've got perfect timing I
think the reason I wouldn't play F5
specifically here is just because black
can trade the Queens off and with the
trade of Queens for the pressure lessons
but he plays it anyway wow does he maybe
there was something stronger that's such
a bad sign wow that's such a bad sign if
he's playing it I actually missed the
exchange of Queens David so I actually
just missed it and uh you're right that
that takes a lot of pressure off left
position doesn't it it's funny because
he's going for The Knockout blow but it
may be the thing that let's let back in
the match right he's maybe sensing the
opportunity to put it away but it's it's
it's exactly the way Hedgehog positions
go wrong for white eventually you play
that overextending pawn move whether
it's a G4 or an F5 and black finally
gets their life and black will have no
weaknesses as the pieces get traded off
but how critical is it for love to find
this queen trade
I think he has to otherwise you might
just get back mated as Simon says the
queen is coming in somewhere along this
diagonal and you might not get another
opportunity
can you go Rook D4 after I was wondering
about that but anyway and give up the
route anyway sorry I'm getting carried
away now but yeah this is a normal break
right this move but
yeah this is a big threats and White's
King has shuffled to the corner this is
getting crazy right now uh it's really
exploded white could have taken this
Pawn but this would have led to a nasty
skewer so he scoots out the way with his
King and
what to do now the gamer might pay off
for another book with with seeing
levon's D5 response because now if we
get a spicy position by the way white
has a three minute time Advantage it's
huge especially as we're about to see
fireworks and that Queen's going to come
to age six so uh maybe the the intuition
there was right that Lev for whatever
reason would not play Queen C5 and now
now the attack is on yeah the attack is
on why it's pieces are poised Lev needs
something with two minutes in this crazy
position you have like three or four
different Pawn captures here where do
you even start calculating with only two
minutes on your clock it's just pure
Instinct but this is a calculation type
of position
oh yeah I feel for black I think just
get the Queen's off and survive that was
her number one priority for black there
and it comes down to having those extra
minutes on the clock which right now
left doesn't have and move after move
he's making these inaccuracies
yeah this one feels wrong and looks
wrong just because white now can pick up
a pawn in the center and just set up a
wall of Pawns that block the black
pieces maybe that's even stronger here
for update sator of maybe your knight
captures on dude I'm gonna say like is
it time is it time I mean let's go like
all in is is there an opportunity to
take with D5 take on D5 with the Knight
I think the C Pawn also is good just to
make sure that we keep things as spicy
as possible I actually wouldn't take
with the epon because I want there to be
more trades White's pieces are more more
primarily placed which chess Theory
teaches us that if the position becomes
open the pieces that are in a better
spots should get better tactics right um
and look at Black's pieces Bishop on A8
91 A7
if this thing blows open white should be
in a better spot to clean up
need to be accurate here Abdi Satora but
looking very very promising he's
probably got more than one good move
that's the other you know that that can
be a bit of a hindrance I guess uh
sometimes because you you overthink the
position but he's got the time to do
that so I mean which way would you
capture her David Instinct first
instinct told me he takes D5 just
capturing away from the center with
White's uh kind of middle Pawn here just
because I wanted to keep pieces on the
board I just thought actually black is
the one who's cramped to keep business
on but the more I look at it I think uh
more I'm inclined to agree with Danny I
kind of want to open up this white
Bishop on B2 go for the kill go for the
kill yeah watch your 17th piece LeBron
sorry
yeah it's ticking down and we're just
gonna update everyone the the Magnus
Fabi game the third game is uh in all
probability going to end in a draw it is
a very peaceful position we'll stick to
the drama here because all the action
here and they've nodded back wins this
it's actually match over yeah Notre back
could be the first person to punch his
ticket to the next round again he just
won the chess game cut he's uh he's on a
roll here it's not over yet we're about
to see fireworks but uh the kid is on
fire it's on fire we don't see him as
often entitled Tuesdays but he's been
playing Amazing online speed chess it's
funny yeah I mean he used to be a staple
in fact that was where he first got
accused because he was winning Donald
Tuesdays but um he's uh yeah you know
he's he's obviously super focused we
know that he uh I don't know if we're oh
come and take his cup commentators curse
this feels wrong on multiple levels
though it feels like you allow black
various different hits on the White
Queen feels like you've given your
opponent a lot of choice the Black
Knight can jump in the center black can
give away a pawn with D4 open up this
bishop 188 I think in general in chess
if you can give your opponent as minimum
kind of as few options as possible
especially in speed chess that tends to
be a huge benefit I mean if it pays off
then I'll leap my words but just it
feels wrong I haven't calculated things
here like after satorov has but enough
on options how many just basing this on
pure calculation otherwise I mean it's
very anti-positional as you mentioned
you know it just feels wrong but it must
just be you know he's crunching the
position right he's saying I'm attacking
the Knight the Knight has to come here
and now we're going to see what his idea
is but uh
very strange decision though it's also
very risky I was going to say what's the
idea is he prepared to sack The Exchange
he's got something up his sleeve but
he's paused again surely by playing E5
you've got kind of a continuation uh
immediately in mind also he's blocked
this this dark Square Bishop on B2 he's
blocked his own attack Black's Knight on
e4 if it survives it's gonna be a
menacing piece it's also Bishop C5 is is
a big threat now that that movie
mentioned before uh the bishop attacking
White's Queen uh could could could be uh
something which is scary yeah Bishop
coming either way and uh well he he's
given counter play to
um Levon when he just didn't need to you
know this is again a mistake maybe maybe
a little bit of Youth that he could have
played one of the moves that David or
Danny recommended just kept a very nice
structure kept total control but there's
no reason to give your opponent counter
play unless there's something Concrete
in the position and um okay well what on
Earth's going on now this is his idea
it's on the board he wants to line up on
this diagonal maybe creep in here the
White Queen creeping into H6 he needs to
deliver Checkmate though White here
otherwise his Knight on H2 is simply
sidelined and whites are Pawn down so
Stakes are incredibly high right now but
from a practical perspective obviously
we have the benefit of the eval bar and
we can we feel the position has slipped
away probably they do too but he's
looking at the clock he's down two pawns
now Fabi he's Danny he's got to go for
the king is it Knight G4 is this his
possible idea just trying to get the
fish pin I can't you know but that is no
I don't know
Knight G4 wow you know I love the vines
I love playing rubbish moves you know
but I mean what else could it be I mean
but this is really all in now right you
know you're giving Pieces away you're
not liking your pawns or your pieces
anymore and the idea of this moves try
to get your other Bishop in this is the
only idea of it but it's very risky and
very risky under 20 seconds did you see
as well I've just sort of played that
move then he looked off at aronian's
camera he was like deal with that yeah
Bishop takes
and now this black king is not going to
survive the white Bishop's White Queen
are going to come in Rook D7 looks
powerful here Rook d7's the move Rook D7
I don't think he saw that as well isn't
there a massive check on it
how's he going to kill this one it's on
the board Rook D7 all the pieces coming
into the attack the phone just didn't
have time on the clock once Bishop gives
a check the White Queen is going to
follow in next is Queen f4s in some
positions you can just trade queens and
made on E5 oh that's beautiful that is
beautiful that's it
Lavon is freaking out he's got five
seconds it's over that's nice yeah
um fidgety focused Legend over there he
knows he's seconds away from actually
wrapping up the March 11 and it is much
over wow
unbelievable not a backup do such
robotics the second win the inner or in
the winners bracket what a stellar
performance this is by the 18 year old
continuing his run he's the man to watch
out for he could very well win his
second title of the Champions Chester
it's amazing because he he it wasn't
clean
but he got the job done right and he
felt the moment and kept the pressure
we're obviously checking back now on
Magnus who I don't think is going to get
the Dub here we'll likely have one more
game after this is a draw but I'm just
blown away by by how noterbeck finished
the job there again it was messy but we
have the benefit of it looking messy
because the eval bar really that was an
aggressive and very very fanciful
tactical attack winning game yeah I
think he should be proud of that updates
of tour if he played the human approach
as well he went for an attack when maybe
there was a defense but it wasn't easy
for 11 Iranian in no time the 17th piece
decided that one Tanya I think that's
the whole point right he played the
position as well as the clock he might
have not calculated the whole thing but
he played fast he put the pressure on
the clock and that got him the big win
that was the human approach and it
worked to Perfection and in this one
this looks like it will end in a draw
which means Fabi will have to win with
the black pieces
yeah uh it does look like that black
king is almost checkmated but anytime
you hit it if you ever push the white G
Pawn forward to give a check Flex King
has an escape Square so if there's no
Checkmate unfortunately that does mean
it's likely to end in a draw and Black's
Rook I really like this really
instructed from Magnus Carlson he's put
it on the fourth rank cutting off the
white king so the white king can never
step forward to hit those weak black
pawns whites Rook as well if it ever
moves away the black king will just
sneak in so I think Magnus can just wait
here just pass with his Rook oh look at
this
that's just too much that is so
unnecessary by Magnus I mean they say
there's no sense of humor in chess but
that shows there is sense of humor yeah
that was pretty that would have been
awesome to see it on the board but David
your idea might be coming up the king's
Lighting on the other side G3 Checkmate
yeah let's just quickly show that again
in action replay Rook to E4 any Rook
move here is pretty much fine Rook B4 is
fine Rook check if you take it with
either king or Rook this is stalemate
ignore the bar this is stalemate yeah
and it would be a draw meanwhile Fabi
has gone for a Checkmate on the other
flank he wants to play G3 trapping this
King but again the Black Brook does the
job of Defender it pins this Pawn keeps
it honest and there's no way through no
route to Checkmate this is gonna fizzle
out to a draw but nice moment of
artistry there from Magnus yeah
it's nice to see that because I mean you
could have you could have played other
moves as well you did not have to play
the flashy move but we we all want a bit
of uh you know Magnus is an entertainer
right he's uh screaming in the middle of
a Coliseum are you not entertained right
he's uh yeah bring it in there's a smile
right there before he turns off the
camera
I was into the fourth round with Fabiano
caronas still trailing the match he
needs to win to force the playoff Magnus
needs just a draw to continue in the
Winner's bracket and there we have a
Fabi what do you guys think is he
looking at the previous game or is he
preparing for the next one
I think he's probably quickly looking at
the last game sometimes you need
emotional closure you know just so you
can move on with uh with full Focus
looks like he might be quickly looking
at where it got away from him because he
was a little better there he's been
pushing the last two games there Fabiano
caruana but yet to get that big win that
ended peacefully but the not a bad game
was anything but peaceful what an attack
that was what a finish that was David
once again take us through the Highlight
yeah the Highlight has to be those final
few moves when nodded back went for a
practical sacrifice and it paid off due
to erroneous lack of time on the clock
here we were saying oh he's let it slip
he's blown it he sacrificed two pawns
nodded back here and the compensation is
a bit dubious but Knight to G4 a
beautiful move a beautiful sacrifice and
actually it should have been ignored
irony had no time on the clock and
panicked at the thought of a night check
but if he had just stayed calm and
brought his Knight to C6 he would have
still been in the game Pawn takes Knight
however was catastrophic and after the
bishop joined the attack this was deadly
the bishop is coming in due to the
crisscross here as well all of White's
pieces are attacking and the killer blow
was Rook to D7 let's just show the final
position after a bishop check as Danny
mentioned the king tries to hide in the
corner a simple Queen trade kills the
game and the Bishops do the work
Checkmate and aronian is eliminated from
the Winner's bracket
stunning chest there which means that
Levon will go down to the eliminate
Asian bracket let's take a look at our
core line going into the final game for
Fabiano caruana and Magnus Carlson
nordeback updu satro of wrapping up his
match against LaVon aronian in just
three games that's not a score line that
many would have predicted at the start
of the day and we are being joined by
the winner of that match not the back
congratulations once again
thank you what a match that was wrapping
it up in three games how pleased are you
not only with the scoreline but the
quality of play as well
yeah obviously I didn't expect to win
the match in three games but yeah I
think the first game was pretty much
very important and
yeah I played this uh dubious line which
which is objectively just lost
but uh in a practical game it's just I
think it's too too hard and
yeah
I managed to to win him quickly and and
then I just switched to the you know
playing solid chess and it worked out
well wow so not a bag you knew that you
were walking into a line that should be
lost if your opponent knows how to
respond
that's amazing what a practical choice
and it paid off and then game three that
was also quite an attacking Masterpiece
now there was this moment where you
sacrificed the peace
how can wins for you of that sacrifice
yeah I felt that my advantage is
slipping so I just tried to you know
create a mess
as possible so yeah I just saw this E6
Fe 9g4 with a good uh but it was very
dangerous looking uh threats so yeah he
had to play 96 but it's you know it's
with 20 seconds in his clock it's too
much pressure I think so yeah
um yeah that was a very good game
also
um but yeah I I got a little bit lucky
there
Notre back you continue to play well man
it's it's impressive to watch I had a
question because yesterday you maybe
didn't start out as on form as you seem
to be now does sometimes it help to get
in a little bit of trouble early in an
event where you have to win on command
and go to Armageddon in order to find it
against Wesley today you seemed right on
form and talk a little bit about how
maybe the momentum carried over to today
yeah it's yeah of course uh in
yesterday's match I I
uh I didn't believe like I have a good
chance to beat Wesley on demand
but uh yeah after I managed it just I
just uh I just uh got the confidence and
uh after that and I just
um
just go everything is going smoothly so
far and
yeah it's very
um
very hard to keep the momentum every
every time but
uh in uh in some days you you get the
you know you get the
week three and and that's that's how I'm
taking the matches
yeah it was really an awesome day of
Chess and you continue in the winners
bracket now the back you're gonna face
either Magnus or Fabi tomorrow in the
winners final any preferences of who
you'd like to play
um um I I played two matches against
Fabi
so yeah as so I think I I didn't even
played
uh a single match against Magnus so I
would of course
um
uh we lost him at such a critical moment
just as he was about to answer but I
think he was going to say that he'd like
to play against Magnus because he hasn't
played him yet in the Champions Chester
and that is a Champions mentality right
there we will be back with a round for
Action from Magnus versus Fabi on the
other side of this break
[Music]
thank you
move over mittens there's a new Top Dog
in town
G the bernadoodle might be an
international master of fetch but chess
lessons with his dad Gotham chess aren't
really sticking
host of his own Public Access TV show
wish boy knows a thing or two about the
most dramatic moment in chess history
a baller through and through buddy
buckets is moving his game from the
basketball court to the chess board
watch out
pinky practices chess from the inside of
his mom's handbag on wolfstock's law
campus don't judge a dog by its Diamante
caller
honchick learned chess from his dad GM
Lavon aronian he has never lost to
another dog at chess and certainly won't
lose to you
this July the possumness is Unleashed on
chess.com
we have one more rapid game coming up in
division one between Magnus Carlson and
Fabiano caruana meanwhile division two
and division three it's a wrap for the
day Kathy give us the big update and
what are we looking ahead right Tanya I
heard you guys were talking about
garakowski Legend and he is fighting to
get his seat in the first division he
will face Sam Sabian tomorrow today
winners semifinals he has Incredible
Journey so far he beat Jeffrey Zhong and
Teresa sahakyan and Tanya I'm looking
forward to see these two matches as well
and danis lazovic is gonna gonna be a
fire for sure
it's gonna be fire reaction in that one
but we also have some big matchups in
the losers round two right all these
players still have chances to come back
they just need to play all the games and
beat their opponents Chef Jeffrey Zhang
Jose Martinez and David paravian
alongside with others they still have
chances to come back
its store points prize money and the
golden ticket to the next division one
of the Champions chess store on the line
for these players who are fighting in
division two right now uh some big names
there big moment for FFL gatakamski can
he do it can he fight his way into
division one and Katie you've got some
updates from division three as well
that's right in division three we do
have two finalists already and there's
gonna be Yankee and mainly those are the
winners in this bracket they gonna fight
tomorrow and is there a favorite in that
one
I would go you young guys is for sure
the favorite rating favorite he has been
playing so much just lately but you
never know because also mainly had such
an incredible run at this event yeah not
just this event you yangi fresh from an
incredible run in Dubai in the global
chess league as well and he continues
that feisty run in division three but
right now it is back to division one as
we go into that final round four Magnus
Carlsen taking on Fabiano caruana he
needs just a draw Fabi has to win on the
van Fabi plays with the black pieces
boys can he do it
well it's been done before we keep
saying that it's not easy to win with
black and force Armageddon but haven't
we've seen it twice now in the event
yeah so a third time's a charm it's
mathematically possible well
mathematically I like that answer
what about practically side when you're
playing against Magnus no chance we said
no chance in Notre Beck beat Wesley
itari Saga B Jordan
saying there's a chance thank you Lloyd
Christmas
likes the new white Black's been scoring
really well actually so far in the
Champions chess tour this season and in
Rapid chess it's all about the opening
if Abby can get a position that's really
tense he will back himself to at least
post some questions to Magnus but uh
getting out of the opening with a
playable position with winning chances
that's going to be difficult especially
when Magnus starts with one E4 he always
goes this way when he's happy with just
a draw with white
but is it psychologically easier for
Fabi to know that you know draw is as
bad as losing so you just go all out he
doesn't have an option in this one a
draw and a loss is the same result so he
knows that he has to take those complex
decisions when the time comes
well I think as we see he's spending a
lot of time thinking here and he's just
literally trying to work out what move
can I play to give myself chances
because uh but yeah and this is risky he
knows that oh this is really risky I
mean he knows
they're like what's wrong with my
opening
okay it's risky basically is risky and
but I mean I think this is probably the
white the wise choice right Danny I mean
and David you've got to play something
unconventional you've probably got to
take uh you know some risks but I like
what Magnus is doing here this this line
is known to be uh a bit of a problem for
black
um it's gonna be so hard isn't it to get
a playable position and again someone
with so much knowledge that it's
straightforward for weight that's part
of the problem too there's not a lot of
places to trick Magnus yeah and the
problem is Magnus employs this opening
quite a lot as himself as black when he
wants to win uh when he wants to keep
the game alive so he knows exactly how
to shut things down from the white side
and wow fabi's setting up in what we
almost call a hippopotamus uh formation
something you know a lot about Simon
I've played this position as black many
times so there I am saying it's really
dodgy but I play it all the time and uh
what white generally does here is move
the Knight next to the king and this is
a really annoying system actually if you
just shut for that night over and it's
actually kind of known to be a bit of a
problem with the what we call the
hippopotamus black setup is is meant to
resemble a hippopotamus
not sure I see it but that's what it's
called and
um yeah and it's it's it's maybe what
what Fabiano has to try at least he
keeps all the pieces on the board this
way and that's important but Magnus
knowing exactly how to approach this and
moving the Knight to the right Square
unsurprisingly you mentioned it's called
The Hippopotamus uh science because if
you imagine to be in the C Pawn which
were in the original place it feels like
a hippo sort of Leaning out of the water
you know with the head up but now with
this BNC Pawn Advanced the hippo is
leaped out and it's suddenly a very
active position what kind of animal is
that I mean you got the colors right do
you want to draw an animal here at that
time there's only one game going we're
gonna get into plenty of analysis I'll
draw give me a I don't know I kind of
wish this Pawn was back like a Chinese
dragon you know like uh like on the the
new year yeah there's a little bit of a
snake thing going on here it's more of a
dragon in a hip hop
wow I don't know I have seen them you
know really short chat said dragon do
exist yeah some of those Friday nights
I've had you know so and
um but it's quite risky of black pushing
the pawn to H square but okay I mean
we've got a position aren't we we've got
a position where everything is on the
board and that's that's uh what black
needs to do keep the tension Simon Harry
the h1's made an appearance Magnus
pushing forward ah this is a move I hate
facing because the problem is and I've
had this happen to me so many times
black yeah H6 played on the live board
but you always have to now think about
H5 G5 and then a sacrifice on G5 and
this might not be possible here but it
just lurks for the rest of the game and
whenever this happens white gets two
pawns but also an attack and uh you know
it's just it's just horrible that that's
there forever and that's why I don't
like the system so much I mean the
analysis shows that it's probably
possible for a white to play for right
now oh wow there's not even any any
worse necessarily than the advantage the
White House on the Whiteboard after this
shows Bishop before so yeah it's um
again I'll say this that if you're
looking for an opportunity to create
a crazy A crazy mess you kind of have to
give your opponent an advantage when
you're playing Magnus Carlson right so
Bobby has given Magnus an advantage it's
going to be a little bit of a mess
um if Magnus is on Forum he's going to
put this away and there will be no arm
again right but at least you've created
a bit of a spicy position here
I took all one question on my mind I see
H4 on the board who's playing for a win
who has to win this game on demand is it
white or black this is the best thing
about Magnus Carlson's Jazz this is the
reason we all you know love watching him
and fell in love when he beat uh LaVon
aronian in the last round of this first
thing field cup when he didn't have to
play for a win and could have taken a
draw and he did it anyway because I
think that that's the mindset that has
allowed him to be as good as he is that
he doesn't he doesn't think the way
people do as far as being afraid of risk
or what they're afraid of losing right
he just objectively
you know again if Bobby offered a draw
here he'll take the draw but he's not
going to play for a draw he's going to
play for the win and uh probably get the
dub along the way not Danny I have to
just say a very quick story I remember
the British championships last round I
was sitting next to this guy on board
one and he only needed a draw to take
the British championships right which is
a massive title and he's there and he's
playing an international Master
dangerous guy and uh the international
Master thinks he's having a nice day off
offers this guy a draw and we all think
yeah okay this guy's gonna be British
champion now what does this player said
he says no I'm like what's wrong with
this guy he's gonna get like 5 000
pounds the British championships and he
turns down the draw and we all know who
that is isn't it this chap here yeah
against Gary Lane and I'm just like how
how confident and brave is that to you
know British championships the same we
dream of becoming and he did you win or
it was a draw eventually eventually but
he turned down the draw and it's like
the only way he can't become British
champion is by losing so I was young and
dumb and I thought I could conquer the
world but I like it but were you young
dumb and Brooke
wow that makes a lot of sense I love
that story because you know great minds
think alike now we know why you and
Magnus are such good friends both of
them refusing draws in these kind of
situations makes a lot of sense it is
the Champions mentality and Magnus here
not playing for a draw he's getting the
kind of positions he wants but this also
gives Fabi the chance that he's looking
for
it does yeah I mean it's very hard to do
anything in this position as black
except for you've got to wait and you've
got to take your opportunity but um you
know okay well Magnus has thrown a pawn
forward first
um and this is gonna create a change in
the position because uh you probably
have to take on D5 something like that
but uh I don't know what do you think
it's painful because I was just thinking
the same thing you kind of have to take
otherwise the D6 Pawn will be lost and
that's exactly what Magnus wants he's
going to take with the E Pawn and then
put the bishop on C2 and he's going to
play H5 and he's gonna Crush you maybe
he'll play 95 so I was shaking my head
and you turned to me because I was like
it's a painful move because oh wait wait
Magnus took with the bishop so I'm
missing something
that's not what he wants maybe this was
too risky maybe he didn't even want to
give up a pawn it still looks like a
fearsome attack but yeah take him with
the bishop that's a uh Twist on the
narrative that we've been peddling for
the last few minutes Bishop takes porn I
guess if he takes with the Queen the D6
Pawn just Falls yeah I guess that's yeah
look he does it I was sometimes it's so
obvious you can't see it right in front
of you right he just takes with the
Queen the D6 Pawn
is falling and what's funny is even if
you objectively like are giving some
sort of chances for black like this is
like this is like a crushing blow for
Fabi right because there's no world
where he's not groveling uh and hoping
for a draw if the Queens come off yeah
at the very best black can hope for
compensation with the bishop pair maybe
but compensation is not the same as
creating serious winning chances and
yeah it's not obvious at all Bishop
takes D5 I don't think it would be on my
radar just looks counter-intuitive to
give up a bishop for a night especially
when the position becomes open but if
you win a pawn in the process
yeah these guys they see everything all
the options every time
anywhere that Fabi can uh hold on to
that pawn on D6
looks tough the problem for black is you
would love to jump the Knight out the
way and unleash an attack there we go
against White's Queen with your light
squared Bishop but you needed to protect
your Bishop on B7 and A5 is not
necessarily the best square and there we
go we will see okay not yet a trade of
Queens it will happen on fabi's terms
and at least the Black Knight on C4 is
active but that pawn on B2 is going to
be protected and Magnus doesn't have too
many weaknesses Magnus moving very
quickly isn't he I mean uh it's some
difficult decisions here I mean maybe
black has some counter play here though
as you said David he's got two Bishops
if he can um get his Pawn back you know
then it is probably going to be better
you know with uh this break B4 that
could be coming up to try to unleash the
dark Square Bishop I mean it looks uh it
looks like there's still a lot of play
left here to me okay uh stylistic Choice
here I'm gonna put it to the uh to the
panel oh okay just as uh he plays rookie
eight I was gonna say in this position
is it an option do you take on B2 and at
least change the imbal of pieces here
you would give up one piece but you're
gonna get one of the Rooks back
dangerous postpones maybe he said no he
didn't go for this Fabiano I think it
was a great idea and I think that might
have been the dynamic imbalance that
that he needed I I a good call out David
I think he should have yeah it's just
okay evaluation Bar says still level but
changing the nature of the position is
often a good thing and okay he missed
that and now after B3 the Black Knight
is forced to the edge of the board it's
most likely going to jump in here but
white is just going to defend this pawn
and everything's covered at least for
now
yeah I will say that and I and again you
know it's normal to be frustrated when
you're down a game playing Black against
the best player of all time but I feel
like fabi's looked a little dejected at
the start of this game he took a bunch
of time on move one he's kind of like
this is an uphill battle and and feeling
a little frustrated and maybe maybe he
just
didn't see that didn't look for that
opportunity I mean it's possible he's
been the player who's been pushing the
last two games he had the edge in game
two and in game three wasn't able to
convert it to an advance to a winning
Advantage but this one as well the
opening he's trying the Queens are off
the board but is this like a queenless
middle game and is there still hope for
Fabi here I think it's definitely hope
right I mean like you've still got two
Bishops you're Brooks are active
um you can try to open up the bishop
even more for that last line uh but you
know and uh you know the game is alive
right the game's definitely alive and it
could be a lot more dead than this uh
when you're playing they're like Magnus
he can kill it straight away I was just
thinking these guys have played so much
right I mean Fabio fabby's played Magnus
Carson for the world championships do
you think fabby's like a bit annoyed
with Magnus it's like I'm not that bad
it's gone again it's not oh my God how
do I beat this guy keeps he keeps doing
me in I mean I mean or is he more like
oh I really want to you know play Magnus
and actually you know get my against him
I you know I wonder which one it is I
don't know players like Fabi they
probably wish they were born in a
different generation I mean
right and he'd probably a fair if it
wasn't of Magnus and you know he
probably would be world champion at some
point you know I mean we've said this
before but he didn't lose the game in
classical chess to Magnus Carlson in the
world championship right and had
opportunities game six in game eight
right I mean so I think uh definitely
one of those there's a lot of people who
can argue that you know how many people
would have had an NBA championship if
not going up against Jordan right but
that is what it is and I think Fabi I
think Bobby maybe looks at the chances
now right the world has been shaken up
with Magnus Carlson
declining to defend the title so who
knows what is in Fabiano caruana's
future he's been playing phenomenal
chess
um number three in the world currently
just won a gcd event as well just yeah
well it's funny too it's the finals
regardless of how this works out Bobby
has been in two finals in the CCT right
but both both times he got there through
the winners bracket
one time he was in the winners bracket
throughout but the second time he did
fall to the elimination bracket and then
rose again ah okay okay he faced him
twice oh that's right that's right okay
yeah I was remembering the Hikaru
Nakamura match oh that was such a
fantastic run for Fabi staying in the
winners bracket but a heartbreaking one
in the end a witch Hikaru eventually won
and Bobby here playing aggressively he
brings his Rook into the game the two
Bishops that you were talking about the
C Pawn for white for Magnus can be a bit
of weakness uh David you've been all day
we've been focusing on nights on the
edge but that Black Knight on A3 that
can be a power piece for black hair yeah
this night if it ever jumps in it's
gonna come with power you can imagine it
if the Brooks will disappear coming in
to win some white pawns if it ever jumps
in to this Square it's going to be
really scary so Magnus pretty much has
to leave a rook on C1 to keep this
Knight caged and if we do a bit of math
mathematics maths maths maths whatever
it's called
then the white Rook is more powerful
technically than the Knight and uh if we
cancel those out it's a big gain for
black so yeah Tanya it's definitely not
over sure I quite like Black's position
yeah I mean if I was going to pick a
side I'd pick black because uh you got
the pressure and I don't think Magnus
looks that comfortable I mean he's not
he's not got the teapot out yet he
hasn't got his leg out yet you know he's
uh and it's just like black has the
pressure yeah he's got the two Bishops
yep I mean there are many ways white can
defend this clearly but you know it's
still it's still nice to have that
pressure at least you know in a
musculine situation I think there's good
chances here you know I agree Bobby took
a sip of water and quickly responded to
Rook E3 with Rook d8 which apparently
the computer didn't like I'm wondering
if there's some sort of hidden hidden
resource hidden tactic the bar is
creepily climbing up steadily and slowly
I feel like this must be some inhuman
computer tactic here because Bobby
played it instantly they both body
language suggests that Bobby's getting
more comfortable not Magnus and um like
what is the tactic on Rook d8 that we're
not seeing yeah so the engine
suggestions we see in front of us it
says that Rook takes Rook is by far
White's best move here other moves are
fine they keep the balance but Rook
takes rook and we're gonna see it
actually on the board but what's the
idea why is it Bishop E5 maybe I guess I
think maybe Knight to even five
attacking attacking the forces the
Bishops off the forces the bishop to
take the Knight because of F7 and of
course Magnus finds it immediately
immediately so yeah on the board and if
you force one of the Bishops to depart
then suddenly white I think here has a
clear Advantage clear X report and now
this night you can tell probably missed
that too the way he just yeah he that
was not a it's like uh and like because
now it's Ops Code Bishops too which only
increases why it's drawing chances I
think uh yeah it's just a Pity as well
this Rook has no good Retreat squares if
you step the whole way back this night
can capture this Pawn because I think
maybe he was banking on this pin this
skewer but the Knight can jump out the
way hit a loose piece I wonder if that's
what he missed at the end I think that
might be it might have been what do you
missed can we back up then to see so if
if the computer gives white The Edge
because of Fabiano's Rook e to d8 what
was the move there because I agreed with
Simon momentum was going farby's way the
bishop here looks good for black what
was the move here I'm going to be a bit
naughty and check the computer it says
C4 uh C4 yeah maybe not the most obvious
move but it does support The Rook with a
pawn and at least if the Rook trade
happens this Pawn will help the Black
Knight get into the game potentially and
might paralyze or at least slow down
some of the white pieces boom not
necessarily easy but yeah unfortunately
a Miss from Fabiano and this is the uh
ruinous position he's left with Knight
to E5 and this Pawn is dropping or
he'll have to part with his Bishop
yeah Magnus big favorite now surely
massive fragrance especially if you just
need a draw yeah I mean uh
that's a big move wasn't it Knight to E5
yeah I mean massive move there and I I I
I don't even know how you can keep
things rolling now really against
magnus's
and if you're forced to trade that
Bishop for the night that's all dreams
over yeah
Bishops it's it's like
smelly has an aroma yeah Smelly Cat what
are they feeding you yeah oh that's the
question what has Magnus been eating
because he's been on this crazy farm
with the nine out of nine in the grand
Chester and then winning his first match
did it surprise you how critical he was
of his quality of play on day one here
nah not at this point I know Magnus too
well and actually all of the top players
it tends to be a thing that they very
rarely Revel in their wins they just
forget the losses or the the small
inaccuracies that they could have made
uh that they did make that's kind of
what sticks with them they're
perfectionists all of them and that's
why they're so good that's why they are
champions uh but yeah I want to see the
celebrations more I want to see them
saying yeah I played like a boss in this
in this game and okay there we see the
trade and it's not a happy trade I think
Magnus will say he played better today
do you know I was just looking at his
position and I was thinking what happens
if Rook D2 sorry I took a jump in the
chest but I was just thinking if white
puts the bishop on F6 and just puts a
rook on d8 it's just like it's actually
quite simple right I mean you can you
know black can't do anything uh so it's
it's so so horrible
playing well I mean that's such a good
Bishop isn't it and uh this Rook is
gonna be very painful to Black and
Unstoppable that was the only activity I
could see black attempting to get and if
we were talking about lights on the rim
are dim Knights on the edge what was it
nice and the edge fall off the head nice
on the nights on the yeah Knights on the
side
because Bishop six once played you know
threats of Bishop to E7 now black has a
Pawn on C5 on a dark square that could
be right for the picking Black's the
Knight on the edge of the board almost
trapped yeah it's just stinky too many
things yeah and maybe the king can even
come into just too much isn't there too
much going on here what does this should
be six because Here Comes Bishop E7 how
do you deal with the uh the parliament
oh Magnus didn't play it I wonder if he
first just stopping the black Rook from
uh stepping down to the second rank nice
of control type of move at this point it
feels like anything is good enough to
kind of maintain the advantage
converting will be another thing but he
doesn't need to convert how do I get how
do you get that night out you know how
many sayings can we get with the Knights
on the rim so nice and the rim are dim
the what's the other one night's on the
edge fall off the Hedge fall off the
head Knights on the side I cannot abide
I cannot abide I like it nice on yeah
[Laughter]
all right wow but that's not a happy
night there that's definitely a donkey
as we've been calling out with the moves
that we've seen the changes in the
position and uh Magnus uh creating some
tension on the queen side how should
Fabi react to this it's a tough one it's
like Sophie's Choice here the white
Bishop is threatening to actually come
back and hit that Black Knight on the
edge of the board so if you're not
careful you might just lose a piece but
then again you don't really want to
block down that flank that side of the
board because your knight will be
stranded there forever White Knight is
about to enter D5 a nice supported
Outpost
everything it's just all these small
things adding up and okay he's jumped in
finally but it feels like again Simon
your idea of the white Rook getting in
if the black Rook ever leaves the open D
file is uh that's going to be the killer
blow okay the knight's out but it's
coming at the cost of another Pawn
this does not spell uh good news for
Fabiano you can tell on the body
language again as experts here in the
studio that's expert body language yeah
I think I think Magnus will play a three
and then if the Rook takes A2 he's gonna
he's gonna try to land his Rook on the
eighth rank somewhere yeah okay we play
Z5 a little more direct even though it
allows 94 I guess he'll just take the
eight bun and for Fabi right now is this
frustrating just this position and this
outcome you want to push you want to
fight for a game and then you have this
one slip allowing magnets to trade in
the center how difficult is it for
Fabian is he truly motivated to try this
position I don't know that we're looking
at the most motivated Fabiano caruano
we've ever seen um I think I think he
kind of knows that this one is uh is the
writings on the wall but also he's not
gonna offer a draw because Magnus will
decline the draw like Magnus won't even
take the draw at this point he doesn't
want to be disrespected like that that's
what I've made in two and there's a
Checkmate coming here even if the even
if the Knight takes the bishop it's over
of course so anyway yeah I don't think
he's that motivated but I think Bobby
will be back tomorrow I mean you you
called out that uh he has been in the
losers bracket before so we'll see it um
I'm I I don't know what I'm more excited
for tomorrow we shouldn't start
previewing it yet but I think this one I
think this one is pretty much over Bobby
not offering a draw because because
Magnus won't take it yeah three pawns
down it's just uh hopeless at this point
unfortunately I gotta hope for a blender
haven't you so and uh one last trick one
last track yeah that's what he's got to
try for yeah definitely but I mean he
he's played so well today Magnus hasn't
he I mean yeah yes I mean what can you
do when you're playing someone who who's
playing like a computer you know he's
playing unbelievable Jason I think
Fabiano's play hasn't been that bad I
mean it's been been pretty good I mean
he's had some half chances but uh not
ever really winning chances at all in
any of the games but he's played he's he
seems to play okay yeah I don't think
he's played that badly no I think he's
playing very well yeah it honestly was
that the first game yeah the first game
where Magnus won the preparation battle
Magnus chose a weapon that Fabi didn't
see coming went right into the heart of
of you know the type of position that a
lot of people avoid against karwana in
those white sides of those open
Sicilians he got the dub and then after
that it's like now I'm just in shutdown
mode right match strategy for the win
and look at that Magnus locking up the
cage for that black king not allowing a
Trader pawns not allowing the black king
to centralize itself and still mating
threats persist this one is I think in
its final stages you can tell body
language he's getting ready to resign
well he's mentally he's been resigned
for a while
and where he can take the bishop Connie
if he wants to play on a little bit but
the White Knight is also just dominating
the the what the black Bishop as well so
I mean uh if black can somehow get his
Bishop I'm really scraping them I'm
really just scraping the bottle here
whatever the saying is scraping the
bottom of the barrel barrel that's the
one yeah
looking at picking up a third Pawn in
the position attacking that night you
really can't do much except trade and
three pawns up is what it's going to be
four in a minute the support uh
disappears and we go four Pawn Advantage
maybe we'll go for some stalemate idea I
was just about to say that that if
there's a blunder of Rook A8 I think
maybe there's a still be a trick I think
rookie Thor and Rook takes Bishop is is
pretty I know the king gets out okay I'm
trying to lose it I'm doing my best you
know so but uh I mean he's yeah he can
body language you don't have to be an
expert even to to work this one out
right it's okay I mean it's like
sometimes it is uh it is what it is when
you're when you're watching greatness
right it's like we always want every
match to end in a Armageddon comeback
fashion simulatory turizaga or Notre
back but you know we still got uh about
20 000 people watching across twitching
YouTube and wherever else you might be
people like watching Magnus do Magnus
things repetition there a Magnus takes
it because it gets him the match Wick
tree what a match performance this has
been by the world number one taking down
wall number three Fabiano caruana tough
day for Fabi which puts him in the
elimination bracket Magnus continues his
run in to the Winner's bracket and
perhaps today he is feeling better about
the quality of his play it was quite a
convincing win there David by Magnus
yeah it was smooth in the end and Magnus
didn't take that risk to try and win it
was a draw but that was enough and it
was actually Fabby here in this position
who when he let the chances slip Rook to
E3 the last move from White and a bit of
a blunder unfortunately Rook to d8 just
careless and neglecting White's
resources C4 would have kept the game
very very tense with the idea that now
you can recapture with a pawn and
Black's Knight is back in the game
anything was still possible route to d8
as we saw a bit earlier did allow a
trade and this was the Hammer Blue
Knight to E5 attacking The Rook
attacking the pawn and destroying
Black's winning chances
chess is brutal sometimes the most
natural looking ones are the ones that
get you into trouble and that's what we
saw in that end game which means that
Magnus Carlsen continues his run in the
winners bracket and he will be playing
against
Fabiano caruana and Levon aronian go
down into elimination bracket and these
are moments that you're glad that this
is a double elimination because you
don't want to lose Autumn players like
Lev and Fabi you don't want to lose out
on Lev or fobby or their opponents who
they're facing tomorrow Wesley so of
course gonna be one of those guys anyway
yes I can't wait for for both brackets
tomorrow and uh it'll be fun it'll be a
lot of fun and right now we're gonna
have fun as the winner is joining us
Magnus Carlson after his win against
Bobby Magnus congratulations
thank you
Magnus yesterday you won in three games
but you were quite critical of your play
are you happier with how you played
today
yeah I think my my uh plan was a lot
better today uh I think the first game
was really really good
um like I I think I played really
um
really well my my brain was also also
working well in in a position that was
far from easy to play because my king
was in the in the center so that's uh
that I think was a really good game uh
the second game was kind of four but
um the third was okay uh and then the
fourth I think I played a little bit
carelessly in the opening and he
actually had a very decent position
where uh I think it was not really worse
but then he made one careless move uh
and um then I just took over
um or I got well I got in D5 and after
after that I can I can never really
never really lose so uh even though like
he has waste to serve equalized the game
there is no way you could play for a win
after that
first game it was very impressive to
watch how much of that was preparation
um
yeah in in Zara in the blitz so I was
kind of surprised
that he he was he was very surprised I
don't know maybe he had some small idea
which she didn't want to show or was not
so sure what to play I wasn't yeah I
wasn't sure about about that
um but uh
I mean I had to to think on my own
pretty pretty early
um but um I felt like I understood it
pretty pretty well so I was very happy
with that
Magnus tomorrow you're moving on to play
the young Notre back of do sator of a
world rapid Champion how excited do you
get for matches like that against
players who a lot of people are looking
at as you know who knows what happens in
five ten years potential World
Championship level Talent so how excited
do you get for matchups like that
he's worst he was championed in 2021 and
I took it back in 2022.
you're right I'm sorry but uh but anyway
how excited are you for that that
matchup
I think it's uh it's a very good uh good
um I have to say he played an amazing
game today the first
uh the first game like that's an opening
I never I've never seen before
um and um he is very very good
practically so
um a very different kind of player from
from whom I played today
and uh Magnus you've been playing one A6
quite a lot recently title Tuesday and
yesterday as there been a reason that
you've been playing uh this opening
anything particular or just there that
you felt like it
actually Peter just told me like a while
ago that he'd been checking A6 for fun
and he said he wasn't that bad so
um
we were like briefly discussing what to
play against Jordan and then I just said
it I'll play six uh because he's
he's so well prepared but I thought as
long as I got to play play chess against
him it's it's fun but then actually in
the in the second game where I went
um A6 and then C6 like he actually went
for one of the really really one of the
most dangerous plants there so he
clearly checked something even though
and Magnus it's been a really busy few
weeks for you but you're looking super
relaxed during this tournament what's
your trick have you been spending the
days before the games
um you know today uh I went for I went
for a swimming just before the first
game which I think helped me a lot
um
yeah but today it's so you know uh it's
so cold outside that actually it was
warmer in the in the sea done in there
which uh and it was like rain which was
it was nice
um but uh but yeah as I said like
yesterday I was retired but today I feel
feel fine and I and the play showed it
as well
and Michael you you have quite a lot of
chairs in your room we noticed uh uh
you're not gonna sell any of them on
eBay for your fans at all or give them
any away as prizes
no uh whenever I am on the rare
occasions that I I do streams I need the
chairs for the idiots in the back
which uh
one of them in the past for sure
well you were talking about that in the
studio Magnus we really appreciate your
time talking to us thank you so much for
sharing your thoughts
thank you all the best for tomorrow
Magnus Carlsen continues in the Winner's
bracket we've got a big day coming up
there uh let's take a look at our aim
chess rapid bracket and there we have it
we will start with the losers
quarterfinals Fabiano caruana taking on
Wesley so another Clash of big names and
then Levon aronian playing against the
underdog Eduardo duruzaga who was
extremely impressive today in the
winners final it is the big clash
between not a bag and Magnus Carlsen
what do you think about that one uh
Danny starting at the top Notre Beck uh
taking on Magnus I obviously bespoke and
Magnus of course the Triple Crown uh
owner when he won the world rapid back
from from notorbeck but the youngster
has won a World rapid Championship he's
uh he's obviously a talent that we all
have our eyes on and I can't wait to see
what him and Magnus get into I love how
Magnus said that you know he won in 21
and then I took it back he made wait to
tell me that and I was sort of referring
Loosely once a world champion always a
world champion but Magnus wasn't going
to let that slide and I like it I think
he's ready for tomorrow he's ready for
tomorrow and Simon notabec is ready for
tomorrow because he said it himself that
he wants to play Magnus which is a
matchup that you're excited about well
that one's going to be really really
juicy I mean they're both fantastic
players but then the All-American clash
as well I mean Wesley so is playing uh
you know against
um there we go Fabiano I nearly forgot
for a second there been a long day but
that's going to be really exciting both
those players played many times before
and hard to predict yeah I'm also
looking forward to a tourism against
Iranian Underdog for short arizaga but
he surprised us today with some
fantastic chess and yeah so much more
action guaranteed tomorrow
it's going to be epic and it's going to
be a fun day of Chess naughty back up to
Central potential future world champion
taking on the gold Magnus Carlson and
that's one match you don't want to miss
also a big losers bracket coming up it's
gonna be super exciting we can't wait
for the action we'll see you tomorrow
whoa whoa
[Music]
Agnes takes it because it gets him the
match with three what a match
performance this has been by the world
number one
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you